So, herzlich willkommen, die 29er. Wir sind, wie alle wissen,
ein politischer Podcast. Und jetzt hast du mir gerade gesagt.
Was ist denn das für eine offizielle Einleitung?
Ja, sehr offiziell, denn wir müssen jetzt dich abholen.
Die Hörer wissen schon Bescheid, aber du offenbartest mir gerade die größte
Story aller Zeiten, unserer Zeiten.
Die Chat-Story, die Chat-Gruppen-Story, die Houthi-Gruppe, die The Atlantic,
Jeffrey Goldsmith oder wie er heißt. Du bist gar nicht richtig im Bilde.
Naja, ich habe die Nachrichten dazu gehört im Radio, hatte aber keine Lust es
zu vertiefen, weil ich dachte, es ist alles so typisch, unterstreicht nochmal,
wie chaotisch dieser Haufen ist.
Und dann wollte ich aber jetzt auch nicht so ganz tief reingehen,
weil ich dachte, wer weiß, was er morgen anstellt.
Ja, es kitzelt mir natürlich in den Rücken, in den Füßen und in den Händen,
die jetzt diese ganze Geschichte von der Antike an zu erzählen.
Ich würde sozusagen die, ich war in Griechenland, Story rausschmeißen und sagen,
damals in Urzeiten, als die Demokratie erfunden wurde und die Amerikaner meinten,
zum ersten Mal eine Frau, könnten wir uns das vorstellen?
Und dann hieß es, nein, denn diese Frau betreibt einen E-Mail-Server.
Und sehr viele Republikaner, die damals noch nicht wussten, dass sie irgendwann mal Magajaner werden,
haben sich erbost darüber gezeigt, wie das denn sein könne, dass eine Frau einen
privaten E-Mail-Server betreibt und dort Staatsgeheimnisse verschickt,
vielleicht auf andere private E-Mail-Server, wie auch immer.
Das muss doch alles ins Archiv.
Wir haben doch hier Bürokratie, die sich darum kümmert, dass es alles ordentlich abläuft.
Wenn der amerikanische Präsident reist, bauen wir doch extra Zelte auf in der
Suite, in der er abhörsicher kommunizieren kann.
In jedem Ministerium gibt es kleine Kammern, wo es heißt, wenn sie die Botschaft
anrufen müssen, gehen sie in diesen Raum, machen sie das nicht über ihr eigenes Handy und so weiter.
Und dann stellt sich raus, es gibt eine Chatgruppe aus 18 hochrangigen,
gewählten oder ihren Beamten und die chatten miteinander und der eine ist sogar
gerade anwesend in Russland, in Moskau.
Man fragt sich so, hat man dafür nicht eigentlich ein Börderphone?
Wie kann er denn seine Signalinstallation, die sowieso schon illegal ist,
auch noch in Russland aktiv betreiben.
Also wirklich die beste Geschichte ever. Alle machen sich drüber lustig.
Und wir wollen es auch nochmal drüber lustig machen.
Denn Peter Neumann, Experte am King's College, wird immer angerufen,
wenn irgendwas ist mit Terrorismus oder drohend oder wie auch immer.
Oder eben auch, wie geht es so zu in der Sicherheitscommunity.
Ja, und was ist gegen die Houthis geplant.
Genau, alle die Fragen. Wird als Gast notfallmäßig eingeladen in den Paul-Ronsheimer-Podcast.
Und erstaunlicherweise hat Paul-Ronsheimer Zeit,
Obwohl er doch auch als Notfallgast zum gleichen Thema, zu dem er einen Notfallgast
in seinem Podcast hat, Notfallgast im Podcast von Miggi Beisenherz ist,
der an dem Tag schon einen Podcast gemacht hatte.
Also das erste Mal, herzlich willkommen liebe Hörer, Sie hören mich gerade zum
zweiten Mal, das ist ja ungewöhnlich, aber ich erkläre es Ihnen kurz, es ist etwas passiert.
Also alle sind durch den Wind.
Aber du hast dich rausgehalten. Genau das habe ich mitbekommen und da war mir
klar, okay, das hält jetzt vier Stunden an und das ist wirklich, okay,
aber du weißt es, das ist jetzt viel Tamtam, vielleicht kann man später nochmal
eine Netflix-Komödie draus machen, aber ich dachte, es ist nicht wert,
dass ich mich jetzt da drin versenke, weil ich glaube, dass am Ende der Erkenntniswert
der bleibt, den man vorher schon hatte.
Es ist eine Chaos-Truppe, die offenbar nicht die einfachsten Dinge,
die man eben beachten sollte, wenn man solche Ämter hat, umsetzen kann.
Ja, wir reden heute sehr viel über den Bürokratieabbau und der geht dort so
weit, dass sie einfach, dass sie glauben, eine Chatgruppe reichen.
Ja, ich meine, wir haben ja immer diese Geschichte gehabt, dass man sagte, passt auf mit dem Trump.
Da gibt es dieses Flooding the Zone with Shit. Das heißt, Trump verkündet 50
Sachen am Tag und dann beschäftigen wir uns alle damit.
Das ist ja immer noch genauso festzustellen und zugleich gibt es aber dann diese
tausend Fauxpas und Patzer und da hat man aber auch natürlich so eine enorme
mediale Aufmerksamkeit drauf,
dass ich versuche mich immer wieder da auszuklinken, weil ich ja sonst auch
mich nur noch die ganze Zeit mit dem Newsticker beschäftigen müsste.
Ja, ich wollte eigentlich auch Adolescence gucken, aber habe es nicht geschafft,
weil ich Chatgruppe geguckt habe.
Siehst du, ich habe aber auch noch Adolescence nicht gesehen.
Aber hast du es auf dem Zettel? Also ich werde es gucken, weil das ständigt
ja doch ganz schön einzuschlagen in dieser Welt.
Sehr gut. Wir haben heute sehr unterschiedliche Themen. Der März war sehr aufregend.
Und bevor wir jetzt alle nur noch sagen, Flooding the Zone with Shit von Steve
Bannon ist sozusagen die Herangehensweise.
Stimmt, aber im Chaos steckt auch manchmal Ordnung, ohne dass jemand reingetan hat.
Es gibt auch eine Verantwortung der Beobachter.
Und ich habe heute Morgen Lanz und Precht gehört, Precht ist wohl jetzt in Berlin
auf der Bühne, aber in so einer Kunsthochschule oder irgendwo,
um dort Wittgenstein zu vertonen.
Und zwar mit diesem Anliegen nochmal zu verdeutlichen, was es heißt,
dass all die ontologischen Hirngespinste, es gäbe eine echte Welt,
nein, wir reden über sie und verfangen uns in diesem Gerede und so.
Und ich finde, es ist jetzt auch eine gute Zeit, um all die guten alten Theorien
und Vorstellungen, die man so hatte, bei denen es bisher immer hieß,
ach, das ist doch fantastisches Denken, das ist doch Quatsch.
Wenn ich in ein Auto steige, ist das doch ein echtes Auto.
Wenn ich gegen eine Wand fahre, dann war die Wand doch echt und so.
Und jetzt stellen wir aber plötzlich fest, ne, da kann so ganze Regierung fahren gegen Wände.
Und plötzlich, ne, da war doch gar keine Wand. Habt ihr was gesehen?
Also, wieso regen sich alle schon wieder über eine Wand auf?
Da war doch gar keine Wand.
Die Regierung ist nicht ein Totalschaden. Alles funktioniert und so, ja.
Und ich finde, jetzt ist die Gelegenheit, die Verantwortung der Zuschauerschaft wahrzunehmen.
Du plädierst ja auch immer zum Sehen. und nicht zum Schauen.
Und die alten, schon bestandenen und ein bisschen verlachten Theorien,
wie Wittgenstein oder dieser Hardcore-Konstruktivismus, die ganze Luhmann-Kram und so.
Ja, ich bin ja durchaus dafür, Wittgenstein und Luhmann ernst zu nehmen.
Beim radikal-konstruktivistischen Ansatz habe ich durchaus meine Probleme damit,
da wir ja so etwas wie Fakten durchaus kennen.
Also ich empfehle sehr das Buch Angst vor der Wahrheit von Paul Bogossian,
der ja diesen neuen Realismus geprägt hat.
Der sagt, es gibt doch schon wieder Fakten und ich war, es ist interessant,
dass du das ansprichst jetzt gerade, denn in Duisburg war ich eingeladen,
um über den Film Rashomon zu sprechen.
Das ist ja ein japanischer Klassiker, der Zeugenberichte eigentlich versammelt,
in eine Rahmenhandlung bettet und am Ende ist unklar, war es denn jetzt ein
Mord, ein Selbstmord, war es ein faires Duell, was auch immer.
Zeugenschaft zu einem Ereignis, das wir alle nicht kennen.
Ja und das wird sehr radikal konstruktivistisch gelesen, aber man kann glaube
ich auch nochmal den Punkt sehr stark machen, dass es durchaus dort Fakten gibt,
die unhintergeber sind und die auch von allen Positionen, die dort vertreten
werden, nicht geleugnet werden.
Und da ist vielleicht nochmal so ein Türöffner auch da, dass man ein bisschen
aus dem radikal-konstruktivistischen Anything-Goes dann rauskommt.
Aber ich glaube, dass wenn wir über die medialen Ereignisse reden und über eben
die Realität der Massenmedien, dann glaube ich, kommen wir gar nicht umhin,
das Konstruktivistische aufzufassen.
Denn das muss man ja gerade diesen Leuten, die das laufend betreiben,
wirklich zurufen oder schreien, dass das nicht die Realität ist,
die sie da täglich besprechen, sondern sie produzieren diese.
Genau, ganz wichtiger Unterschied, nur weil es unhintergehbare Wahrheiten gibt,
wie jede Energie, die wir hier benutzen oder verwenden, kommt ursprünglich von
der Sonne, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass das, womit wir den Alltag bestreiten,
diese Art unhintergehbare Wahrheit ist, die ohne weiteres Gerede als Faktum im Raum steht.
Sondern wir haben es ganz schön oft mit, mein Kind kommt mit einer entsprechenden
Note nach Hause, beschwert sich darüber, erzählt mir, wie es zu dieser Note
kam und ich glaube ihm dann.
Und dann steht es Aussage gegen Aussage gegen Aussage gegen Aussage und dann
hat man auch noch eigene Gedanken.
Also es ist ja wirklich alles drunter und drüber. Und so funktioniert ja Politik im Allgemeinen.
Jemand bringt eine Tatsache mit nach Hause, eine Tatsache und dann haben alle eine Meinung.
Ja und manchmal sehen die Tatsachen plötzlich anders aus. Denn dies ist ja auch
der Monat, in dem eine große Recherche veröffentlicht wurde zur Labortheorie.
Nämlich hat man herausgefunden, dass das Bundeskanzleramt, also Merkel und dann nachher auch Scholz,
früh Informationen vom BND hatten, dass zu 80, 85 Prozent man doch davon ausgehen
könnte, dass das Coronavirus im Labor entstanden ist.
Und wir erinnern uns, wer dies aussprach zuvor, galt als Verschwörungstheoretiker.
Also sofort ins Labor gebracht. Es war ja vollkommen plausibel,
dass dieses Virus nur dadurch entstehen kann, dass ein Chineser in eine Fledermaus beißt.
Und jetzt plötzlich hat man diese Recherche.
Es ist also über Jahre etwas unbekannt.
In der Schublade verschlossen gehalten worden.
Es wurde der Öffentlichkeit nicht
mitgegeben. Wir wissen jetzt immer noch nicht, war es das jetzt genau.
Man schweigt sich natürlich auch weiter dazu aus. Ich finde,
dass es nicht so eine richtig große Welle gemacht hat, diese Enthüllung,
also in gewissen Kreisen, die vielleicht drauf gewartet haben.
Aber die Leute haben aus Gründen keine Lust, wäre auch nochmal so ein schönes
Thema für den Ethikrat oder ich wünsche mir auch nochmal diese Faktchecker Podcast,
dass die sich dem auch nochmal annehmen, weil die waren sich ja zum Teil auch
unglaublich sicher, dass es auf jeden Fall kein Laborvirus sein kann.
Und da finde ich, ist es doch auch wieder interessant, also erstmal das Verhältnis
der Bürger zur Regierung,
dass man da einfach so jahrelang nicht gesagt bekommen hat, was da auch noch
sein kann und dass auch alle einfach so Glaubensbekenntnisse,
die ja auch nicht mehr wussten als wir alle,
also die auch nicht mit dem BND oder sonst was, einfach so Glaubensbekenntnisse
immer von sich gegeben haben und sagten, nein auf keinen Fall,
also wer das behauptet ist ein Verschwörungstheoretiker und da dachte ich immer,
ja woher wissen die das genau?
Und das waren ja zum Teil dieselben Leute, und das hat mich auch immer so besonders
stutzig gemacht, das waren ja zum Teil dieselben Leute, die den Chinesen sonst alles zutrauten.
Also die ja noch vor der chinesischen Kaffeemaschine warnten,
weil die das Smartphone und dann das Smart Home wird angegriffen und ausgespäht und was weiß ich.
Da dachte ich immer, macht mal ein bisschen runter mit der Panik.
Aber hier, ganz interessant, waren sich alle total sicher und wer das Gegenteil
angesprochen hat, war verrückt.
Ich finde vor allem interessant, dass wir hier, wenn wir jetzt wieder auf, was ist der Fakt?
Wir kommen, also ist jetzt, warum wir deshalb,
Wir diskutieren darüber und du sagst dann, ja schon, aber zu wenig.
Ja. Und da könnte man ja auch wieder fragen, ja genau, weil was sind genau,
warum sollte man genau darüber diskutieren?
Dass es aus dem Labor entstanden oder entfleucht sein könnte oder dass der BND
darüber wusste und so weiter.
Ich würde über die Geheimhaltung diskutieren und über die Rolle der Regierung
und der Presse und überhaupt, wie unsere öffentlichen Diskurse geführt werden.
Denn das war ja jetzt nicht der erste Fall.
Es ist ja doch interessant, dass es dann immer irgendeine größere Recherche gibt.
Also das zeigt ja erstmal, es funktioniert schon noch, es wird ja recherchiert.
Aber dann sagt man sich, ah ja, dann war das so. Ja, also ich erinnere dich
an Nord Stream 2, da war vollkommen klar am Anfang, das hat Putin in die Luft geschwenkt.
Man hat sich zwar als klar denkender Mensch überlegt, warum sollte er das tun,
warum sollte er sich nochmal so massiv selbst schaden, ist er verrückt?
Nun ja. Und dann stellte sich danach heraus, Bojan Panschewski hatte es recherchiert,
nee, aus der Ukraine kam es und man hat quasi im Westen, also Polen und vor
allem USA haben weggeschaut und gesagt, naja, alles drauf.
Und als das dann rauskam, sagte man, ja, ja, gut, also dann ist das jetzt so.
Das ist doch, also jetzt haben wir ja auch wieder lauter Szenarien,
die uns als, so wird es auf jeden Fall kommen, beschrieben werden,
die ich auch jetzt glauben muss.
Wenn das ja nächstes Jahr wieder ganz anders ist, dann sage ich einfach achselzuckend,
naja, gut, woran muss ich jetzt glauben?
Also das ist eigentlich so das Interessante, dass ich mich immer neu orientieren
muss, was muss ich jetzt glauben?
Aber das Interessante ist doch, am Ende wird es ja so sein, also angenommen
man kriegt es mal richtig aufgelöst, wird man sagen, ja, es gab einen Laborunfall, allerdings 2014.
Und 2014 war damit plötzlich, weil in Wuhan eben dieses Labor und dieser Viehmarkt
ist, ein Virus im Umlauf, das nicht
aufgefallen ist, weil es halt nur in irgendwelchen Tieren und so weiter.
Aber genau das Virus, das fünf Jahre vorher entfleuchte,
war halt das, was mutierte. Also
es ist ein Laborenfall, aber halt so indirekt. Es ist sozusagen alles.
Ich kann das nicht beurteilen. Ich gehe mich dann nur wirklich aus.
Von daher finde ich das auch eine wahnsinnig interessante Diskussion,
weil wir sie wieder so A, B, Schema A, Schema B führen,
während die eigentliche Wahrheit dann irgendwie so eine totale Verquickung von
allem ist, was eben wieder bedeutet, es ist eigentlich Chaos.
Und im Nachhinein nur retrospektiv ergibt sich irgendein Sinn.
Also man wird, wenn man es nachforscht, kommt man zu irgendwelchen Erkenntnissen.
Aber wir können nicht von Anfang an vermuten, dass irgendwo Intentionen dabei waren.
Also auch wenn es aus dem Labor kommt, war es trotzdem ein Unfall.
Ja, davon gehe ich aus.
Es wird jetzt kein Angriff gewesen sein von jemandem, der das bewusst und so
weiter, sondern irgendwie war es eine Verkettung von,
weshalb es auch witzig ist gestern war Professor Moritz hier in Frankfurt und
hat sich nochmal sehr darüber gefreut, dass ich so vehement für die Atombombe stritt mit dem Argument
wenn wir jetzt Panzer kaufen habe ich Angst davor, dass man sie einsetzt das
droht ja wohl bei einer Atombombe nicht und dann guckt er mich nur so an und sagt,
Also das sagen wir immer jetzt und dann bis morgen und dann.
Und so, also in der Hinsicht, auch was wir hier sagen, ist immer,
was ich sage, ist mit Vorwürfe.
Es ist ja eine interessante Frage, warum es so unter Verschluss blieb,
was da diplomatisch vielleicht lief, obwohl man die Information hatte.
Und das ist eine urdeutsche Debatte, dass man irgendwann noch mal China Vorwürfe
machen kann, dass sie das nicht richtig abriegeln oder was auch immer. Ja, schön und gut.
Aber hier haben wir es mit einer sehr deutschen Diskussion zu tun,
denn während alle in Aufregung waren,
gab es Theorien, auch von Leuten, die das mit Evidenz basiert und nicht nur
politisch überraten, sondern die Politik selbst sind, also BND und so.
Und trotzdem will ich nochmal sagen, ich habe ja auch jetzt häufiger dafür geworben,
so Szenarioplanung zu machen.
Also nicht immer so im Prinzip Hoffnung, hoffen wir mal, dass es gut geht,
Plan A und im Zweifel Plan B, sondern nein, wir legen ganz ernsthaft Plan A,
B, C und D in die Schublade und dann gucken wir mal, welchen wir brauchen.
In der Hinsicht bin ich schon dafür, dass der BND solche Sachen macht,
auch unter der Maßgabe sie nicht zu veröffentlichen.
Nur in dem Fall, ja, ich finde, du hast jetzt kritisiert, dass es ja noch nicht
so die große Welle macht.
Ich würde sagen, nee, ist doch eigentlich gut, dass wir jetzt Corona mal nicht
immer als große Sau durchs Durft treiben, sondern jetzt auch mal geruhsam.
Einfach die Zeit hat jetzt einen Text gemacht und warten wir doch mal ab,
was einfach dann in Büchern steht in einem halben Jahr oder so.
Für mich geht es jetzt auch gar nicht konkret um den Fall, sondern einfach dieses
Diskursklima, dass immer sagt, jetzt ist das, jetzt ist das,
jetzt ist das. Ich glaube, wir erleben jetzt auch gerade so einen größeren Umschwung,
wenn man sich Artikel in der Zeit oder der FAZ ansieht in Bezug auf Gaza.
Also jetzt, dass doch selbst Hardliner nicht mehr richtig das aufrechterhalten
können, warum eigentlich die israelische Regierung da einen mörderischen Krieg
gegen die Zivilbevölkerung in Gaza führt, dass das nicht mehr irgendwie jetzt passiert.
Nochmal herleitbar ist mit dies und das. Das wird immer mehr sich jetzt durchsetzen
und wahrscheinlich sehen auch manche sowieso schon ihre Fälle davon schwimmen und sagen, okay,
dann müssen wir mal langsam einschwenken und auch mal das Leid zumindest mal
mehr abbilden, damit man sich nicht nachher den Vorwurf gefallen lassen muss,
aber den muss man sich jetzt schon gefallen lassen, in meinen Augen, man hätte weggesehen.
Naja, wir haben ja nachher die Strongman-Attitüden nochmal drin beim Thema Bürokratie.
Es ist ja ein bisschen wie damals 2015, ich erinnere mich noch ziemlich genau,
weil wir hatten gerade angefangen mit dem Aufwarn-Podcast und plötzlich hieß
es so in Nebensätzen, Kurznachrichten, da ist ein Schiff gesunken im Mittelmeer, 800 Tote.
Und alle waren so bestürzt und dann haben wir ja noch im selben Jahr so diese
Willkommenskultur und so weiter gehabt und dann diesen Umschwung, angeführt von der Bild.
Und plötzlich war es so ein, nee, ich bin ja kein Nazi, aber ich will ja doch
noch das eine oder andere noch sagen.
Und selbst Leute, die von sich wirklich glaubten, sie sind ja kein Nazi und
vielleicht haben sie sogar einen syrischen Flüchtling aufgenommen.
Hatten manchmal nicht allzu versteckt im Hinterkopf noch so ein,
zum Glück machen die Österreicher die Grenze zu.
Also zum Glück müssen wir es hier nicht lösen. Ich habe Angst vor,
was weiß ich, dass es dann rechtsradikale Angriffe gibt oder wie auch immer.
Aber ich will jetzt erstmal kein Chaos.
Und Chaos heißt, Ausländer bringen Chaos mit, ich will das jetzt nicht so.
Und so haben wir das jetzt auf vielen Ebenen, dass man immer wieder so im Hinterkopf
so eigentlich, na gut, zum Glück macht jemand und so.
Und das schlägt sich in vielen Themen wieder. Also wir haben wiederkehrende
Muster von Chaos, die Hoffnungen hervorrufen und so.
Und da, wenn man jetzt sensibel ist und neu beobachtet, glaube ich,
kriegt man mehr zu sehen, als sich, auch großes Thema Verschwörungstheorien zu ergeben.
Man muss dann auch immer wieder denken, so dieser ganze Kram.
Es haben jetzt sehr viele Idioten einfach Trump gewählt und jetzt haben wir
halt eine Idiotenregierung.
Und jetzt ist das aber blöd für die Idioten, weil die plötzlich feststellen,
Ach so, Mist, ich hatte schon die Hoffnung, dass die Themen weggeräumt werden.
Also so im Dezember ist der Ukraine-Krieg vorbei und im Januar ist das mit Gaza geklärt.
Denn jetzt ist irgendwie so März und die Ideen, die da sind,
sind irgendwie, ich hatte mir mehr versprochen vom Strongman.
Und jetzt hängen halt alle so rum und denken, ah Mist, hätte er doch mal die
Balkanroute geschlossen, hätte er doch mal das Gaza-Problem gelöst. Aber ist halt nicht.
Aber es ist immer das Versäumnis auch, dass man nicht entsprechend selbst gehandelt
hat. Also die beiden Regierungen hat da die Sachen liegen lassen.
Das ja immer.
Und einfach darauf gehofft, wenn wir wieder gewählt werden, haben wir ja wieder
vier Jahre und können uns dann darum kümmern.
Und so kann man ja nicht rangehen. Also nicht in einer Demokratie.
Da muss man sagen, wir schaffen die Demokratie ab, dann hat man die sehr lange Perspektive.
Aber sonst kann man eben nur immer in diesen Abständen arbeiten,
in denen man auch legitimiert ist.
Absolut davon. Ach, wir hören es vorbei.
Dann kann man auch sagen.
Ich habe gerade meine Familie begnadigt, viel Spaß und dann ist man weg.
Ich fand es auch ganz erschreckend, dass also Merz jetzt schon betont hat,
dass er einen Weg finden will, um Netanyahu einzuladen, obwohl ja dieser Haftbefehl
da ist vom internationalen Strafgerichtshof.
Strongman-Attitüden, ich beende den Krieg am Tag 1, ich löse das Gaza-Problem,
ich lade Netanyahu ein, ich sage, ist mir egal, was jemand fordert wie Jens
Spahn oder Willensbegründnis.
Aber du hältst es also nicht für möglich, dass er das tatsächlich tut?
Ich möchte den anberaumten Termin sehen.
Okay, ja, weil ich meine, Waffen werden ja weiterhin geliefert.
Deutschland ist ja nach wie vor der zweitgrößte Waffenexporteur nach Israel von schweren Waffen.
Waffenlieferung ist das eine, aber nach so einer Anklage gegen Netanyahu,
ihn in Deutschland einzuladen, ist dann doch was ganz anderes.
Denn wenn hier die öffentliche Meinung auftritt auf der Straße und sagt,
was habt ihr denn, ich fordere doch nur, dass das Völkerrecht eingehalten wird
und nicht Wischiwaschi von euch jetzt auch noch zertrümmern.
Das ist ja genauso wie diese Anklagen gegen die...
Aber wer geht auf die Straße? Also glaubst du jetzt zum Beispiel,
dass Leute aus anderen Parteien, ich klammer jetzt mal bewusst,
die Linkspartei aus zumindest teilen,
aber glaubst du, dass irgendjemand sonst der Parteien im Bundestag und der daran
anknüpfenden Aktivisten und NGOs und so, dass von denen Leute auf die Straße
gehen, wenn Netanjahu kommt?
Ich muss zurückziehen, es interessiert mich nicht, wer auf die Straße geht,
denn ich freue mich nur auf das Chaos in den Redaktionen. Also das ist für mich das Entscheidende.
Was wird darüber geschrieben, wenn die anberaumt ist?
Dann gibt es ja Tage zwischen wurde verkündet und findet statt.
Und das möchte ich dann sehen.
Dann fällt wieder die Netflix-Serie aus, dann kriegst du wieder das.
Genau, da lese ich dann Leitartikel und so, weil das ist das,
worauf es ankommt. Ob noch Leute auf die Straße gehen, ja.
Ich meine, die letzte Generation war auf der Straße, wird jetzt irgendwie angeklagt
wegen terroristischer Vereinigung.
Ich denke mir, das Ziel einer terroristischen
Vereinigung ist irgendwie Grundgesetztexte einzuhalten und so.
Also was ist denn das mittlerweile für eine Definition von Terrorziel?
Staatsziele sind jetzt Terrorziele.
Und zwar gerade in der Woche, wo wir das wirklich als, wir machen jetzt aus
dem Staatsziel, das schon im Grundgesetz steht, ein Programm,
knüpfen das an die Investitions- und Schuldenbremse und gleichzeitig fährt die Polizei los und sagt,
Und aufgrund dieses Staatsziels und den Methoden, sich auf der Straße festzukleben,
nehmen wir jetzt Leute fest. Also das ist ja irgendwie absurd.
Was? Sie wollten das Grundgesetz einhalten? Also jetzt hört es aber auf.
Genau, das geht gar nicht. Und vermummt haben sie sich auch noch.
Achso, Corona, ja gut. Ja, das ist alles durcheinander.
Ja, demokratietheoretisch ist es doch auch spannend. Wir hören einen kurzen
Auszug aus einer Markus-Lanz-Sendung.
Da war Roderich Kiesewetter von der CDU zu Gast.
Sie sagen Wählertäuschung. Folgendes ist, nein, das habe ich nicht gesagt.
Ich habe gesagt, man kann Argumente verstehen, dass Leute sagen,
das war Wählertäuschung. Kann ich nachvollziehen.
Für mich war das schon im Wahlkampf klar, dass ich gesagt habe,
Leute, nach dem Wahlkampf werden wir sehr viel Geld in die Hand nehmen müssen.
Denn mir war es im letzten Jahr schon klar, 300 Milliarden für Verteidigung
waren die Zahlen, die ich sagte, die wir brauchen bis 2030.
Und nochmal 200 Milliarden für Infrastruktur. Und was passiert?
500 Milliarden für Infrastruktur und nach oben offen für Verteidigung.
Alles richtig. Aber man hätte es früher sagen müssen und unsere Bevölkerung
darauf vorbereiten, dass wir den Gürtel enger schnallen müssen.
Und jetzt die Joker-Frage, warum hat man es nicht gesagt?
Aus einerseits Sorge in den Wahlen im Osten, dass man gesagt hat,
dann sind die Leute vielleicht in Sorge, dass der Krieg eskalieren könnte von
russischer Seite. Das tut er sowieso.
Und man hat gedacht, dass wir als Hüter der Schuldenbremse nicht den Eindruck
vermitteln wollen, mehr Geld in die Hand zu nehmen. Das kann ich verstehen.
Wurde Ihnen das so gesagt? Lass das mal mit den Schulden.
Das wurde nicht mir gesagt, sondern das war natürlich die offizielle Politik. Das will keiner hören.
Das war ganz klar, dass eben im Osten mit der Konkurrenz zu Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht,
zur AfD und der Angst, dass der Krieg sich ausweitet, hat man nicht den Mut
aufgebracht, nein, den Satz noch, hat man nicht den Mut aufgebracht,
der Bevölkerung zu sagen, Achtung, wir müssen mehr Geld in die Hand nehmen,
sonst weitet sich der Krieg aus.
Das ist eine schöne Formulierung, nicht den Mut aufgebracht.
Man hat die Wähler bewusst getäuscht und wusste, dass man am Tag danach genau
etwas anderes machen wird, als das, was man im Wahlprogramm reingeschrieben
hat. Und als das, was man auf den Bühnen bei den Wahlkampfauftritten verkündet hat.
Und das ist doch ein demokratietheoretisches Problem.
Da geht es doch jetzt nicht darum, dass man sagt, ja, es wird alles nicht so
heiß gegessen, wie es gekocht wird oder sowas. Ja, natürlich ist nie das Wahlprogramm
eins zu eins dann das, was danach umgesetzt wird.
Aber hier wurden ja die Wähler an der Nase herumgeführt und ich kann,
auch wenn ich deren Inhalt nicht teile,
kann ich doch die Position jetzt frustrierter CDU-Wähler tatsächlich verstehen,
die sagen, ich habe die gewählt, weil ich ja nicht mehr schulden wollte,
weil ich das und das nicht wollte und habe genau das Gegenteil bekommen.
Also das ist ja völlig verrückt.
Ja.
Also das wäre ja jetzt genauso, also jemand wählt die Linkspartei und danach
kommt die Linkspartei und sagt, was wir jetzt brauchen sind Abschiebungen.
Dann würde man sagen, wie Moment, ich habe euch gewählt, weil ich denke,
ihr seid mal eine Partei, die keine Abschiebung fordert.
Ich habe lange gerätselt, ob das, was die Grünen da jetzt reinformuliert haben, gut ist oder nicht.
Diese 100 Milliarden.
Ja, nicht nur die 100 Milliarden, sondern dass die ganzen 500 Milliarden unter
Klimaziel 2045 Vorbehalt stehen.
Dass also künftig nicht mehr geklärt werden muss über die öffentliche Meinung,
ob Merz das machen darf, was er davor hat, sondern die Grünen und dann reicht
es allein der Fraktionsvorsitzende und die Fraktionsvorsitzende einfach sagt,
Ich rufe mal in Karlsruhe an und lasse das überprüfen.
Also ich kläre das mit der Richterbank. Zehn Leute.
Öffentliche Meinung ist außen vor, weil Grundgesetz. Die Formulierungen sind glasklar.
Was für mich bedeutet, Deutschland hat es jetzt geschafft, einen Green Deal
zu formulieren, so wie ihn sich AOC wünschte.
Nämlich, dass der Staat zusätzlich und so weiter alles unter Klimavorbehalt.
Und zwar nicht im Sinne von, wir schützen jetzt das Klima, sondern jeglicher
Staatsumbau, der stattfindet.
Jegliche Investition in Infrastrukturertüchtigung.
Außer Rüstung.
Das ist ja ein eigenes Paket. Aber die 500 Milliarden für Infrastruktur sind ja...
Aber dieses Infrastrukturpaket lässt ja beispielsweise einen Autobahnausbau
zu. Da wird ja in Karlsruhe niemand sich da querstellen.
Doch, wenn nämlich doch. Also in Karlsruhe macht man ja keine Gerechtigkeitsstudien,
sondern da liest man einfach das Grundgesetz und interpretiert.
Und der Satz, der lautet, das muss alles nach dem 2045er Ziel ausgerichtet sein,
hat jetzt programmatische Kraft.
Denn bisher war es ja nur ein Staatsziel und das wurde ja so wischiwaschi ausgelegt,
dass erstritten wurde, dass Karlsruhe feststellte, ja stimmt,
die haben ein Grundrecht auf Zukunft, die notwendigen Programme müssen früher stattfinden.
Und jetzt hat Karlsruhe die Vorlage bekommen aus der Zweidrittelmehrheit,
jeglicher Euro, der bewegt wird, muss programmatisch passen zu diesem Ziel.
Man kann keinen Euro ausgeben, der nicht erklärt, wie er zu dem 2045er-Ziel kommt.
Was bedeutet, auch jeder Autobahnkilometer muss jetzt gerechtfertigt werden. Das kriegt man ja hin.
Klar kriegt man das hin. Aber es ist halt eine kognitive Anstrengung,
dieses Klimaziel da reinzubauen.
Nur es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass das ein Paket ist, das zum Beispiel den Automobilverkehr
beschränken wird und die Bahn ausbaut. Also das Paket ist das ja nicht.
Nö.
Also das bedeutet Autobahnbrücken. Ich bin ja sehr dafür. Ich will ja gar nicht
sagen, dass ich dagegen bin.
Nur ich glaube nicht, dass das stimmt, dass das in diesem ganzen Rahmen dann ist.
Nur wird man auch weiterhin rechtfertigen können, auch wenn man vielleicht ein
paar Verrenkungen mehr anstellen muss, warum man beispielsweise noch eine weitere Autobahn benötigt.
Genau, es gibt neue Rechtfertigungspflichten, man muss Programm schreiben.
Es ist im Grunde schon ein bisschen mehr Bürokratie, aber wir haben jetzt ein
Staatsziel, das sozusagen programmatische Beobachtung und Konzentration erfordert und provoziert.
Mit der Besonderheit, wir haben uns ja sehr darüber beklagt,
dass immer alles jetzt ins Grundgesetz geschrieben werden muss.
Typischerweise steht ja im Grundgesetz Floskeln, ausgehend von Artikel 1.
Dass der nicht überall eingehalten wird, ist ja klar. Nur in dem Falle ist das halt ein Preisschild.
Und das ist wirklich ganz neu. Also das ist eine echte Zäsur.
Und ich finde eben, auf deine Frage zurückzukommen, wir haben hier was echt
ganz Großartiges, bei dem ich mich lang gefragt habe.
Sollte man nicht doch lieber nochmal die jetzt sagen, die Grünen sprengen das Anliegen,
lassen Merz ohne diese ganzen Gelder in die Kanzlerschaft laufen und er muss
dann während seiner Kanzlerschaft mit Grün und Linken und zwar bis er bereit
ist die Schuldenbremse als Schuldenbremse zu tilgen oder zu verändern.
Jetzt hat man sie halt aufgeweicht mit diesem 1%. Also die Verteidigungskosten
da höher als 1% rauszunehmen, entlastet ja schon mal sehr.
Und wenn man Geld braucht, kann man es sich einfach nehmen.
Man muss halt jetzt die Entscheidung treffen, will ich entweder eine Verzichtsdiskussion
im Haushalt anführen, weil wenn ich was brauche, muss ich halt jemand anderes wegnehmen.
Oder greife ich in den Topf, wo ich halt die ganze Zeit das Klima im Nacken
habe. Und es ist doch eine super Ausgangssituation.
Mich stört ja gar nicht der Inhalt dieses Pakets so sehr.
Also ich sehe auch da Probleme, aber das ist gar nicht mein strittiger Punkt,
sondern ich finde wirklich strittig,
dass wir eine Bundestagswahl veranstalten, die die ganze Zeit etwas Falsches
vortäuscht und nun am Ende sieht es anders aus.
Wir haben ja auch schon gesehen, was das auch in der Bevölkerung auslöst.
Die AfD hat direkt zweieinhalb Prozent dazugewonnen. Die CDU hat eben diese verloren.
Und das bedeutet, CDU und AfD sind bald gleich auf.
Die Lüge steht im Raum und sie ist auch ein großes und wichtiges Thema.
Aber ich finde die Würdigung, dass wir in Deutschland jetzt einen Green Deal haben.
Also wir haben jetzt nicht mehr die fortschrittlichste Regierung der Welt, wie Adam Tuss sagte.
Green Deal ist vielleicht ein bisschen sehr euphemistisch.
Also lass uns mal abwarten, welche Projekte da so dann kommen.
Wir kriegen ja noch einen Koalitionsvertrag und ob das ein Green Deal ist,
der ja zugleich noch eine halbe Milliarde, eine halbe Billion in die Aufrüstung steckt,
von der ich jetzt erfahren habe, dass die nicht so umweltfreundlich ist.
Ja, das stimmt allerdings.
Das wird ja vermutlich nicht mit Recyclingpapier gebaut.
Der zweite Punkt, den ich noch machen will, also neben, ich sage jetzt Green
Deal, ist noch, die Deutschen haben nicht so richtig, ihnen wurde nicht so richtig
erzählt, dass dieses Geld jetzt einfach da ist.
Und zwar einfach nur, weil es im Bundestag eine entsprechende Mehrheit gab.
Bei dieser Bundestagsdiskussion, ich habe sie mir alle angeschaut,
wurde nicht darüber diskutiert, wie man jetzt den Brief formuliert an die Milliardäre,
weil man denen das wegnehmen muss.
Oder wie man jetzt die Arbeitsagentur für Arbeit oder die Bundesagentur für
Arbeit umbaut, damit man den Leuten das Geld nicht mehr auszahlen muss.
Sondern eben anders als wir Privatleute mussten keine Sicherheiten hinterlegt
werden. Und keinen Tilgungsplan geschrieben.
Man hat einfach gesagt, ja so ab 2030 wird so ein bisschen zurückgezahlt.
Wir machen 30-jährige wurde es halt leider so in 30 Jahren und sowas.
Und ich finde, das muss auch nochmal beschrieben werden. Wir haben das natürlich,
unsere Hörer wissen Bescheid, aber ich finde auch für das allgemeine Nachrichten-Projekt,
sollte man nochmal, habt ihr gesehen, einfach nur, weil das dann eine Mehrheit gab,
Und am Montag kam die Idee und am Freitag war das fertig so.
Genau, wenn man das auch nicht Leuten begreiflich macht, dann bekommen die natürlich Horrorvisionen.
Aber es wurde zu Recht auf die Lüge. Ich stimme dir dazu, die Lüge ist ein echtes Problem.
Wie verändert sich nun überhaupt Deutschland bzw.
Wie sieht es mit der Rüstung und all dem aus? Erstmal hören wir ganz kurz einen
österreichischen Militäranalysten, Franz Stephan Gadi. der war in dem Zeit-Podcast
das Politik-Teil zu Gast.
Er sagt uns jetzt erstmal, wie wir das mit den Staaten zu verstehen haben.
Dieses Friedensprojekt Europa eben herauszubilden, auf internationales Recht
zu setzen, Normen, Regulierungen und so weiter.
Und dann haben wir komplett versäumt zu sehen, dass die Welt nach wie vor anarchisch
ist, dass militärische Gewalt oder die Androhung von militärischer Gewalt ein
Grundprinzip internationaler Beziehungen darstellt und dass wir das eben tun müssen.
Das ist also der Realismus, den wir schon bei den strukturellen Realisten wie
Mörsheimer gefunden haben.
Das wird jetzt hier einfach so gesetzt, womit man dann auch sieht,
also es ist ein Gewaltverhältnis zwischen den Staaten, so will er das sehen.
Also das ist jetzt seine Perspektive darauf, wir werden ihn nachher auch nochmal
hören, aber erstmal sehen wir jetzt, das ist offenbar die Prämisse,
unter der jetzt sich alles versammelt.
Ja, diesen Gadi-Podcast habe ich gehört in Athen in der U-Bahn.
Ja.
Nachdem die erste U-Bahn kam, aber ich nicht einsteigen konnte,
weil sie war so voll und so. Und das Wetter war aber schön und es hat mich nicht
gestört und ich bin ja auch nur Tourist.
Und dann steige ich halt aus und stehe dann auf diesem Platz,
wo das Parlament ist und das ist wirklich das hässlichste Parlamentsgebäude
der Welt und der ganze Platz ist auch super hässlich.
Und dann geht man ein Stück weiter und steht mal vor der Gruppel ist und so weiter und so fort.
Und ich denke mir so die ganze Zeit, er sagt ja dann auch, ja wir bräuchten
eigentlich 400.000 Leute unter Waffen und so.
Ich denke mir die ganze Zeit, ne, kein Bock. Warum? Macht doch gar keinen Sinn.
Hier ist es so schön, warum soll ich denn jetzt und so.
Aber das ist genau die richtige Haltung. Also ich habe das hier nicht zustimmend
vorgespielt, sondern das ist genau die richtige Haltung. Aber wir bekommen jetzt
erstmal so andere Zahlen.
Rheinmetall, wir haben es alle mitbekommen, die Aktie hat mal 90 Euro gekostet vor Putins Krieg.
Jetzt sind wir bei über 1000 Euro angekommen.
Der Vorstandschef Armin Pappberger wird interviewt im Deutschlandfunk.
Wir haben eine Hochrechnung bzw. eine Simulation gemacht und in dieser Simulation
sehen wir, dass bis zum Jahr 2030, wenn wir 2,5 oder 3 Prozent ausgeben in Europa für die Rüstung,
in Summe etwa 1000 Milliarden bis zum Jahr 2030 nur im Jahr 2030 ausgegeben werden.
Wenn man sagt, weil man ja etwas
braucht an Materialien, dass 40% für investive Mittel gegeben werden,
dann hat Rheinmetall über die nächsten Jahre bis zum Jahr 2030 ein Potenzial
von 300 bis zu 400 Milliarden Euro Auftragseingänge in diesem Bereich.
Das ist eine gewaltige Zahl. Also nicht, dass das der Auftragseingang sein wird,
sondern dass das das Potenzial ist.
Wieso redet er so im Radio?
Naja.
Was soll die öffentliche Meinung jetzt damit? Wenn er sich darüber freut,
kann er sich doch einfach darüber freuen. Aber ist das jetzt eine Investorenansprache oder?
Ja, ich glaube schon, dass er nochmal die Aktie schmackhaft machen will da.
Also ich habe jetzt auch ein neues Bild über dieses, also ich bleibe ja weiterhin
bei meiner Atombombe, weil Atombombe heißt einfach, also wenn man sie einsetzt,
ist es vorbei so. Also Atombomben nimmt halt relativ viel so spieltheoretischen
Pfirlefans einfach raus.
Weil das hier, was hier diskutiert wird, also Raketen in einem Lager wie die
Hisbollah, die haben 100.000 Raketen irgendwo rumliegen. Oder halt Panzer.
Wir können Panzer verschicken, aber haben wir immer noch welche übrig.
Ich möchte gern, wir haben ja manchmal eine Diskussion über Geld und dann redet
man über Leute, die sehr viel Geld haben und sagt dann so, das ist Spielgeld
für die. Und ich finde hier das auch.
Also diese Sachen mit diesen Panzern und so, das sind kleine Jungs,
die mit ihren Panzern auf den Tisch und dann sagt der eine, nee,
ich hatte gestern Geburtstag, ich habe einen größeren gekriegt,
komm mal, meine fährt mit Fernsteuerung und so. Also das ist Spielzeug.
Ich meine, man muss ja auch, dass sich mal so überlegen, es wird die ganze Zeit
gesagt, Deutschland oder Europa muss aufrüsten, um ein Drohpotenzial zu haben
und sich verteidigen zu können.
Das wird ja immer gesagt, wir werden gleich mal hören, ob es immer nur um Verteidigung
und Russland und so geht, aber das bleiben wir erstmal dabei.
Und die Sache ist ja, es schaukelt sich ja hoch.
Die anderen Länder, die angeblich unsere Rivalen sind oder es auch tatsächlich
sind, die rüsten jetzt auch dann mehr auf.
Also die sagen ja nicht, wir bleiben jetzt auf dem Niveau und gucken mal,
bis die auch so viele Panzer wie wir haben, sondern die sagen ja,
dann nehmen wir auch schon mal wieder 100 Panzer mehr.
Ja, und das bedeutet ja, es gibt ja nicht irgendwann so ein Gleichgewicht,
sondern ein immer weiteres Hochschaukeln.
Und es ist ja auch nicht so, dass man sagt, jetzt ist der Punkt erreicht,
jetzt haben alle genau gleich viel, nehmen sich an der Hand und fließen dann
alles wieder abzurüsten.
Also das ist ja eine irrige Vorstellung.
Also ich hätte gern, wenn er so fleißig dabei ist, sich Excel-Simulationen zu
machen, wie sein Profit aussieht 2030.
Wie genau sieht der Krieg aus?
Ja.
Also wie sieht der Krieg aus, indem wir auf beiden Seiten 17.000 Panzer haben?
Das ist doch absurd.
Ja, wir hören hier nochmal weiter.
Und um dieses Potenzial heben zu können, um dem gerecht zu werden,
müssen wir letztendlich dann weiter investieren.
Das heißt, wir würden unsere Kapazitäten noch einmal verdoppeln und das tun wir auch.
Das heißt, wenn die Entscheidung der Bundesregierung und anderer Regierungen
und einige haben es schon entschieden, wie Litauen, die sind auf 4 bis 5 Prozent
jetzt hochgegangen des GDPs, aber Deutschland wird der große Treiber sein.
Der große Elefant im Raum ist sicherlich Deutschland.
Dann werden wir weiter investieren und dann werden wir sicherlich auch eine
wichtige Rolle spielen.
Gut.
Was mich jetzt auch daran interessiert hat, ist, wie schätzt ein solcher Mann?
Was meinst du? Geht er davon aus, dass er Lagerbestände schafft?
Oder glaubt er, irgendwann muss er auch mal das alles verschossen werden,
damit ich nachliefern kann?
Also bereitet er jetzt Krieg vor oder macht er einfach volle Lager?
Und volle Lager heißt halt, du hast so eine riesige Belegschaft,
den du wie in so einer Behörde sagst, ich weiß, sie haben ganz aufwendig studiert
und sie waren sehr gut in Mathe und wir zahlen ihnen auch nicht viel.
Und trotzdem muss ich ihnen sagen, also sie planen hier die nächsten 30 Jahre
einfach 30 Kilometer Autobahnen und wenn wir Glück haben, schaffen wir es,
die fertigzustellen, bevor sie sterben. Das ist ihr Leben.
So, sie bauen jetzt hier Panzer. Was passiert mit diesen Panzern?
Also wenn sie Glück haben.
Die kommen da drüben in das Lager.
Ja, und wenn, also die Sache ist ja so, das funktioniert ja besonders dann gut,
wenn, wie du sagst, man diese Dinge auch nutzen kann, damit wieder neue produziert werden.
Panzer macht wirklich nur Sinn, wenn man sie nutzt.
So.
Das kann man selbst tun. Vielleicht steht das auch noch aus.
Also ich würde so langsam, wenn ich mir eine gewisse Stimmung ansehe,
wenn ich höre, da ein Sönke Neisse sagt, das ist vielleicht unser letzter Sommer
in Frieden und solche Aussagen da von Sigmar Gabriel und so weiter höre,
dann würde ich dann denken,
auch auf der EU-Ebene nochmal von Callas oder so, dann würde ich sagen,
vielleicht geht es auch mehr darum, dass Europa tatsächlich auch mal wieder
irgendwo intervenieren will.
Nicht, dass man jetzt nach Moskau gleich will, aber schon irgendwo intervenieren will.
Ich will jetzt ein Argument, das ist ein bisschen heikel, liebe Zuhörer,
ich weiß, YouTube-Kommentare, herzlich willkommen.
Aber wir haben ja jetzt gesehen, was mit dem Iran passiert, wenn man ihn so
hart provoziert, wie Israel das jetzt getan hat, die letzten anderthalb Jahre.
Der Iran legt die Hände in den Schoß und hofft, dass es einfach vorbeigeht.
Da wird nicht groß zurückgeschossen, da wird vielleicht mal eine strenge Ankündigung
gemacht, man versucht, die eigene Bevölkerung im Zaube zu halten und so weiter und so fort.
Ich frage mich so ein bisschen, wenn in Europa jetzt alle aufrüsten und die
Regierung irgendwann dazu übergehen, zu sagen, wir brauchen jetzt mal einen
Feind, hätte ich so die Vermutung, dass sehr viele Länder auf der Welt sagen, nee, sorry.
Auch unter dieser Maßgabe, wir haben es mal besprochen bei der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz,
sorry, aber wir wissen, was Krieg ist. Wir haben echt keine Lust.
Was macht Europa dann? Also ist das Szenario dann einfach, dass wir gegen Portugal
in den Krieg ziehen, weil wir dann so Trumpeske Regierungen haben,
die sagen, diese Küsten brauchen wir.
Nee, gegen Portugal sicherlich nicht. Also auf Europa-Ebene.
Man könnte ja zum Beispiel sagen, wir müssen die EU noch ein bisschen erweitern
und müssen das auch durchaus militärisch durchsetzen.
Oder man könnte zum Beispiel auch auf die Idee kommen, dass man gewisse Gebiete
doch nochmal versucht zurückzuerobern, die man Putin dann in irgendeinem Frieden
mit Trump überlassen hat.
Ich meine, Marokko hat die Westsahara übernommen. Wir haben so gesagt,
kein Problem, wir machen trotzdem Freihandelsverträge mit euch.
Kann natürlich auch ein Erfolgsrezept werden.
Deutschland ist ja bekanntermaßen Exportweltmeister, man muss jetzt schon fast
sagen gewesen, wegen der Autoindustrie und das heißt, dieser Aufrüstungswahn,
der ist ja nur dann lukrativ,
wenn man es auch schafft, Waffen zu exportieren.
Also man kann sich natürlich, du hast es jetzt beschrieben, man kann Schulden
aufnehmen und dann kann der Staat, Rheinmetall, das abkaufen,
aber darauf kann man natürlich nicht dauerhaft eine sinnvolle Volkswirtschaft aufbauen.
Auch teile Milliarden sind irgendwann aufgebaut.
Ja, irgendwann ist dann gut und du kriegst, irgendwann wird auch die Kredibilität
nicht mehr gut sein, wenn du sagst, wir bauen nur noch Panzer,
wir machen nichts mehr anderes und kaufen die uns selbst ab.
Das heißt, du musst exportieren, wie man ja auch Autos exportieren muss,
um als Volkswirtschaft zu funktionieren. Das heißt, wir haben ja schon viele
Rüstungsexporte und es gibt ja sehr viele Stimmen, die jetzt sagen,
wir brauchen eigentlich mehr.
Das heißt, wir werden also Waffen an Länder exportieren, die damit Dinge tun,
die wir eigentlich ablehnen.
Oder, und das ist jetzt ein sehr realistisches, diese Chatgruppe.
Drehte sich ja um diese Bombardierung dieser Houthi-Stellung. Und da hat ja J.D.
Vance diesen kleinen Snippet gebracht zu fragen, sollten wir das jetzt eigentlich machen?
Das wird ja auch noch ein großes Thema, weil Trump hat gesagt,
wir sollen das machen und J.D. Vance hat in dieser Gruppe so Kritik an dieser Entscheidung geübt.
Also da scheint es auch Spaltpilze zu geben. Und die drehte sich ja darum, dass J.D.
Vance sagte, warum schießen wir schon wieder den Europäern den Suezkanal frei?
Denn durch den Suezkanal gehen drei Prozent der amerikanischen Güter,
aber 40 Prozent der europäischen oder irgendwie so.
Ich habe es jetzt auch nicht genau vor, aber es gibt halt solche Kalkulationen.
Und wenn jetzt in Deutschland immer die Rede ist davon, dass ja die Amerikaner
nicht mehr den Sicherheitsschirm für Deutschland mit aufspannen können und so,
heißt das ja konkret, wir müssen uns wirklich selbst die Seewege freischießen.
Weil es Amerika nicht mehr tut.
Den Clip 181 anspielen. Der ist von der Lage der Nation. Wir hören hier Ulf Burmeier.
Aber wenn die USA das eben in Zukunft nicht mehr für uns übernehmen,
dann müssen wir eben selber die nötigen Flugzeugträger haben.
Dann müssen wir eben selber die nötigen Marschflugkörper haben,
um notfalls die Houthis in die Steinzeit zu bomben. Anders funktioniert es doch nicht.
Also das wird jetzt gefordert von einem, ich will das nochmal ausdrücklich sagen, offenbar.
Also Ulf wird ja vermutlich nicht mehr selbst abknallen. Ja,
also wir haben hier einen,
ich will es nochmal ausdrücklich sagen, einen linksliberalen Podcast,
ja, so wirklich ganz, ganz Mitte, Mitte, Mitte, der sagt, wir müssen es zur
Not, müssen wir die Houthis selbst in die Steinzeit zurückbauen.
Da dachte ich, Moment, diese Formulierung kennt man doch.
Ach ja, das ist die Formulierung des Luftwaffengenerals Curtis E. LeMay.
Zu Vietnam. Wir müssen die I in Vietnam in die Steinzeit zurückbomben.
Und das ist jetzt eben diese neue Sache, denn man kann natürlich sehr gut jetzt
gerade, um Leute für diese Aufrüstung zu gewinnen, diese Bedrohung machen.
Putin steht kurz vor Berlin. Dann denkt man immer so, also Putin hat es nicht
geschafft, nach Kiew zu kommen.
Er strampelt sich jetzt seit drei Jahren ab, hat jetzt ein paar militärische
Erfolge, aber das ist ja alles äußerst schleppend, muss sich von Nordkorea noch
irgendwelche Soldaten geben lassen, um weiterzukommen.
Was übrigens als Drama überall ausgeblendet wird.
Ist ein Armutszeugnis, ja, wird das Armutszeugnis, ist natürlich ein Armutszeugnis
dann, wenn man so möchte, für Russland. Ist ja nicht irgendwie ein Signal der Stärke.
Und zugleich sagt man, Putin kann aber gleich schon in Berlin sein.
Und damit kann man aber Angst produzieren und diese Aufrüstung dann,
glaube ich, auch den Leuten schmackhaft machen.
Aber worum es hier offenbar auch geht, wird ja hier angesprochen.
Und du hast es jetzt eben mal so frei assoziiert.
Und ja, das denken die jetzt auch tatsächlich schon.
Ja, also gut, die einen sagen, Houthi sind die Steinzeitbomben,
die anderen reden vom Suezkanal, also der Vizepräsident.
Das ist, finde ich jetzt auch als Hörerlebnis nicht gut, denn typischerweise
machen wir hier im Podcast Pointen, indem wir wie nachher zuerst ein Trump-O-Ton
spielen. Wie er sagt, die Bürokratie ist der Krebs, davon müssen wir das Land befreien.
Und danach spielen wir einen Hoss und Hopf Clip, in dem Philipp Hopf davon erzählt,
dass die EU ja der Krebs ist, von dem wir uns befreien müssen.
Aber im gleichen Maße, ja, Entscheidungsträger höre, die sagen und so weiter
und dann kommt plötzlich genau dasselbe von Burmeier, finde ich nicht gut.
Ja, ich auch nicht. Wir hören nochmal beim Deutschlandfunk rein.
Moderator Philipp May fragt jetzt mal nach, denn das ist ja doch interessant.
Ist dieses transatlantische Verhältnis jetzt komplett kaputt?
Es wird ja jetzt schon über Buy-European-Klauseln, auch in der Rüstungsindustrie diskutiert.
Momentan ist es so, dass für 62 Prozent, glaube ich, der Waffen in Deutschland
oder in Europa, die kommen aus den USA.
Das sehe ich nicht so. Kann Europa die USA komplett ersetzen in der Aufrüstung?
Zurzeit nicht. Also im Bereich der Waffentechnik haben die Amerikaner sehr spezielle
Technologien, die wir in Europa zurzeit nicht haben.
Ob wir das alles haben müssen, ob wir komplett unabhängig sein müssen,
so wie die Amerikaner das ja letztendlich wollen, ja. Die USA...
Die Leitnation der Welt im Augenblick, das ist so, im Bereich Militär sowieso.
Und die haben gesagt, wir müssen letztendlich alles alleine können.
Europa hat das bisher die letzten 30, 40 Jahre nicht so gesagt.
Die haben gesagt, wir kaufen halt was ein und wir kooperieren.
Papperga aber möchte jetzt gar nicht, dass diese Unabhängigkeit kommt,
denn das ist interessant, wir haben ja gerade einmal Leute, die weiterhin transatlantisch
sind und Aufrüstung fordern und dazu gehören jetzt so Leute auch wie Jens Spahn.
Und dann haben wir Leute, die sagen, Aufrüstung, damit Europa sich loslöst,
bis hin zu Leuten, die die NATO eh immer scheiße fanden und sagen,
ja, wenn wir die NATO jetzt selbst steuern dürfen, dann ist vielleicht auch die NATO gut.
Also es ist interessant, es gibt mehrere Positionen, die alle sagen,
Aufrüstung ja, aber tatsächlich immer sind dann doch die Grundsätze andere.
Und jetzt geht es um F-35.
Die F-35 Kampfjets. an deren Produktion in Deutschland Sie hier auch beteiligt
sind, über das Werk in Wesse.
Sie machen den Mittelteil dieses Kampfjets.
Ich nehme an, Sie sind nicht so
glücklich über diese Diskussion oder wie verfolgen Sie diese Diskussion?
Dass man jetzt sagt, man sollte den Kauf möglicherweise sogar rückgängig machen,
weil es ist einfach zu riskant, weil man sich zu sehr von den Amerikanern da abhängig macht.
Jetzt kommt die Antwort.
Ich glaube, dass das sogar gefährlich ist, weil wenn wir nichts anderes haben
oder nichts Adäquates haben, wie der F-35, dann könnte Amerika irgendwann mal
hingehen und könnte sagen, das hat man ja damals mit der Türkei gemacht,
ihr seid kein Reliable Partner mehr. Aber dann fehlt uns eine ganze Menge.
Ich glaube, als allererstes muss man reden miteinander. Wir sehen jetzt,
dass man ja versuchen muss, mit Präsident Putin zu reden.
Auch muss man letztendlich mit Präsident Trump darüber reden und nicht jetzt
irgendwo noch Feuerchen schüren nebenbei und sagen, also das müssen wir jetzt
kündigen und das müssen wir machen.
Wollen wir denn wirklich die transatlantische Partnerschaft zugrunde richten? Das geht doch nicht.
Wir, das machen auch die Amerikaner gar nicht.
Ja, das Interessante ist ja, dass die europäische Rüstungsindustrie,
zumal auch die deutsche, sehr gute Kontakte hält in die USA.
Die sind nicht dafür, dass man jetzt sagt, Europa macht sich da ganz unabhängig. Sag nochmal.
Ich bin der Meinung, dass diese Diskussionen falsch sind, sondern man muss hingehen
und man muss vernünftige Wege finden, und Programme, Investitionsprogramme,
by the way, das wird sehr teuer, denn wir haben einen Vertrag, der gültig ist.
Das heißt Lockheed muss kompensiert werden, wir müssen kompensiert werden,
wir stellen gerade mit Gesamtkosten für 500 Millionen Euro ein Werk dahin in
dem Bereich, das muss alles bezahlt werden.
Also bestehende Verträge und dann geht das so weiter.
Nun hören wir nochmal Franz Stephan Gardi zur transatlantischen Partnerschaft.
Nicht, ich glaube die größere Frage ist, werden die Vereinigten Staaten in Zukunft
tatsächlich ein Gegner irgendwann einmal sein?
Und ich glaube, in dieser Hinsicht müssen wir wirklich die Kirche auch im Dorf
lassen. Ich glaube, es geht nicht so sehr darum, dass die Vereinigten Staaten
irgendwann mal ein potenzieller Gegner eines Vereinigten Europas sein könnten.
Nein, ich glaube, die Vereinigten Staaten werden immer ein sehr enger Sicherheitspartner bleiben.
Ich glaube, wir werden auch in gewisser Weise verbündet bleiben.
Ich glaube nur, dass wir nicht mehr mit diesem Automatismus zu rechnen haben,
dass die Amerikaner uns immer eben zur Seite stehen.
Diese Unabhängigkeit, also die jetzt so sehr stark zu vernehmen war und die
auch sehr viel gerechtfertigt hat.
Und ich glaube, es gibt ja auch ein gewisses anti-amerikanisches Ressentiment
ohnehin, dass man jetzt nochmal so ein bisschen abgegriffen hat,
um diese Aufrüstung zu rechtfertigen.
Das scheint mir gar nicht so das realistische Szenario zu sein,
denn die Rüstungsindustrie ist sehr wohl daran interessiert, dass man beides macht.
Also sowohl Europa aufrüstet, als auch die transatlantische Partnerschaft aufrechterhält,
einfach weil man sehr viel kooperiert und da es ja auch wieder um Exporte geht,
ist man natürlich ganz dankbar,
wenn beispielsweise die Amerikaner, wo sie jetzt schon Zölle auf Autos belegen wollen,
wenigstens vielleicht die Waffen dann günstig abnehmen.
Ja, also ich halte sowieso, es ist die ganze Idee, dass man überhaupt diskutiert,
ob wir irgendwann mal mit Amerika in den Krieg ziehen, dann doch mal die Kirche
in den Dorf lassen oder so.
Also es gibt Weltregionen, in denen ist es teuer, wenn Sachen kaputt gehen.
Deswegen gibt es da keinen Krieg. Das wird auch immer so sein.
Wenn jetzt halt, keine Ahnung, irgendwo riesige Verarmungszonen stattfinden,
wie in der Ostukraine, dann ist es halt egal, ob da ein Krieg ist oder nicht.
So und in Amerika gibt es ja auch, es gibt da, ich hatte das einmal.
Wir müssen jetzt nochmal betonen, für die Kapitalseite, nicht,
dass jetzt, je nachher ausgelegt wird, Stefan ist egal, ob Krieg in der Ostukraine ist.
Nein, er wollte betonen, wie das Kapital ein Interesse daran hat,
wenn es dort stark vertreten ist, dass dort kein Krieg ausbricht.
Ja, mein Mitleid mit den Leuten ist dort besonders groß, weil nämlich,
und da gibt es eine Schilderung einer Korrespondentin, die im Zeit-Podcast,
das Politikteil, auftritt.
Die habe ich in irgendeinem Text auf meiner Webseite verlinkt oder kann man
sich es anhören, wie sie so sagt, also wenn ich als Europäerin hier durchfahre,
das sieht aus, als wäre hier Krieg gewesen.
Also irgendwelche vor 30 Jahren stillgelegten Fabriken, aber dann nicht nur
Fabriken, sondern ganze Stadtteile, wo einfach der Stadtkern komplett tot,
Bürogebäude, die man seit 30 Jahren nicht mehr betreten hat und so.
In der Ukraine jetzt.
In Amerika.
In Amerika. So, und das sind natürlich Gegenden, also der Krieg droht auch dann
so ein bisschen, und ich habe ja gesagt, so ein Krieg im Außen geht auch mal
mit dem Bürgerkrieg einher.
Solche Art kriegerischen, gewaltsamen Auseinandersetzungen drohen dort,
wo es nichts mehr zu verlieren gibt.
Und wenn es Regionen gibt, in denen europäische Korrespondenten hinfahren und
sagen, das sieht ja aus wie ein Krieg, dann wird es halt brenzlig.
Also wir kommen ja nachher auf den Sozialstaat zu sprechen und so,
wenn da nichts mehr da ist, dann ist halt Gewalt das neue Diktum.
Aber noch haben wir ja in Europa und Amerika andere Zustände und es ist doch
völlig, also die bauen jetzt Panzer und Kampfflugzeuge.
Und wir haben gesehen, dass zwei Tage Regen im Ahrtal, das ist nun nicht gerade
als industrielle Hochburg oder sonstiges,
einfach die zweitgrößte Naturkatastrophe der Welt darstellen,
nur weil da so viel kaputt gehen kann. Und wir reden wirklich nur von privaten Wohnhäusern.
Dann ist es völlig undenkbar, dass, also ich finde ja immer noch witzig,
dass es diese Frage gab, als Scholz damals kurz vor Kriegsbeginn durch Putin in Russland war.
Und dann so die Frage war, ja, wenn Russland jetzt angreift,
betreiben wir da Nord Stream 2 noch?
Und wir wissen heute, Nord Stream 2, was für ein Detail. Es geht doch hier gerade um alles.
So ist das ja jetzt auch. Also diese ganzen virtuellen Gedankengänge,
die jetzt so im Sinne von, ja, also wenn wir mal wieder in Deutschland eine
Situation haben, bei der wir tausend Panzer irgendwo hinschicken,
da würde ich sagen, ja, dann ist auch alles egal.
Also dann brauchen wir keine Politik mehr und keine politischen Podcasts und
überhaupt nichts mehr, sondern dann ist nur noch die Frage, wo kann ich meinen
Kartoffelacker aufmachen, in der Hoffnung, in drei Monaten mal wieder was zu essen zu haben oder so.
Oder wie komme ich in die Schweiz? Ich versuche ja, meine Kontakte zur Schweiz
zu verstärken, wie du weißt, schon durch Auftritte.
Ja, du musst dann aber noch ein paar Warten antrainieren, damit du mit den Gebirgsjägern
auch dich wirklich zurückziehen kannst.
Denn auch Zürich wird nicht sicher sein.
Na meinst du, die Schweiz wird es ja vielleicht noch so eine besondere Insel
dann werden. Also ich habe da die Hoffnung.
Ich glaube, so ein nuklearer Fallout ist relativ groß.
Ich habe mich tatsächlich informiert,
wie das dann ist, wenn man als Deutschland-Schweizer Konto eröffnen will.
Ist schwierig. Denn, also entweder hat man regelmäßig in der Schweiz zu tun,
das will ich natürlich ausbauen mit vielen Auftritten, dann könnte ich das rechtfertigen
und sagen, dann kann ich da das Honorar mir drauf spielen lassen.
Und sonst braucht man so eine Million, die man auf dieses Konto drauf spielt.
Und da muss ich noch ein paar Vorträge hatten, ja.
Aber wir haben hier Diskussionen, die ich heute noch, sagen wir mal,
wir gehen jetzt mal mit mit dieser Idee, heute noch, im letzten Sommer vor dem Krieg,
Behandeln wir das noch als politische Fragen? Das wird uns, wenn das alles ernst
gemeint ist, ganz albern vorkommen.
Ja, wir werden darauf noch ganz spät im Podcast kommen.
Das wird erschütternd sein, das kann ich jetzt schon sagen. Wir haben ja im
Salon über das Buch von Palantir-Chef Alex Karp gesprochen und der sagt,
diese ganze E-Commerce-Silicon-Valley-Scheiße, die will ich nicht haben.
Die Leute sollen jetzt mal wieder sich in einem Kollektiv und zwar dem Nationalen
einfügen und die großen Tech-Konzerne sollen umstellen auf das,
was wirklich benötigt wird.
Das ist zum einen eine Infrastruktur und zum anderen ist das natürlich Rüstung.
Marc Andreessen von Andreessen Horowitz, der ja in dieser ideologischen Bubble
mit drin hängt, hat bei Twitter folgendes Video veröffentlicht.
Wir hören jetzt nur Musik, aber vielleicht können wir ein bisschen beschreiben, was wir da sehen.
Also hier wird schon eingeblendet. Amerika. We build the Empire State Building.
In the 40 days we build the stream. Also es wird jetzt nochmal NASA-Raketen.
Acht Jahre bis zur Mondlandung.
Flugzeug wurde erfunden.
Monogramm.
Television, iPhone.
Und jetzt plötzlich ein bisschen Tempo, oder was? Nein. Jetzt kommen die Computer,
die ganze digitale Vernetzung, die Freiheitsstatue wird uns gezeigt.
Jetzt große Raketenheben ab, Cowboys auch nicht gern.
Und jetzt Rüstung.
Gott schützt unsere Truppen.
Flugzeugträger Darth Vader in einem Schronen zu Wasser.
It's time to build wird angeblendet for America.
American Dynamism wofür.
Mark and Priest Werbung macht dieses.
A16 Set ist ja seine Dings mit Andresen Horowitz.
Ja.
Also ich habe vorhin in dieser Grafik von Bernie Sanders gesehen,
Marc Andresen hatte 41,3 und Horowitz 41,2 Millionen für die Wahlkampagnen gesponsert.
Ja.
Jetzt würden wir noch ein Return on Investment.
Genau. Und das ist genau das, was wir jetzt erleben. Also man geht weg von E-Commerce,
wir haben noch eine Dating-App programmiert und was weiß ich,
und geht hin zu eben diesem Aufrüstungsprogramm.
Das ist also Also jetzt das neue westliche Projekt, könnte man sagen,
das wir in all diesen Ländern beobachten können, dass man sagt,
unser Fokus liegt jetzt darauf und man kann interessanterweise damit ja sehr
viele auf seine Seite ziehen, wo man es eher nicht gedacht hat.
Also es war ja zum Beispiel jetzt bei Markus Lanz kürzlich Ulrike Herrmann,
Freude strahlend zu erleben, wie sie sich freute darüber,
dass jetzt die Autoindustrie schwächelt, dadurch Arbeitskräfte frei werden,
die dann in der Rüstungsindustrie arbeiten. Das ist jetzt diese neue Idee.
Zugfabriken, ungewidmet. Bombardier, hat ja Ulrich Herrmann vor Monaten gesagt.
Wir sollen eh nicht so viel mit dem ICE hin und her fahren. Ist doch jetzt wunderbar.
Wenn schon gar keine mehr gebaut werden, machen wir lieber Panzer.
Also ich finde es in Zeiten dieses politischen Chaos, bei dem auch alle fragen,
was macht die Trump-Begehung jetzt und so.
Dass man denjenigen, die jetzt über Jahre gefordert haben, dass der Staat doch
endlich mal handlungsfähig ist, um das Coronavirus zu besiegen,
einfach eine neue Idee unterjubelt.
Ja.
Das ist für mich ein roter Faden.
Und damit ist aber auch Alex Karp schon mitten in unserer Gesellschaft angekommen.
Absolut.
Bernd Ulrich hat in der Zeit gefordert, einen Feiertag weg, Wehrpflicht einführen und aufrüsten.
Wir hören jetzt bei OMR Florian Heinemann, der ist ein Venture Capital Fonds
Gründer und zwar Project A heißt das.
Wie auch sonst, Project A.
Und der sagt jetzt erstmal folgendes.
Wirtschaft, ohne das werden alle Aufgaben nicht lösbar sein.
Und ich glaube, wir bewegen uns halt in die Welt rein und ich versuche das ja
immer unideologisch zu sehen.
Da zählt halt wirtschaftliche und auch militärische Macht und die wird nur aufzubauen
sein, wenn wir eben eine wachsende Wirtschaft haben.
Und deswegen ist es, glaube ich, ganz wichtig, dass man nicht versucht,
so diesen Widerspruch aufzumachen zwischen das Kapital und sozusagen die Arbeit
oder die Kapitalisten und die Arbeitenden.
Das ist einfach, das ist ein überkommendes Weltbild.
Denn jetzt kennen wir nur noch Deutsche. Also das ist wirklich diese Idee.
Bitte, liebe Gewerkschaften, haltet euch zurück. es gibt nicht mehr irgendein
Spannungsverhältnis zwischen Kapital und Arbeit.
Nein, wir alle haben ja gemeinsam zu kämpfen für Europa, die Demokratie, was auch immer.
Und das wird jetzt hier in so einem Investor-Podcast einfach mal verlautbar.
Ich will dir was vorlesen, was, ich will es mal so labeln,
Jemand hat einfach den Auftrag bekommen, jetzt reden Sie mal einfach,
sagen Sie einfach irgendwas, ist mir egal was.
Es war sozusagen ein freies Gespräch von jemandem, der ansonsten nur drei Minuten
Snippets abliefert, heute Journal.
Dort verantwortliche Rollen hatte, wie Chef des heute Journals zu sein,
jetzt Korrespondent in Washington, Elmar Thewissen.
Und Elmar Thewissen sprang ein kurzfristig für Ulf Röller bei einem Gespräch
in der Oper zu der Wiederaufführung aus einem Totenhaus.
Da gibt es ja immer Termine, die dann Michael Friedmann bestreitet und die laufen
ja immer unter einem Grundbegriff, in dem Falle Opportunismus.
Ich hatte mich sehr auf Ulf Röller gefreut, denn Ulf Röller war ja unter Trump
1 Amerika-Korrespondent, dann Corona-Pandemie in Peking und jetzt in Brüssel gerade.
Und wir wissen ja immer nicht so genau, wer in Brüssel regiert.
Also da sind einfach keine Strongmans.
Und dadurch ist ja immer super interessant, diesen Zeitglas aus Brüssel aufzugreifen.
Elmar Thewissen sitzt also in dieser Veranstaltung, in der Freundschaftsdienst,
ich springe ein für dich, Ulf. Ich weiß nicht, was du hast, aber okay.
Und dann, das Gespräch läuft schon eine Stunde.
Und die Frage von Michael Friedmann war einfach nur, jetzt sagen Sie doch mal
ganz optimistisch, was optimistisch ist.
Nachdem eine Stunde lang, ach, Amerika hat Scham, wir kommen nicht mehr weiter und so fort.
Und dann setzt Elmar Thewissen an und schüttelt Folgendes aus dem Ärmel.
Das ist ein bisschen länger, ich lese mal vor.
Und wenn man den Anschein erweckt, als könnte man mit den riesigen Herausforderungen,
die wir momentan haben, einfach so fertig werden, indem man nur Geld in die
Kasse füllt, dann riskiert man, dass wir die Kurve eben nicht bekommen.
Keiner weiß, welche Kurve, keiner weiß, wovon er hier spricht und so.
Wer hier in Anschein erweckt, welche Herausforderungen. Also es ist wirklich bescheuert.
Woher kommt das Geld? Von wem? Wer setzt es ein?
Genau. So, weiter geht's. Die Zeit ist knapp. Welche Zeit? Was ist knapp? Warum die Eile?
Kann man nicht einfach erstmal nach Athen fahren? Nein, es gibt eine Deadline,
die ist drei, vier Jahre maximal.
Es muss ein Plan innerhalb der nächsten Monate, eigentlich bis zum Sommer entstehen
und ein Narrativ, um der Bevölkerung genau klar zu machen, jetzt zählt es,
jetzt geht es um die Wurst, jetzt kommt es darauf an.
Man fragt sich, worauf kommt es denn jetzt an, was ist denn mit der Wurst und so?
Nehmen wir an die Werbpflicht.
Er redet einfach mal weiter. Und dazu gehören Fragen wie,
dass man selber auch Verzicht übt, indem man möglicherweise im Steuerbereich,
möglicherweise in der Frage eines Feiertags, in der Einführung einer Wehrpflicht,
die sicherlich in der Bevölkerung auch dann klar macht, wie weit die Einschränkung
geht, weil es jetzt drauf ankommt.
Und wenn das nicht kommt, sondern der Anschein erweckt wird,
man könnte das alles mit ein bisschen mehr Geld lösen, auch wenn es ziemlich
viel Geld ist, eine Billion, dann wird das nicht geschafft.
Toll.
So, wir haben also jetzt die Situation, in der Journalisten...
Die die ganze Zeit davor warnen, jetzt keine einfachen Antworten,
nur weil die Leute irgendwie einen Strongman suchen, heißt das noch lange nicht,
dass wir einen brauchen und so weiter.
Zwar eine Billion Euro im Raum stehen sehen und ich finde auch sehr viele soziale
Fragen, also ich wüsste nicht, ist jetzt unklar, was wir mit einer Billion Euro machen sollen. so, ja.
Plötzlich so da sitzen und sagen, Mist, mir fehlt noch eine Idee.
Ich hätte gern so eine ganz einfache Antwort, dass jetzt jemand vor mir steht und sagt, das ist es.
Das ist die Idee, damit ich meiner Bevölkerung, die mir millionenfach abends
zuschaut, klar machen kann, jetzt geht es um die Wurst.
Also dieses Horowitz-Video, das ist quasi für Elmar Thewissen gemacht,
der nämlich völlig wie so ein Gockel, dem Kopf abgeschlagen,
über den Hof rennt und einfach nicht weiß, wo geht es denn jetzt weiter und
so. Und der braucht jetzt einfach...
Und zur Not gehen wir mal Druck nach unten ab.
Genau. Elmar Tewissen braucht jetzt einfach die Ansage. Sehr gut,
als Verzichtsappell hast du sehr gut gemacht.
Und ab jetzt hier Aufrüstung, Krieg, Feinde suchen und dann in die Richtung, da geht es lang und so.
Also die warten im Grunde. Wir warnen vor Alex Karp und diesem Buch und der
Elektronischen Republik. Elmar Tewissen wartet drauf.
Also ich sage dir, wenn das ins Deutsche übersetzt wird und die das dann in
die Finger bekommen, oh Gott.
Das wird deren neue Bibel.
Ja, ja.
Endlich wieder,
Kurs statt Chaos, wie ja mein Ministerpräsident immer sagt.
Ich hatte ein Gespräch mit einer Journalistin und die habe ich ernsthaft gefragt,
also das war ein internes Gespräch,
die habe ich ernsthaft gefragt, ob sie irgendjemanden aus dem A-Liga-Journalismus
kennt, also von denen, die vorne sind und sie kennt diese Leute,
die gegen die Wehrpflicht sind.
Gibt es irgendeinen, wo sie sagen könnte, da ist jemand gegen die Wehrpflicht
und sie konnte mir keinen Namen nennen. Interessant.
Ist hier jemand gegen die Impfpflicht?
Ja.
Nö, wir haben ja niemanden gegen die Impfpflicht.
Wir kommen gleich noch zu Alena Wüchsler.
Aber wir wissen übrigens, was aus der Impfpflicht geworden ist.
Und ich sage, Wehrpflicht ist genau so ein Rohrkrepierer.
Okay. Wie gesagt, ich hoffe immer, dass du recht hast. Oder fast immer.
Florian Heinemann hier jetzt über die Europäisierung, wie er sich das vorstellt.
Also die Finanzleute gucken natürlich ein bisschen anders drauf.
Und das ist auch meine Hoffnung, dass eben sozusagen das, was wir jetzt gerade sehen, in den USA,
dass das eben die Europäer dazu treibt, zu sagen, okay, es bringt halt nichts,
wenn wir in Frankreich, in Paris, in Amsterdam und dann noch in London irgendwie
Börsenplätze unterhalten, die alle unterkritisch sind, was Technologie angeht,
sondern wir müssen einen Weg finden, hier zusammenzuarbeiten.
Und ich hoffe sozusagen, dass jetzt die Ereignisse der letzten sechs Wochen
nochmal dazu beitragen, vielleicht die Ressentiments eben zu überwinden.
Also da geht es eigentlich um so eine Vereinheitlichung von Börse und sowas,
wo man auch sicherlich darüber diskutieren kann, ob das sinnvoll sein kann.
Interessant also, dass das sehr viel stärker oder viel ausgeweiteter zu betrachten
ist, als wir das jetzt gerade haben in diesem rein auf die Rüstung dominierten Diskurs.
Wir haben ja uns lange gefragt, wer ist eigentlich der Verfechter der Schuldenbremse?
Und die Antwort war ja immer, Leute mit Spielgeld. Weil wenn der Staat jetzt
plötzlich als und so auftritt und selber Häuser baut, wäre ja blöd.
Bis ja Investitionen jemand anderen, also kriegt dann auch der die Rendite und
vielleicht will der Staat gar keine und dann sinken auch noch die Mietpreise,
also das geht ja gar nicht.
Wir wollen ja immer Nachrichten, ist ja auch erstaunlich, wir kriegen ja immer
Nachrichten für die Massen, was weiß ich, eine Frankfurter Rundschau oder so, dann steht ja immer,
Und Frankfurter Mietmarkt erholt sich. Und man denkt so, cool,
Preise steigen wieder. Also es ist ja völlig verdreht eigentlich.
So, jetzt haben wir dieses Angebot. Er möchte gerne die Technologie unterkritischen
Börsen zusammenlegen, damit die Schlagkraft stärker ist.
Ich habe 10.000 Euro extra und möchte dann nicht mehr der Gefahr laufen,
dass ich auf dem falschen Börsenplatz investiert habe, obwohl doch die Unicorns
alle in London gelistet sind und so.
Deswegen vereinheitlichen, damit ich einfach weiß, ich suche mir die gutste Firma raus.
Und für die Unternehmen natürlich, die ein IPO machen wollen.
Genau, für die ist es auch super easy. Die wissen dann, wo es lang geht.
Wir haben aber ein Gegenangebot gerade.
Und zwar von Richard David Precht. Der macht es natürlich salopp im Gespräch, im Podcast mit Lanz.
Wir hören es nachher. Elmer, nicht Elmer, sondern Thomas de Maizière,
Andreas Voskuhle, Julia Jekyll und so, die nämlich jetzt plötzlich sagen,
der Staat sollte als strategischer Investor auftreten.
Ja, und das sieht er aber inzwischen auch so. Pass auf.
Bin gespannt.
Der ganze Bereich Defense kommt nochmal dazu.
Ich glaube, wir müssen uns insgesamt überlegen auf europäischer Ebene,
wie schaffe ich es aus dieser Einzelfalllogik rauszukommen hin zu,
das sind die sieben, acht, zehn Technologiefelder, die wollen wir fördern.
So machen wir das im Mittelstand, so fördern wir Startups und so sorgen wir
auch dafür, dass der Staat, häufig hilft es ja auch schon, wenn der Staat zuverlässiger
Kunde ist. Wir sehen es jetzt ja auch im Bereich Defense.
Viel passiert da jetzt auch gerade oder deutlich mehr als vorher zumindest,
weil im Prinzip die Armeen in Europa oder auch die NATO-Armeen deutlich schneller
und experimentierfreudiger bereit sind, von Startups zu sourcen.
Das reicht häufig schon, da brauchst du gar keine Förderung mehr,
sondern alleine, wenn sozusagen dort Anreize geschaffen werden,
um eben mit solchen Firmen früh zusammenzuarbeiten, passiert schon viel in die richtige Richtung.
Ja, also wenn jetzt jemand zu mir käme und sagte, Stefan, ich bist ja ein kluger
Typ, ich brauche mal Beraterleistung.
Mein Projekt ist folgendes.
Ich möchte, dass der Staat über sein demokratisch gewähltes Gremium mir 400
Milliarden für mein Rüstungsbusiness verschafft.
Und ich will aber gleichzeitig alle 400 Milliarden, also ich will nicht,
dass irgendein Bürgergeldempfänger kommt und sagt, ich hätte gern auch was davon,
weil der hat ja das Gräbo mitgewählt.
Dann würde ich sagen, sorry, ist nicht mit meinem Gewissen vereinbar.
Offenbar haben die aber Berater gefunden, die ihnen versprochen haben,
du kriegst deine 400 Milliarden und wir legen noch ein bisschen von dem Bürgergeld Leuten drauf.
Wir nehmen denen noch was weg. Das Programm sehen wir gerade.
Ja, und das finden die natürlich großartig, denn jetzt lohnen sich ja Investitionen
plötzlich in diesem Unternehmen.
Public-Private-Partnership.
Ja, die ganze Zeit war man ja gegen den Staat, weil der hat natürlich nicht
die Dating-App unterstützt.
Also das hat er nicht getan. Aber jetzt kann man natürlich den Staat nicht nur
als den erkennen, der Steuern nimmt, sondern der auch Investitionen tätig,
beziehungsweise eine Investitionssicherheit bietet.
Westermeyer, der Moderator, fragt danach.
Was waren eure letzten Investments? Habt ihr irgendwas gemacht in dem Bereich?
Oder generell, um mal so rauszuhören, dein Day-to-day-Business,
was hat Project A zuletzt so finanziert?
Jetzt?
Dating, ne? Wir brauchen keine Dating-Apps mehr. Ab sofort, wir sprechen uns
auf der Straße an, Wolfgang, was war dein letztes Investment?
Ja, oder?
Dann sagst du irgendwas, dann sage ich, ich würde keinen Kaffee mit dir trinken.
Oder wo hast du gedient?
Wo hast du gedient, ja.
Können wir auch machen. Heinemann erzählt hier über ein Investment.
Labris haben wir ja gerade gemacht. Das ist so eine Mischung oder eine Schnittstelle
zwischen die Fans und sozusagen humanitärer Hilfe.
Da geht es also sozusagen um ein letztendlich ein System, was dabei hilft oder
eine Softwarelösung, die dabei hilft, Einsätze auf der Softwareseite zu koordinieren.
Also sowohl im Battlefield als auch theoretisch humanitäre Einsätze,
wo es ja immer darum geht, wie kann ich die verschiedenen Parteien in einem System koordinieren.
Und Labris hilft dabei als ein UK-Startup.
Ja, weiter.
Also wenn Frank Schirrmacher noch dabei wäre und hier das publizistisch begleiten
könnte, da würde er gar keine Bücher mehr schreiben. Da würde er nur noch so Notizen rausgeben.
Ich habe es euch immer gesagt, Targeting,
Das ist nicht Werbebranche. Das ist Rüstung. Die üben nur im Supermarkt.
Haben die gar kein Problem damit. Das ist interessant, wer auch dann mit dem
Investor da so befreundet ist.
Aus der sehr woken Musikindustrie. Leute, die da auch dann mit investieren. Die sonst sagen.
Geld macht so gefügig.
Das sind so Leute, die sagen, ich kann nicht irgendwo auf einem Festival auftreten,
wo Nena dabei ist. Das ist irgendwie schlecht. Ich ist ja auch gegen Impfen.
Aber ich kann natürlich da mitmachen. Und jetzt, auch Westerbeier wundert sich.
Das scheint relativ jetzt auch defense-lastig mittlerweile. Ja,
also ich würde sagen so vielleicht 25 Prozent oder so.
Also vielleicht so null mal vor ein paar Jahren, wo man nur über E-Commerce
redete und sowas. Das ist schon krass.
Ja, das ist schon, genau. Und das ist schon viel, was wir machen.
Genau das, was jetzt Alex Karp sagt.
Also insofern, uns wird nicht langweilig. Aber E-Commerce und so ist jetzt erstmal nicht mehr da. Wenig.
Also klassisch so Digital Content. Ab und zu im Private-Equity-Bereich noch,
wo wir auch unterwegs sind, da machen wir noch was E-Commerce-lastiges,
aber ansonsten ist es schon 80, 90 Prozent B2B mittlerweile, ja.
Einfach E-Commerce vorbei, B2B, das ist jetzt das Neue und da machen dann zum
Teil die D-Kurs-Leute mit, weil die sagen, endlich hört diese Konsumkultur mal auf.
Heute nur Pointen an der Stelle, es ist viel zu düster für was anderes,
wenn man Kinder erzieht, hat man ja so verschiedene Geschichten,
weil die Elterngeneration redet ja mit, also die,
Großelterngenerationen und dann sind das so Sachen wie, früher haben ja noch
alle Kinder draußen gespielt, heute indoor,
früher haben ja alle noch Fernsehen geschaut, heute nur noch TikTok also du
hast immer sozusagen, das was immer verteufelt wurde, ist dann plötzlich so,
ah das war noch schön, es wird wirklich die Zeit kommen, in der die Leute in
ihren Panzern sitzen und sagen, weißt du noch früher,
als wir einfach fünf Stunden TikTok gescrollt haben,
friedliche Zeit und so. Das ist ganz schlimm.
Hier sieht man auch wieder, wenn du ein Investor bist und auf Komfort setzt.
Die Leute haben ja schon alles, was sie brauchen.
Da muss ja einfach nur noch alles bequemer werden.
Die nächste Stufe zur Bequemlichkeit ist einfach einen Panzer zu verkaufen.
Dann wird deine Limousine noch bequemer.
Wenn du zehn Panzer verkaufst, kriegt sie plötzlich Flügel, Privatjet,
ja, also diese Verknüpfung, dass das so einfach möglich ist, ist so sensationell.
Muss man sich nicht mit Lieferando und Delivery Hero rumschlagen und so einen
ganzen Kram, das ist jetzt einfach gut, der Staat nimmt es direkt ab und geht
dann in die Privatwirtschaft.
Wir hören jetzt noch einmal Franz Stephan Gardi, denn damit das alles auch so
kommt und akzeptiert bleibt, muss man was tun? Natürlich das Denken ändern.
Die Wiederherstellung des Abschreckungspotenzials. Das funktioniert aber nicht
nur rein auf der materiellen Ebene, was viel wichtiger ist.
Und daher nenne ich ja mein Buch Die Rückkehr des Krieges muss vor allem in
den Köpfen politischer Entscheidungsträger und Trägerinnen,
Wir müssen unserer Streitkräfte nicht durch den Frieden mehr denken,
sondern vor allem durch den Krieg, um dieses Abschreckungspotenzial zu stärken.
Weil nur wenn wir den Willen haben, in den Krieg zu ziehen, können wir auch
einen potenziellen Aggressor abschrecken.
Und das sind alles frevelhafte Ausdrücke, die ich hier benutze für einen deutschen
Politiker, eine deutsche Politikerin. Da geht es gleich in die Kriegsträberei und das alles.
Da möchte ich nur sagen, die Leute, die das behaupten, sind wirklich Opfer eines
sogenannten parasitären Pazifismuses.
Bleibt doch unwidersprochen.
Die Not alleine reicht nicht. Du musst doch wollen.
Parasiterer Pazifismus, das ist also das Neue nach dem Lumpen Pazifismus.
Und du kennst es vielleicht auch, manchmal sind deine Gedanken nicht so klar.
Du weißt nicht so recht, wo ist eigentlich oben und unten.
Manchmal habe ich auch in Elmer Thewesen.
Vielleicht brauchst du einfach mal eine Feindbegegnung.
Nun, ich glaube, was jetzt die Beziehung Deutschland zu militärischer Gewalt
betrifft, Weil um das geht es ja, glaube ich, liegt noch ein sehr weiter und langer Weg vor uns.
Es gibt aber diesen Ausspruch eben, und verzeihen Sie, dass ich immer wieder
englische Zitate bringe, von Dr. Johnson aus dem 18.
Jahrhundert, der mal gemeinte, wenn man eben einem Mann seinen Gargen zeigt,
an dem er gehängt wird, im Englischen hat er den Ausdruck reingeschrieben im
Buch, it concentrates the mind, also es konzentriert quasi den Geist,
wenn man seine eigene Zerstörung eben vor Augen hat.
Und in dieser Hinsicht glaube ich schon, dass wir langsam die Realisierung im
haben, im deutschsprachigen Europa, wenn ich da andere Länder auch mit einbeziehen kann.
In diesem Podcast bringen die ja immer ein Geräusch mit.
Ja.
Und er hatte ja so einen Abschuss von irgendeiner Waffe.
Und dann haben die gefragt, was ist denn das für ein Geräusch,
wieso haben sie denn das mitgebracht? Und er so, ja diese Waffe wurde auf mich abgeschossen.
Und eigentlich sollte sie mich treffen, aber da ich mein Aid Kit verloren hatte
und mich bückte und so. und er ist halt immer in Kriegsgebieten unterwegs,
weil er gerne mit den Soldaten an der Front spricht.
Und jetzt denkt man so, okay, also der redet mit Soldaten im Gefecht und ist
auch in diesen Gefechtssituationen dabei und bringt dann ein Geräusch mit,
das ihm fast das Leben gekostet hätte.
Der wird ja wohl die folgende Stunde damit verbringen, uns zu sagen,
Krieg ist ganz schlecht.
Ich habe es gesehen, ich habe es gehört und fast wäre ich gestorben.
Dürfen wir nicht machen.
Stattdessen ist irgendwie seine Vorstellung, das sollten wir jetzt alle mal erleben.
Ja, es ist verrückt.
Aber die Zeit so, wir nennen es politischen Podcast, ist uns egal,
wo sie das gerade hören, sie sind auf dem Weg zur Arbeit, was arbeiten sie denn,
ist uns auch egal, wir spielen das jetzt einfach.
Gucken Sie auch heute schon mal auf den Galgen. Das klärt den Kopf.
Dann habe ich im Deutschlandfunk den Podcast von Corbinian Frenzel gehört.
Dort war Alena Büx zu Gast. Gut, wir wissen, wir lieben sie von Stunde eins dieses Podcasts an.
Ich kann wirklich auch sagen, ich habe den gesamten Podcast gehört und es ist
nicht ein Satz, bei dem ich sagen würde, ja, das aber….
Das hätte ich dir vorher sagen können.
Ja, oder irgendwas Intelligentes. Aber wir wollen es nur auf diese Sache Wehrpflicht,
Aufrüstung mal konzentrieren.
Es geht zunächst mal um dieses Gesellschaftsjahr und diese Idee von Freiwilligkeit.
Also ich habe viel Sympathien für so eine Idee. Ich habe auch schon mal öffentlich
das zum Ausdruck gebracht. Allerdings finde ich ganz, ganz wichtig,
dass das nicht was ist, was man jetzt nur der jungen Generation umhängen würde,
sondern wenn dann wirklich tatsächlich für alle und es gibt da durchaus auch viel Interesse.
Also es können sich auch Leute in der Mitte des Lebens oder auch die aus dem
Beruf ausgeschieden sind, sowas sehr häufig vorstellen und das sollte man unbedingt abholen.
Da will ich auch nochmal sagen, wer sich das ja vorstellen kann, kann das ja machen.
Also wenn ich mich jetzt ein Jahr engagieren will oder wenn ich in Rente bin
und sage, ich habe jetzt nochmal Lust, ich werde mit offenen Armen empfangen.
Ich kann im Tierheim Tiere ausführen, ich kann mich in den Grundschulen melden,
um vorzulesen, ich kann ältere Leute betreuen bei den Einkäufen,
als Gesellschaft da dort auftreten.
Es gibt tausende Möglichkeiten, die Vereine vom Karnevals- bis zum Sportverein,
alle suchen nach Leuten, die irgendwo eine helfende Hand haben,
Kuchen backen für Sonntag. Es ist alles da.
Du musst auch heute kein Fußballspieler sein, um Fußballtraining zu machen.
Ja, ich brauche keine Organisation, die mir vom Start aus sagt,
und jetzt los, sondern ich könnte es einfach jetzt gerade machen.
Also ich kann jetzt hier in Frankfurt vor die Tür gehen und zehn Meter weiter
mich irgendwo engagieren.
Wir nehmen dich alle mit Handkuss.
Ja, es ist, also wenn die Leute das immer sagen, also ich kriege das auch immer
jetzt so vorgerufen, ja, aber Engagement ist doch wichtig. Ich frage immer,
ja, aber dann engagier dich doch.
Was machst du denn da gerade? Anders anpreisen. Meine Beobachtung ist,
Leuten wird ja immer unterstellt in diesem Instagram-Zeitalter,
sie wollen was hermachen.
Ich empfehle sehr aus eigener Erfahrung einfach in der Grundschule anfragen,
soll ich euch mal die Vorstellung des Fördervereins ein bisschen aufpeppen in
diesen drei Minuten, in denen die Eltern davon erfahren, dass es das auch noch
gibt, weil sonst die Schule nicht funktioniert.
Ich habe das dann also zu antiken Zeiten mal einmal gemacht.
Ich werde immer noch auf der Straße angesprochen.
Sie sind doch der Förderverein. Wo ist denn die Frau Schmidt?
Wenn ich dann in diesen Momenten sagen würde, ja, die hatte erst gedacht,
sie hat Husten, aber jetzt hat sie plötzlich Krebs.
Wenn die irgendwann in 40 Jahren mal stirbt, würde es heißen,
ah, die hatte ja auch Krebs.
Also ich bin sozusagen, ich kann das voll ausspielen. Also einmal so ein kleines,
also wer richtig was hermachen will, nicht Instagram oder so,
Sondern einfach drei Minuten lang mal öffentlich so einen Verein darstellen
und danach bist du Mann von Welt in deinem Stadtgebiet.
Eltern liegen dir zu Füßen, wenn du Fußballtraining anbietest.
Die sagen dann zwar so Sachen wie, habe ich gestern das wieder gehört,
das ist ja jetzt nicht so das tolle Training.
Die sind auch erst 15, selber noch jung und so.
Aber dann gleich im nächsten Satz, ja, aber die rennen halt draußen rum und
das ist so schön und überhaupt und so.
Alle sind ihnen dankbar und so. Also man kann sehr viel Local Fame abgreifen,
wenn man einfach deiner Empfehlung folgt. mal so ein paar Sachen zu machen.
Ja, aber weißt du, so freiwillig, das ist doch nichts hier. Hör doch mal.
Gleichzeitig habe ich auch eine gewisse Sympathie dafür, nicht zu sagen,
das sollte nur freiwillig laufen.
Weil dann machen es nur die, die ohnehin sozusagen sehr gemeinwohlorientiert sind.
Und die Idee von so einem Jahr ist ja, du kriegst das hin, was früher nur für
Männer Wehrdienst-Zivildienst gemacht haben. Alle mischen sich.
Du triffst alle Leute aus allen Schichten, von allen Bildungsniveaus und so.
Und das ist eine gute Erfahrung.
Und man lernt sozusagen mal das echte pralle Leben kennen.
Deswegen würde ich mir dafür natürlich plädieren, dass es wirklich für alle,
also selbstverständlich dann auch für Frauen...
So können nur Leute sprechen, die mit dem Leben nichts zu tun haben.
Die sich nur von Podium zu Podium bewegen und auch da mit dem Publikum,
das dort sitzt, selbst mit dem Publikum nicht in Kontakt treten.
Die reden genau so. Denn jeder Mensch, der normalerweise eine Sozialisierung
in Familie und Freundeskreis hat und vielleicht auch Arbeitskollegen hat oder
auch mal sonst unterwegs ist in Kneipen oder sonst wo,
wird mit dem Leben konfrontiert.
Es sei denn, man ist ehemalige Ethikratsvorsitzende und hat da den Vorsitz gehabt
und während einer Pandemie dann plötzlich so nach anderthalb,
zwei Jahren mal gedacht, stimmt, die Kinder, da müsste man auch mal drüber reden.
Also das ist schon erstaunlich, dass man so weltfremd sein kann,
das glaube ich wohl, dass das etwas ist, was einen jetzt im Nachhinein vielleicht auch irritiert,
nur das dann allen aufzuoktroyieren, nur weil man selbst diese Weltferne hat,
das finde ich doch ein bisschen eigenartig.
Also von mir nur ein paar Antworten zum Thema, aber ich meine alle ernst.
Ich will jetzt gleich einiges aufmachen. Ich habe mich ja eben schon darüber
beschwert, dass ja ein Panzer keinen funktionellen Grund hat,
außer halt, er liegt als Bedrohung in einem Lager, also wird einfach gestapelt.
Im Grunde baust du eine Fabrik und dann die Halle direkt daneben und dann fährt
er halt drüber und dann war wieder einer fertig.
Wenn ich jetzt nach öffentlichem Engagement suche, Leute verlassen ihre private
Komfortzone und engagieren sich auch für Leute, die vielleicht mal nicht über
Geburtenfolge mit ihnen verbandelt sind, sondern einfach auch Jung brauchen
Hilfe, man kümmert sich.
Wenn man dann sagt in einem öffentlichen Gespräch, das Engagement sollte darin
bestehen, im Wald schon mal üben, Schützengraben auszuheben,
dann ist das genauso dumm, wie
ein Fabrikpanzer einfach rüber in die Werkshalle zu fahren, wo er lagert.
Das ist einfach verschwendete Lebensmühe. Auf der einen Seite hat man Geld verschwendet
und Stahl und alles und diese Arbeitskraft und auf der anderen Seite bei der
Frage, wozu brauche ich einen Schützengraben? Nie.
Wenn ein Krieg kommt. Ja, das war ein tolles zivilisatorisches Engagement.
Ich habe mich jetzt eingebracht.
Es geht auch weiter.
Meine sorgenvolle Erwartung ist, dass sich diese Diskussion ein bisschen erledigen
wird, weil ich davon ausgehe, dass wir sehr bald, sehr schnell über die ausgesetzte
Wehrpflicht debattieren werden.
Wenn sich sozusagen mit Blick auf die Sicherheitsfragen, die wir ja schon angetönt
haben vorhin, da ein neues Denken in Deutschland etablieren wird,
ist das sicherlich etwas, was besprochen werden wird.
Und in dem Zuge wird man auch darüber diskutieren, okay, also es wäre ungerecht,
wenn das jetzt nur, es soll ja jetzt erfasst werden, hat der Pistorius auch
gesagt, dass man mal erfasst, wer da überhaupt in Frage kommt.
Und es wäre ein Stück weit ja ungerechter, nur denen wiederum etwas umzuhängen.
Und ich glaube, damit wird dann sehr schnell dieses Gesellschaftsjahr für die
anderen, die dafür nicht infrage
kommen, gegebenenfalls auch in einer verpflichtenden Form relevant werden.
Und weiter sagt sie dann.
Irgendwie sind wir gedanklich da auch schon bei dieser großen Frage der Staatsreform,
die wir eben gerade besprochen haben.
Also wie beweglich sind wir eigentlich dann wirklich große Räder zu drehen?
Da habe ich so meine Zweifel. Also was dieses Thema anbelangt,
bin ich da zuversichtlicher, weil die Diskussion gibt es jetzt ja schon so um die zwei Jahre.
Die hat es immer gegeben, immer mal wieder. Der Bundespräsident war da sehr
engagiert beispielsweise.
Der hat das aus Tapet gebracht und interessanterweise, wenn man das verfolgt,
hört man aus sehr vielen verschiedenen Parteien durchaus Unterstützung dafür.
Also dann im Zweifel auch zum Beispiel mit der AfD, weil ich glaube,
die wäre eher dabei als die Linke.
Das kann ich nicht einschätzen, aber...
Das kann sie nicht einschätzen.
Schade, sie wurde hier gerade und jetzt ist leider ihr Denkapparat nicht schnell genug.
Ja, also. Sie kann es ja erst, sollen wir noch die Folge antworten, sie redet weiter dann.
Sie redet ja einfach über AfD, stimmt die AfD würde da irgendwie zustimmen und
die wollen ja auch 5% mehr und so.
Zwei Drittel mehr halt. Sorry, Error, Error, Error und so und sie weiß nicht weiter.
Nun, wir können ja nicht einfach sagen, nur weil die AfD mitredet,
ist es eine schlechte oder eine gute Idee.
Und sie hat ja gerade gesagt, schade, dass wir demnächst über die Wehrpflicht
reden, weil dann meine super Idee vom zivilisatronischen Engagement und so weiter.
Wenn wir so an Diskussionen herangehen, also dass wir einfach immer feststellen,
die Diskussion ist legit alleine, weil ich sie als Idee aufwerfe.
Aber die Ziele und so weiter überdenke ich jetzt einfach nicht. Es ist halt, wie es ist.
Dann möchte ich auch, dass Alena Böcks in Podcasts darüber redet,
dass die AfD ja völlig legit als demnächst dann auch größte Oppositionsfraktion
und sowieso auch demnächst mal größte Fraktion im Bundestag einfach sagt,
doch, doch, wir meinen das mit dieser Remigration schon ernst und das mit den Frauen am Herd auch.
Und dann kommt jemand und sagt, naja, aber ich habe nochmal nachgeschaut,
minus 10 Millionen Ausländer, minus 15 Millionen Frauen, dann arbeiten ja nur
noch 15 Millionen Leute in Deutschland.
Und dann muss man sagen, ja, wir sollten das jetzt nicht von hinten und vom
Ziel und von der Vernunft aus betrachten, sondern es ist halt eine Idee im Raume.
Wir müssen sie jetzt diskutieren.
Bei der AfD machen wir das nur nicht, weil es halt ein AfD-Vorschlag ist.
Und da würde ich jetzt aber sagen, nee, kommt, das ist mir jetzt egal,
ob das ein AfD-Vorschlag ist, er steht im Raum von einer großen Fraktion,
wir diskutieren das jetzt.
Und wenn es dann sich als lächerlich herausstellt, ist es halt so.
Und so würde ich gerne auch, dass an diese Diskussion herangegangen wird.
Beziehungsweise könnte man ja hier sehr hellhörig werden deshalb,
weil sie ja offenbar das mit der Zweidrittelmehrheit nicht versteht oder sie
will es nicht verstehen oder sie sagt, naja,
wenn das Ziel richtig ist, nämlich die Wehrpflicht einzuführen,
dann ist egal, wer am Ende zustimmt.
Sie führt ja weiter, dass sie aus.
Ich sehe jedenfalls bei den Parteien der sogenannten politischen Mitte relativ viel Unterstützung.
Und ob es dann und wie dann damit verfahren wird im neuen Bundestag,
wenn man zwei Drittel Mehrheiten finden muss, das werden wir sowieso sehr,
sehr bald feststellen. Da bin ich auch drauf gespannt, da wäre jetzt ein Teufel
tun und da was vorweggreifen.
Da glaube ich auch nicht, dass das verpflichtende Gesellschaftsjahr das erste sein wird.
Aber wenn das angegangen wird, glaube ich, ist das etwas, wo sich relativ,
also im Vergleich mit anderen Dingen, diese zwei Drittel finden lassen würden.
Ja, wie, wenn man Mathematik in der Grundschule hatte, dann weiß man doch,
wie eine Zweidrittelmehrheit zustande kommt.
Diese kommt jetzt in diesem aktuellen Bundestag nur noch zustande,
wenn entweder die Linke zustimmt oder die AfD.
Deshalb hat man ja genau das jetzt noch mit dem alten Bundestag gemacht, mit der Aufrüstung.
Worüber reden wir dann jetzt? Also die einzige Möglichkeit wäre ja,
dass man entweder die Linken überzeugt davon, dass eine Wehrpflicht eingeführt
wird oder die AfD, die muss man nicht davon überzeugen, die will das eh.
Ich glaube, wir kommen so langsam in diese Nähe. Also wenn die AfD will das
so sehr, dass die AfD sogar Mehrheiten herstellt, selbst wenn Teile der Regierung da ausfallen.
Wir kommen irgendwann dazu, dass die AfD völlig zu Recht dann sagen wird,
Das haben wir doch schon immer gesagt, eine geheime Abstimmung,
da wissen sie nicht, wie wir abgestimmt haben.
Und das war ja bei diesen ganzen Personalwahlen in Thüringen und so weiter ja
auch. Oder hier im Bundestag.
Nur weil sie jetzt sagen, wir hätten den Kemmerich als Ministerpräsident gewählt,
das stimmt doch gar nicht.
Und hier dann auch. Es gab jetzt eine Mehrheit für und so weiter.
Wir wissen nicht, wer da abgestimmt hat.
Der Journalist Kevin Gensheimer hatte ja getwittert und ich fand das eine sehr gute Pointe.
Aber alle Aufrüstungsdebatten müssen auch vor dem Hintergrund geführt werden,
dass der nächste oder sagen wir dann übernächste Verteidigungsminister ein AfD-Minister ist.
Ja, das will ich mal sehen, wie man das… Also muss man ja mal zusammenkriegen.
Bis der Krieg beginnt, ist alles noch Politik.
Ja, also Jan, er sagte nämlich, das wäre ja die Gefahr und das war ja doch die
ganze Zeit immer diese Debatte, wenn es zum Beispiel um Massenüberwachung oder
so in Deutschland ging, Überwachung von öffentlichen Plätzen.
Das sind alles die Tools, die geben wir dann der AfD-Regierung mal lieber nicht
in die Hand, deswegen lassen wir sie lieber fallen.
Und jetzt rüsten wir noch und nöcher auf, damit Bundeskanzlerin Alice Weidel
dann sagt, wir schießen uns mal den Handelsweg frei.
Ich würde da auch gerne nochmal eine rote Linie für mich ziehen.
Also wenn in der politischen Planung, die bisher läuft, auch von den Leuten,
die sie als Teil des politischen Prozesses und des Politiksystems sehen,
die eigentlich Berichterstattung sind.
Und wenn da eingepreist wird, dass ein AfD-Mann Verteidigungsminister sein könnte,
möchte ich doch von meinem Atombomending wieder abrücken.
Genau. Und das war ja ein Warnruf quasi von Kevin Gensheimer zu sagen, pass auf,
ihr rüstet jetzt auf, ihr rüstet auf und dann kommt irgendwann doch eine Koalition
mit der AfD und die sagt, wir nehmen auch das Verteidigungsministerium, das passt gut zu uns.
Jetzt nochmal auf die persönliche Ebene, kombinieren Frenze und Alena Büx.
Meine Jungs sind elf und dreizehn. Das hat für mich eine ganz konkrete Bedeutung.
Deswegen ist das auch nichts, worüber ich irgendwie flapsig rede oder nachdenke.
Aber ich gehe davon aus, dass wir das diskutieren müssen.
Und ich finde das zutiefst verstörend, aber es hilft ja nichts.
Also die geopolitische Lage wird sich nicht deswegen ändern,
weil man sowas verstörend findet.
Es hilft ja nichts. Wir haben ja sowas auch schon eben gehört.
Wir müssen da die Houthis eben mit Bomben bewerfen, hilft ja nichts.
Das ist genau diese Haltung. Jetzt wird nochmal nachgefragt,
konkret und das ist interessant.
Also ich will es nicht übertreiben mit meinen Pointen, aber die Erklärung für
Holocaust, die ich in den Dokumenten so gelesen habe aus Schulunterrichts und
so weiter, sind reformuliert auch alle. Es hilft ja nichts an Sprachen ans Publikum gewesen.
Also sagen wir so, um es ein bisschen abzuschwächen, damit wir hier nicht in Teufelsküche kommen.
Also es hilft ja nichts. ist kein politisches Argument.
Alle Kriege werden mit, es hilft ja nichts.
Ja, genau.
Begründet. Alles kann man mit, es hilft ja nichts begründen.
Und was mich schockiert hat, ist, dass jetzt,
Frage an eine Mutter gestellt wird. Frenze stellt jetzt die Frage an eine Mutter
und wir hören jetzt diese Antwort an.
Wir hatten ja schon Väter, die schon mal die Einjährigen für den nächsten Krieg einpreisen.
Wir hören jetzt hier die Mutter, Alena Böcks.
Aber jetzt mal wirklich diese konkrete Situation, vor der dann ihre Söhne stehen
werden, viele stehen werden, sie als Mutter.
Wenn dann die Situation ist, ja und das ist die Frage, wer Dienst leisten oder
eben doch den Ersatzdienst, den Zivildienste, diese Alternative wird es ja immer
geben und muss es auch immer geben.
Was wünscht man sich da als Mutter? Man wünscht sich, dass die eigenen Kinder
das wohl überlegt, gut begründet entscheiden.
Und dass man ihnen dabei hilft, die Argumente für sich abzuwägen und dass sie
dann am Ende dem folgen, was sie im Wesentlichen aufgrund ihrer Wertvorstellung für richtig war.
Also sie schafft es nicht zu sagen, ich will nicht, dass meine Kinder in den
Krieg ziehen. Also ich finde das so verrückt.
Wirklich dieser Ethikrat ist ja sowieso so ein komisches Konstrukt,
aber sie ist ja jetzt draußen.
Das ist ja eigentlich so eine, früher hätte man bei Hofe gesagt,
so eine Hoffransenfunktion, dass man einfach nur nochmal wie so ein Papagei
wiedergibt, was die Regierung jetzt gerade von einem möchte.
Naja, der Ethikrate hat sich hauptsächlich mit Compliance befasst.
Wie kriegen wir es hin, dass das Publikum spurt, wenn die politische Ansage
kommt? Das war die Aufgabenstellung des Ethikrates.
Und das scheint wohl auch bis in die privaten Kreise hinein genau das Verfahren zu sein.
Ja, also weil sie über seine Kinder redet, ja.
Ja, lassen wir das vor uns gut stehen.
Das geht nicht.
Wir sollten vielleicht jetzt gucken, ob wir den Start effizient machen mit ihm und Musk, oder?
Da ist noch ein Clip, ich habe diese Sendung nicht gesehen.
Ach ja, genau, ein Clip ist noch da, ganz interessant.
Also diskutiert wird mit Simon David Tressler in der Führungsrunde über die Wehrpflicht.
Und die Moderatorin hat einen sehr tollen Einwand.
Ich finde auch, wenn ich hier mal eine Medienkritik üben darf,
die sieht man in deutschen Medien nicht allzu oft, diese Realität.
Da ist immer noch das Bild von diesen tapferen Ukrainern, die alle freiwillig
unsere Freiheit verteidigen.
Ist ja auch erstmal spannend, dass sie unsere Freiheit verteidigen.
Da müssen wir öfters die Zeit lesen, wenn ich sagen darf, da hat man nämlich
auch solche Geschichten.
Aber es ist ja schon, das spielt ja das, was Sie gesagt haben,
dass man dann wirklich die Leute nachschieben muss und was Sie gesagt haben,
dass es ohne Zwang nicht geht.
Und das stimmt ja. Es ist zynisch. Es ist die Wahrheit über das Verhältnis zwischen Staat und Bürger.
Also dass der Bürger in dem Moment, wo ein Verteidigungs- oder Kriegsfall eben
ausbricht, nicht mehr ganz Herr seiner selbst. Wir haben es im BGH-Urteil vor kurzem gesehen.
Es gibt auch die Schulpflicht. Es gibt bestimmte Pflichten, die man hat als
Bürger. Ja, aber die Schulpflicht ist was anderes als die Pflicht den Staaten.
Die Schulpflicht.
Sorry.
Es gibt ja auch die Schulpflicht. Das kann doch nicht sein.
Also ein Krieg nach außen ist immer ein Krieg gegen die Familien.
Denn diese Soldaten müssen irgendwo herkommen. Nun hat Deutschland sich in diese
einzigartige Situation gebracht, dass wir hier gar keinen Massenmord durch fremde
Feinde brauchen, um hunderttausende Wunschkinder, die sind einfach nie geboren worden.
Was bedeutet, nicht nur hängen diese Familien, häufig einzelne Menschen oder halt Paare,
so ungefähr statistisch gesehen ein Kind, und das sind statistische Erhebungen
der Bundesregierung selbst, ein Kind hinter ihrem Wunschkinderzahl hinterher,
sondern der Staat hat auch niemanden, der ihn verteidigt.
Ja, das heißt, wer Pflicht, schön und gut.
Man könnte jetzt auch sagen, okay, wir bereiten uns jetzt ernsthaft auf die
Kriege vor, wir brauchen neue
Soldatenjahrgänge, wir machen erstmal eine ordentliche Familienpolitik.
Ja, bitte bringen nicht noch Leute auf Ideen. Es ist alles schlimm genug.
Bevor wir zu Doge übergehen, bleiben wir noch beim Digitalen und Verweisen auf den neuen Salon.
Also wie gesagt, wir haben jetzt im vergangenen Salon, und ich glaube,
es war eines der wichtigsten Bücher für alle Debatten, die jetzt so kommen werden,
über das Buch von Palantir-Gründer Alex Karp gesprochen, sehr ausführlich das
diskutiert, welche Idee er hat vom Starte.
Wir widmen uns aber im nächsten Salon, wenn man so möchte, der leichteren Muse.
Wir lesen nämlich von Liz Pelly das Buch Mood Machine, The Rise of Spotify and
the Cost of the Perfect Playlist.
Sie hat sich tief hineinbegeben in den Spotify-Konzern, fragt sich,
wie sich unsere Hörgewohnheiten verändert haben, wie Musik passkonform für Spotify
gemacht wird, wie AI natürlich entsprechend als Komponist jetzt auftritt und
wie solche Playlists gehackt werden.
Es ist, glaube ich, ich habe es ja noch nicht gelesen,
ein sehr relevanter Einblick in unsere Alltagskultur, denn so richtig haben
wir es, glaube ich, noch nicht verstanden und man braucht offenbar auch viele Seiten.
Sie hat hier 250 Seiten verfasst, ist tief hineingegangen und das ist das Buch,
das wir im nächsten Salon lesen werden.
Es ist sicherlich nicht so lang, auch wenn wir Lobpreisungen des kurzen Buches
kürzlich gemacht haben, denn bei all diesen Fragen, die wir bis hierhin diskutiert
hätten und auch ab jetzt diskutieren, stellt sich immer die Frage,
was verteidigen wir eigentlich?
Und dann müsste man eigentlich sagen, ja sowas. Musik hören, gemeinsam Musik hören.
Ach, die armen Künstler, jetzt können sie nur noch Konzerte machen.
Aber immerhin, da können wir ja dann hin. Also wenn sie auf die Bühne gezwängt
werden, ist ja voll gut und so.
Naja, jedenfalls sind wir da mittendrin.
Wir weisen nochmal darauf hin, dass man den Salon ganz einfach abonnieren kann.
Man kann einfach auf die Seite neue20er.de gehen.
Dort ist ein goldener Button, da steht Salon und dann kommt man auf die Steady-Seite.
Dort kann man ein Abo abschließen, ab drei Euro im Monat ist man dabei und kann
dann auch natürlich alle alten Folgen hören. Zum Beispiel auch den Live-Salon,
den wir im März aufgenommen haben. Wir waren ja wieder auf der Bühne.
Du hast uns die Männer-Podcasts vorgeführt.
Du hast auch Karneval gemacht.
Und ich habe die Mainzer Karnevalssitzung mir angesehen und dann kann man da
mal sehen, wie sich die bürgerliche Mitte konstituiert und es ist erschreckend,
soll aber lustig sein. Also von den Mains an. Jedenfalls kann man das...
Wir haben Nachfragen bekommen bei einzelnen Clips. Könnte es nicht zumindest
lustig gemeint gewesen sein? Und wir haben beide E-Mails geschrieben mit Nein.
Ja, also wer das alles noch nachhören will, kann einfach den Salon abonnieren über Steady.
Wer uns bequem über Apple weiterhören will und ist der Apple-Kunde,
will da auch nicht weg, kann das auch dort anklicken.
Dort kann man dann auch das monatlich abonnieren. Und wer schon bei Patreon
ist und für den das leichter ist, kann auch dort weiterhin das hören.
Und es gibt eine tolle Neuerung. Die hat eine Mail rumgeschickt.
Bisher war es ja so, man hat als Apple-Kunde, also mit einem iPhone,
alles in einem Feed gehabt.
Also man war Abonnent der 29er und dann ploppte einfach in diesem Feed der Salon auf.
Zwar mit einem Hinweis, kostet, also wenn sie nicht bezahlt haben,
drücken sie hier, einen Klick und so weiter. Und auch bei Spotify kann man die
Feeds jetzt zusammenlegen.
Ah, okay.
Also der Salon taucht jetzt einfach in dem einen, die 29er-Feed auf,
was wirklich super praktisch ist, finde ich.
Das heißt, wer uns über Spotify hört, kann auch von dort einfach ganz leicht steady abonnieren.
Genau. Was jetzt allerdings wieder dazu führt, und ich bin nach hinten hergerissen,
weil ich selber höre weder über die Podcast-App von Apple noch über Spotify.
Wir haben ja gesagt, es gibt alles im Salon. Und wenn jetzt aber vermehrt der
Salon durch technische Errungenschaften, die sich ergeben und die wir auch gut
finden, in den normalen Feed eingewoben wird, ob es vielleicht,
Aber wir bleiben erstmal dabei,
alles was wir herstellen, auch die heutige Folge gibt es auch im Salon.
Für Leute, die nur den Salon und dann wie ich über Overcast oder sowas hören.
Aber wir machen uns da nochmal Gedanken. Es ist auf jeden Fall ein Fortschritt,
dass man jetzt nicht mehr zwei unterschiedliche, nämlich den Neu20er und den
Salon bei Spotify einzeln abonnieren muss,
sondern dass man das Teil auch demnächst als integrierte Timeline sozusagen gibt, so wie bei Apple.
Also es geht in die richtige Richtung, aber es stellt für uns wieder kleine
Denkaufgaben, aber es macht es zumindest einfacher für alle,
die immer suchen und dann, hey, aber ich habe jetzt den Salon gefunden,
aber nicht die 29er, aber wie auch immer und so. Es gibt Fortschritte zu verbreiten.
Nutzerfreundlicher.
Ja, wir werden das dann entsprechend rein organisieren in unseren Ablauf.
Wunderbar und das ist die Möglichkeit, den Podcast zu unterstützen und wir freuen
uns, wenn das viele tun und bedanken uns natürlich auch bei denen,
die schon dabei sind. Und jetzt wird Geld gespart mit Elon Musk.
Doge. Wir fragen uns jetzt, wer liegt eigentlich in der sozialen Hängematte?
Wir wissen, wie Diskussionen und Laufen.
Niemand hat Ahnung von dem, worüber er spricht.
Heizungsgesetz. Halbes Jahr später Marion Horn. Wir haben hier niemanden,
der weiß, wie eine Wärmepumpe funktioniert.
Bürokratieabbau. Da ist schon einiges Wahres dran. Bürgergeldempfänger.
Keine Ahnung, alle blöd. Können ja alle arbeiten. Machen sie nicht. Was ist da los?
Jetzt haben wir ja diese Konstellation, dass wir in Deutschland Diskurse über
ganz enge Nadelöhre haben.
Maybrit Illner, Anne Will, Marietta Slomka, Markus Lanz.
Das heißt, wann immer wir einen kurzen Einblick in diese Denkweisen bekommen,
können wir sagen, so ist der drauf.
Und eigentlich müssen wir dann sagen, diese eine Sekunde, in der wir ihn hören,
der gilt jetzt ab jetzt für alle Diskussionen. Also wenn Lanz einmal etwas Auffälliges
in einem Gespräch mit Richard David Precht in seinem Podcast sagt,
Muss man das immer im Hinterkopf behalten für alle zukünftigen Diskussionen,
in denen man Markus Lanz jeden Abend mit irgendwelchen Leuten hört.
Wir haben heute Morgen so einen Moment serviert bekommen, denn Precht wollte
Anmerkungen machen zu einem Thema, das Lanz aufgeworfen hat.
Diese halbe Minute klang so.
Die Anzahl derjenigen, die sagen, hoch, ich bin doch nicht doof,
der Staat bezahlt mich, so mache ich das, nicht die Mehrheit.
Die gibt es, aber es ist nicht die Mehrheit.
Die Mehrheit sind eher Leute, die man im Arbeitsprozess heute nicht wirklich
gebrauchen kann, weil sie nicht belastbar sind.
Das glaube ich. Aber ich kann es nicht beweisen.
Ich kann es nur aus meiner anekdotischen Evidenz derjenigen Menschen,
die ich kenne und ich kenne einige, die vom Bürgergeld leben.
Du kennst Leute, die vom Bürgergeld leben? Ja, die kenne ich und kenne sogar
sehr gut. Und da trifft genau diese Struktur zu.
Du kennst Leute, die von Bürgergeld leben. Ich rede immer nur im Fernsehen über
Bürgergeld mit Millionären.
Du kennst welche, die von Bürgergeld leben? Oh, das ist erstaunlich.
Jetzt bin ich kurz geschockt.
Ja, aber das ist genau das. Und das ist so wie Alena Bögs, wir brauchen mal
eine Wehrpflicht, damit die Leute mal aus verschiedenen Milieus zusammenkommen.
Dabei nicht sehen, dass Leute immer wieder aus verschiedenen Milieus miteinander zu tun haben.
Es sei denn, sie haben eine derart exponierte Stellung wie eine Ethikratschefin
oder einen Moderator beim ZDF.
Also über Wehrpflicht reden wollen, weil man ja auch Kinder hat.
Ist 1 plus 1 gleich, keine Ahnung, was ist denn das für ein komischer Blödsinn.
So, also, Markus Lanz redet die ganze Zeit abends über das Bürgergeld.
Warum? Jetzt kleine Vorrede zu dem, was wir besprechen.
Weil sie zu viel kosten. Wem? Dem Staat.
Der Staat verbraucht also Geld. Ja, ja, ganz viel und an den ganz falschen Stellen.
Also die Bürgergelddiskussion ist eigentlich eine Bürokratiediskussion.
Da hängen ja Leute in der Hängematte des Staates.
So, und darüber reden, also das Wort Hängematte fällt auch in diesem Gespräch
heute Morgen bei den beiden.
So, nur jetzt, bevor wir uns diesen Doge-Sachen angucken, was ist diese Hängematte des Staates?
Der Precht, hört das bitte selber, das ist wirklich sehr empfehlenswert,
erzählt heute in Kürze die Geschichte des Sozialstaats.
Nämlich, zuerst einmal ist Kapitalismus Marxens Zeiten, Mitte des 19.
Jahrhunderts, es geht drunter und drüber, die Leute schlafen auf zwei Meter
langen Pritschen, einen halben Meter lang, also sie haben quasi einen Quadratmeter,
der ihnen zusteht, und selbst der nur, sie schlafen im Schichtprinzip, so, ne?
Sie gehen arbeiten und stellen fest, ein Kapitalist, tausend Arbeiter,
eigentlich sind die Mächte- und Kräfteverhältnisse verteilt.
Wir sollten jetzt hier mal und so, und kennt man ja, Arbeiteraufstände, wie auch immer.
Und dann gibt es plötzlich eine politische Idee.
Und zwar, wir zähmen jetzt die Wut der Arbeiter und halten ihnen die Karotte des Sozialstaats hin.
Was bedeutet, ab jetzt haben wir einen Korridor geschaffen, in dem der Kapitalist sich austoben darf.
Und das macht er auch. Deswegen ja die ganzen Milliardäre.
So, der Sozialstaat ist also eine Zähmungsmaschine, die den Gemütszustand der
Arbeiter unter Kontrolle hält, sodass der Kapitalist seine Profite einfahren
kann und nicht umgedreht.
Also das Vorzeichen muss genau einmal umgedreht werden zu dieser Bürgergelddiskussion,
wie wir sie immer geführt haben.
Und jetzt haben wir in Amerika jemanden, der diesen Sozialstaat gerade abschafft,
obwohl er derjenige ist, der am meisten von der Hängematte Sozialstaat profitiert hat.
Als nämlich der Sozialstaat auf die Idee kam, wir schützen jetzt mal oder wir
zähmen die Wut der Klimaschützer, wir machen so einen Zertifikatehandel.
Und dann hat er Tesla gegründet, Tesla hat nie einen Verbrenner hergestellt, also hieß es,
Tesla macht Profite mit Autos, aber noch mehr Geld verdienen die in diesem Zertifikatehandel,
weil nämlich alle Autohersteller auf der Welt Flottengrenzwerte einhalten müssen
und Mercedes dann sagt, wir haben jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten.
Entweder wir bauen auch E-Autos, damit wir einen Anteil an E-Mobilität haben,
wie das Gesetz das Jahr anstrebte, oder wir bezahlen halt einfach die Zertifikate.
So, jeder Autohersteller hat die gleiche Anzahl von Zertifikaten,
die man da verhandeln oder die man kaufen muss.
Tesla muss keine kaufen, also kann man einfach die Last auf Tesla übertragen,
indem man einfach Geld rüber schickt.
Tesla verdiente also zig Millionen, Milliarden Euro pro Jahr,
einfach nur durch diesen Zertifikatehandel.
Zweite Einkommensquelle von Tesla, Subvention. Der Staat steht da und sagt,
wir wollen diese Industrie, wir wollen es aber nicht selber machen.
Hier hast du Milliarden und Milliarden und Milliarden.
Er kommt nach Grünheide, sagt, ich mache das hier gerne, ich werde aber keine
Gewerbesteuer zahlen, ich werde nichts zahlen.
Hier gibt es allenfalls eine Abfuhr von Einkommenssteuer, aber das betrifft
ja meine Arbeit, da ist mir egal, ich verbuche das pauschal, fertig.
Elon Musk ist überhaupt nur so super reich, weil er die Hängematte Sozialstaat
die ganze Zeit genutzt hat.
Dass ein Tesla im Laden auch noch was kostet, war so Einkommensquelle 3 von
Tesla. Aber niemals maßgebend.
So, und dieser Typ baut jetzt den Sozialstaat ab. Das ist sehr paradox.
Und das muss man auch immer genau so sehen.
Und ich finde es sehr interessant, dass Leute, auch uns, dann immer so Texte
schicken aus der Zeit, von den New York Times, die Atlantic,
wie auch immer, die so in dem Tenor laufen.
Da gibt es in Maralago so ein Papier.
Da wird erklärt, was es mit diesen neuen Zöllen auf sich hat.
Das ist so ein Masterplan und in der Wallstreet sind auch alle schon ganz hyped.
Und ich denke mir dann immer, ja genau, keine Angst vor Verschwörungstheorien.
Manchmal ist das Chaos so groß, dass die Leute, die bisher immer nur den anderen
unterstellt haben, so einfache Antworten, Ordnungsprinzipien wird es ja wohl
geben, der ist schuld, wie auch immer, den sollten wir mal und so.
Dass die plötzlich anfangen, händeringend, wie wir es bei MRT-Wissen gehört
haben, orientierungslos rumzurennen Und dann, zum Glück gab es auch bei Trump
im Lager mal ein Papier, wo mal auf über drei Seiten stringenter Gedanke durchgehalten wurde.
Nur das sagt noch gar nichts aus, wie da jetzt im Verhältnis zur Realität steht.
Also wir haben es hier mit einem Thema zu tun, Bürgergeld, Sozialstaat, Bürokratie.
Keiner weiß Bescheid.
Wenn man sich ein paar Podcasts anhört über das, was jetzt die Trump-Regierung
vorhat, dann bekommt man so viele Positionen aufgefächert.
Allein schon wie das Thema Außenhandel, Zölle, Währungsabwertung, Bitcoin-Reserven etc.
Gesehen wird. Da würde ich sagen, da ist das Spektrum innerhalb dieser Trump-Regierung
schon fast so groß wie das zwischen Linkspartei und AfD. Also das ist so verrückt.
Luhmann hat ja immer gesagt, Demokratie oder politischen Streit kann man auch
in einer Partei machen. Und das sehen wir jetzt.
Das kann man da echt sehen, weil das sind wirklich entgegengesetzte Projekte
zum Teil, nicht in allem, also sie haben natürlich eine hohe Einigkeit,
Vogue finden sie alle scheiße oder so, ja, aber sobald es um diese Hard Facts
der Ökonomie geht, weiß keiner genau, welche Richtung es denn eigentlich jetzt entlang geht,
beziehungsweise es passiert ja derzeit häufig, dass beide, dass also,
gegensätzliche Richtungen gleichzeitig eingeschlagen werden,
mehrfach, was dann ja zu solchen Konfusionen führt.
Die einen wollen Hartrechte grenzen zu, die anderen sagen, wir brauchen noch
Fachkräfteeinwanderung und so, also es geht drunter und drüber.
Wir haben häufig eine Diskussion darüber, dass jetzt irgendwie Trump möchte
sich zu einem Strongman wie Xi machen.
Was eigentlich zu beobachten ist, dass die Republikanische Partei die Chance
ergreift, sich Amerika als Land unter den Nagel zu reißen, um dann zu sagen,
bitte alle Konflikte nur innerhalb der Partei.
So wie man auch in der Zeitung sagt, Zeitungslandschaft schön und gut,
aber wenn wir beide Stimmen einer Debatte bei uns abdrücken konnten,
das war ja schon mal das Idee von Vöthau, dann wieso publiziert da noch jemand in der Zeit und so.
Und FAZ Vöntau hat davon sehr profitiert.
Wir haben diesen Text gelesen aus Amerika, aus den ländlichen Regionen,
wo einfach völlig klar war, wenn du dich hier politisch engagieren musst,
weil du ein echtes Problem hast, dir fehlt ein Zebrastreifen oder so,
geh nicht zu den Demokraten, es gibt da nämlich keine.
Geh zu den Republikanern und füge dich und dann setz halt dein Sachanliegen durch.
Es gibt ja eine große Volkswirtschaft mit einer Partei, die ja nicht unerfolgreich
ist wirtschaftlich und das ist China.
Und wir hatten mal irgendwann im Salon, hatte ich es mitgebracht,
solche Reden von Xi und da ging ja auch auf die Massenlinie, so nennt man das ein.
Und das zeigt also, es geht in der chinesischen Partei natürlich auch darum,
eine gewisse Pluralität herzustellen.
Also ja, es gibt diese ganz klare Ausrichtung auf Xi, aber man hat die Region,
hat dort einzelne Funktionäre, die wieder in Kontakt sind mit den Parteimitgliedern
und dann soll da über eine Pluralität der Meinungen und so eine möglichst günstige
Entscheidung getroffen werden. Das gelingt mal mehr oder weniger.
Jedenfalls hat man glaube ich einen falschen Eindruck, wenn man jetzt China
immer so als die Xi-Diktatur nur versteht, weil man dann natürlich diese pluralen
Elemente völlig verkennt und ja auch zum Beispiel sieht,
dass in Bezug auf den Klimawandel dort ja auch widerstreitende Interessen sind.
Also manche sagen ja, man muss jetzt ein bisschen weniger Klimasubventionen
machen, andere in der KP sagen wohl, man braucht eigentlich viel mehr.
Wir wissen zu wenig darüber, weil das natürlich nicht eine freie Presse ist,
die uns das eigentlich mal genau erläutert.
Aber wenn man sich so ein bisschen da rein vertieft, dann sieht man natürlich
plötzlich, es ist viel vielstimmiger, als man dachte.
Genau und Vielstimmigkeit, die zerstört.
Dieser Verknüpfung von Posten und Personen nicht gefährdet, ist ja für Xi dann auch egal.
Also es nützt ihm ja auch, wenn es im Land wirtschaftlich floriert,
also wenn sich im freien Kräftespiel diejenigen durchsetzen.
Hauptsache, sein Posten ist nicht gefährdet.
Das haben wir ja bei Trump auch immer gehabt, das war ja mal klar, die Apprentice.
Er vergibt seine Aufträge mehrfach und dann wird halt geguckt und einer wird
gefeuert und der andere nicht. So, aber bis dahin, freies Kräftespiel.
So ja auch bei Doge. Doge hat ja zwei, also Elon Musk und diesen Ramaswani.
Der eine wurde halt jetzt rausgekickt vom anderen. Jetzt ist es halt nur noch Elon Musk.
Ja, interessant, dass das so schnell geht.
Das war immer diese Prinzipien, der Stärkere setzt sich durch.
Aber wer jetzt immer hofft, dass es hier so eine große rote Linie gibt oder
bei irgendeinem Paper und dann hält man sich daran oder irgend sowas, das ist alles absurd.
Also wir gehen das mal durch, wie auf der einen Seite wirr, chaotisch und auf
der anderen Seite dann doch zumindest zielorientiert ist.
Und wir machen das auch jetzt, weil es klar in Amerika aktuell ist,
aber auch in Deutschland. Also wir haben eine Initiative für den handlungsfähigen Staat.
Ich habe mit den beiden Soziologen Stefan Kühl und Judith Muster im ARJAS-Podcast
auch darüber geredet, zwei Stunden, also einfach als Textgrundlage.
Es ist sozusagen ein Special Interest Podcast, wir spielen da keine Clips und
lesen den Text nicht, denn der wird einfach vorausgesetzt, ist quasi Seminar.
Hier allerdings nur Clips heute. Wir beginnen mal hier.
Also, Elon Musk steht im Oval Office, die Szene ist ja soweit bekannt,
und möchte eine interessante Anekdote erzählen, die...
Er steht dort mit Basecap.
T-Shirt, nur ein Sakko übergeworfen. Also nicht formell korrekt gekleidet für das weiße Haus.
Aber es spielt hier noch keine Rolle, weil er ist ja nicht Selensky im Krieg,
sondern da beginnt es schon. Ja, es ist einfach wirr, wirr, wirr.
Also er möchte uns eine Anekdote erzählen.
This is actually a great anecdote. Because we're told, the most number of people
that could retire possibly in a month is 10.000.
We're like, well, why is that?
Well, because all the retirement paperwork is manual.
Das ist manuelles Calculiert, dann auf eine Art Art Artikel.
Dann wird es nach einem Minden. Und dann ist es, was ich mit einem Minden?
Ja, es ist eine Lammstone Minden, wo wir alle die Retturementen Papierkomen haben.
Und wenn wir eine picture auf das Minden, wir sehen uns später,
und das Minden sieht aus dem 50er Jahre aus, weil es in 1955 ist,
so es ist wie eine Zeitwärm.
Und dann ist die Spiegel, die Faktor ist, Der speed at which the mine shaft
elevator can move determines how many people can retire from the federal government.
And the elevator breaks down sometimes, and then nobody can retire.
Ja,
es klingt ziemlich crazy, weil es halt auch crazy ist. Also,
was er hier im Bilde hat, ist ja so ein Idol-Game.
Wir haben es ja schon mal besprochen, ich habe mir dann auch mal eins runtergeladen,
Human hat mir erklärt, wie es geht.
Also so ein Typ mit einer Schippe, damit geht es los. Der buddelt also ein Loch,
irgendwann braucht er einen Fahrstuhl, also baut man ihn in einem Fahrstuhl
und dann kommt es auf die Managemententscheidung von dir als Player an,
die Fahrstuhlgeschwindigkeit so einzustellen, dass gerade der Eimer voll ist,
wenn der Fahrstuhl immer unten ist und dann baut man das so ganz langsam immer größer.
Das ist so seine Idee von wie Amerika funktioniert. Da ist also eine Mine.
Und in dieser Mine unten werden Rentenanträge verarbeitet.
Und da der Fahrstuhl klein ist, können nur höchstens 10.000 Leute pro Monat
in Rente gehen, weil ansonsten wäre der Fahrstuhl überlastet.
Die müssen alle darunter, sich einen Antrag abholen oder so.
Diesen Fahrstuhl gibt es nicht. Diese Mine gibt es allerdings schon.
Und ja, diese Mine ist alt, denn natürlich baut keiner eine Mine,
um Sachen zu verarbeiten, sondern man hat eine Mine und die wurde gegraben,
weil da Rohstoffe waren.
Und dann denkt man sich, eigentlich eine tolle Facility, bevor wir jetzt hier
ein Bürokomplex bauen und alle 50 Jahre rumziehen müssen, nehmen wir lieber
geologisches Gestein, hält für immer.
Für ein Archiv gar nicht so schlecht, weshalb das auch als Archiv genutzt wird.
Also da kommen sozusagen nur fertig verarbeitete Akten rein.
Und die werden auch nicht mit dem Fahrstuhl runtergefahren, sondern es ist dieser
Iron Mountain in Pennsylvania oder so, da fährt man einfach mit dem LKW rein,
da wird er abgeladen, fertig.
Also fährt man waagerecht in den Berg und fährt nicht eine Mine runter.
Also die ganze Metapher, die er aufmacht, verstehen wir, die ist aber soweit
falsch, weil sie empirisch nicht trägt.
Was allerdings stimmt ist, das wird alles papiermäßig verarbeitet und deswegen
dauert ein Rentenantrag zu bearbeiten drei Monate, also 90 Tage.
Es schwankt so zwischen 60 Tagen und 90 Tagen.
So, das heißt, wir haben ein echtes bürokratisches Problem, denn alle Welt,
ja, die Dänen bauen jetzt ihre Briefkästen ab, weil einfach jede formale Post
natürlich per E-Mail elektronisch zugestellt wird und die Amerikaner verarbeiten Rentenanträge,
Das ist ja auch absurd, ja, auf Papier, ist ja irgendwie blöd. Naja, jedenfalls.
Wir halten aber fest, diese Anekdote ist natürlich unsinnig,
aber wir halten ja erstmal fest, jeder, der über Bürokratie nachdenkt,
wird anfangen zu ächzen.
Zugleich müssen wir Leuten deutlich machen, komplexe Gesellschaften kommen ohne Bürokratie nicht aus.
Das bringt das mit sich, wenn man sich mit mehreren organisieren muss.
Aber es läuft ja einiges schief.
Auch interessant, es liegt ja nicht nur an der Digitalisierung.
Ich kann dir zum Beispiel auch einen Fall nennen, da wurde mir jetzt erzählt von einem Architekten,
der natürlich vollkommen digital ist und dann zum Beispiel auch mit Stadtversorgung
oder so sprechen muss, um irgendwelche Anschlüsse zu bekommen.
Ja, und das funktioniert dann weder per E-Mail, noch telefonisch, noch brieflich.
Das heißt, das ist jetzt wieder wie ganz früher. Der geht jetzt dahin und macht
das Tamtam, damit das dann, also der tritt dort dann auf, lässt sich den Chef
geben und so, damit dann Leute einen Anschluss bekommen, damit was umgesetzt wird.
Also das sind natürlich Dinge, die man beobachten kann.
Genau, es ist ein ganz zweischneidiges, wir haben natürlich jetzt auch viele
Mails bekommen, die das so gehört haben. unser Gespräch, weil sie so aus der
Fachrichtung kommen, es gibt Forschungseinrichtungen,
die sich mit Entbürokratisierung natürlich befassen.
Die haben dann verschiedene Ideen, wie diese virtuelle Zusage oder wie das auch
immer heißt, also wenn du dem
Staat einen Antrag stellst und der reagiert nicht, gilt es als genehmigt.
Ab dann muss der Staat rechtfertigen, warum er das doch nochmal anders sieht.
Und dann ist er in der Begründungspflicht, dann muss jemand einen Stift in die
Hand nehmen, das ist alles aufwendig. Also weiß man, okay, da ist man ziemlich durch. So.
Genehmigungsfiktion heißt das in dem Fall. Es gibt andere, dass man neue Gremien
schafft und dann erstmal in.
Experimental ein Labor schafft oder Anträge auf Abweichung vom Gesetz zulässt
und lauter solche Sachen.
Aber die müssen halt penibel getestet und dann und so weiter.
Da gibt es schon Fortschritte, aber ich bin auch ein echter Hasser von der Bürokratie.
Also da, wo sie mir begegnet, finde ich es immer Schrott.
Und der menschliche Verstand, der gesunde Menschenverstand geht auch immer ein
bisschen weiter. Und es beginnt zum Beispiel bei ganz einfachen Sachen.
Wann darf ich mein Kind aus der Betreuung abholen? Gibt es da immer Zeitfenster,
damit es für die leichter ist, die Kinder in diesen Zeitfenstern loszuschicken.
Die müssen ja natürlich, da darf ja nie ein Fehler passieren,
dass jemand nicht mehr da ist und so weiter. Also das Abholen muss genau geregelt werden.
Aber muss das denn für mich bedeuten, dass ich mein Kind wirklich nur in einem
Zeitfenster pro Stunde abholen kann oder einfach immer, wenn es mir halt passt. Lauter solche Sachen.
Deswegen, Bürokratie ist ein echtes Problem.
Bürgergeld, wie wir es organisieren, ist in vielen Belangen auch ein echtes Problem.
Das heißt aber noch lange nicht, dass nur Leute, weil sie sich häufig damit
beschäftigen, also weil Lanz häufig in seiner Sendung darüber redet,
also eine Issue-Ownership hat, deswegen auch ein Experte ist.
Nein.
Das gilt für Elon Musk genauso. Der hat halt eine Issue-Ownership,
weil er irgendwelche Leute rumdelegiert, die ihm irgendwas machen und die tragen
ihm dann irgendwelche Pointen vor und die trägt er dann weiter ins Weiße Haus.
Aber ich glaube, der hat so wenig Ahnung wie von seinen Raketen.
Der versteht das im Prinzip und vor zehn Jahren hat er auch mal was damit zu
tun gehabt, aber jetzt machen halt irgendwelche Leute für ihn Raketen und es
ist ja ein sehr fester, also die Frau, die für ihn die SpaceX leitet,
macht das ja seit über zehn Jahren und so.
Wenn die weg wäre, dann hätte er echt ein Problem. Aber solange sie da ist, ist halt alles gut.
Beim Bürgergeld ist es ja auch so, dass man viel mehr, und das gilt für viele
Bereiche, mit Pauschalen arbeiten könnte.
Mhm.
Und würde damit natürlich den Weg öffnen, dass nicht jeder Antrag von zehn Sachbearbeitern
monatelang backert werden muss.
Das Ähnliche kann man auch feststellen beim BAföG.
Luxemburg unterstützt auch Studierende, macht das glaube ich einfach mit dem
Gießkannenprinzip an alle fertig los.
Und sobald man aber in so eine Gerechtigkeitsvorstellung sich verfangen lässt,
die sagt, wir müssen jetzt genau bei jedem gucken.
Also nicht, dass du am Ende 10 Euro mehr bekommst als der Herr Schmidt,
weil der hat ja keinen Extraaufwand und und und. und dann braucht man für jeden einen einzelnen Fall.
Und dann ist jeder ein Einzelfall und dann brauchst du auch Gesetzestexte,
die kilometerlang sind.
Wenn du das nicht machst, wenn du das pauschalierst und wenn du dann auch so
gütig bist zu sagen, naja, dann bekommt da einer eben 50 Euro mehr, dann wäre das okay.
Ist aber eigentlich mit der Regierung ja jetzt nicht dann zu erwarten.
Die CDU will ja eigentlich, was das Bürgergeld anbelangt, die Bürokratie hochfahren.
Die Pointe der CDU ist ja, dass mit Friedrich Merz jemand antritt,
der vor über 20 Jahren die Pauschalierungsidee überhaupt hatte,
nämlich der berühmte Bierdeckel.
Der Bierdeckel war danach auch nochmal bei Obama Gespräch,
bis Obama sich das hat durchrechnen lassen und es hieß, wenn wir das Steuersystem
so machen, ist es besser für alle, aber das bedeutet eine Million entlassene
Beamte und zwei Millionen entlassene Steuerberater und Rechtsanwälte,
die sich dann einen anderen Job suchen müssen.
Man kann es nachlesen bei David Kreber im Bullshit-Buch.
Genau, Bullshit-Job, also da sind wir genau da. Also es ist wirklich dramatisch.
So, was bedeutet, wir haben eine Bürokratie. Sie ist aus Gründen da,
die wir uns soziologisch immer pointiert erklären können, aber sie ist halt trotzdem da.
Ich bin auch sehr dafür, sie abzuschaffen und ich will, bevor wir das machen,
noch eine Pointe bringen, denn die fand ich wirklich sehr überzeugend.
Stefan Kühl hat ja darüber auch in der FAZ geschrieben. Ein Lob des Verbots.
Bevor wir schrittweise Restaurants, Regeln mitgeben und dann bitte wird das
auch dokumentiert und dann gehen wir hin und schauen uns die Dokumentierung
an und sagen, alles okay.
Sagen wir einfach, liebes Restaurant, du hast zwei Möglichkeiten.
Plan A ist, wir geben dir genau vor, was du machen musst, damit du niemals Sorgen
mit dem Gesundheitsamt, mit dem Arbeitsamt, mit der Ausländerbehörde oder was auch immer hast.
Oder wir sagen dir, du darfst deine Restaurantgäste nicht gefährden.
Es ist dir einfach verboten.
Halte dich an dieses Verbot. Das war das ganze Gesetz.
So, wir haben allgemeine Regeln,
was wie Gefährdungen so aussehen und so weiter. Die gelten einfach.
Und dann ist uns auch egal, wann du einen Topf gereinigt hast oder wer hier
mit welchen Wischmitteln und so weiter.
Du hast jemanden gefährdet. Wenn das wissentlich war, kriegen wir das raus. Zack.
Und dann hätte man tausend Seiten Bürokratie. Nicht nur im Gesetzestext,
sondern auch in der Dokumentationspflicht.
Einfach weg. Du darfst es einfach nicht. Verbot.
Und Kühle meinte dann, der DSA gibt diesen Unternehmen, den Großen,
riesig viele Gesetzestexte, wo alles geregelt ist.
Man hätte ihnen auch einfach sagen können, das sind die Ziele,
das ist verboten. So, Punkt.
Ja, es gibt ja zum Beispiel bei kleinen Lokalen oder Cafés dieses Toilettenproblem.
Also man hat irgendwann neue Regularien geschaffen und wenn dann die alten Inhaber
gehen, das verkaufen und jemand soll es übernehmen, dann stehen die plötzlich
vor dem Problem, dass da eigentlich noch eine Toilette her müsste irgendwo,
wo man aber keine schaffen kann.
Und dann sagen die ja, das kostet 40.000 Euro, das Ganze jetzt umzubauen oder noch mehr.
Also lasse ich es lieber ganz. Und wenn man genau nach dieser Maßgabe geht,
um das jetzt mal konkret zu machen, bedeutet das einfach, du darfst sie mal
nicht gefährden. Aha, okay, du hast also diese Toiletten, die sind ein bisschen
limitierter, als es eigentlich erforderlich ist.
Nun, was ist also in den Erzfällen? Zum Beispiel, da ist eine schwangere Frau.
Ja, die wird halt grundsätzlich vorgelassen und dafür hat man Sorge zu tragen.
Und dann ist egal, ob man eine grundsätzliche Anzahl von Toiletten eingehalten
hat, sondern es ist dann gewährleistet und damit hätte man das auch dann umgehen können.
Und ja, dann wird man noch ein paar Maßstäbe brauchen, dass nicht am Ende eine
Toilette für 100 Leute oder sowas, Das geht alles dann nicht.
Aber ich glaube, dass diese Flexibilität natürlich wahnsinnig helfen würde,
denn das, was man da so hört, ist ja...
Auch an Räumen, wie sie belastet werden dürfen. Also es gibt Räume,
die werden jahrelang mit schweren Möbeln und allem belastet.
Da fahren auch Gabelstapler durch.
Auch ein Fall, der mir kürzlich erzählt wurde. Da sollen jetzt 15 Leute einen
Seminarraum bekommen. Da sagt man, naja, das weiß ich nicht,
ob das mit der Statik klappt.
Also wo man vorher wesentlich mehr Gewicht hat.
Und wo man dann auch sagen will, ja gut, wenn diese Leute nicht jeweils 250
Kilo wiegen, dann kann das eigentlich kein Problem werden.
Und trotzdem gibt es dann plötzlich solche Auflagen, ja.
Genau, also das ist ganz viel absurd und häufig ist die Kritik an Bürokratie
mit, das weißt du auch gesunde Menschenverstand besser, richtig,
bedeutet aber, die Renaissance des strafenden Staates.
Ja.
So, also das muss man dann einfach sehen und das ist ja auch nicht verkehrt,
also ich bin sehr für einen strafenden Staat, ja.
Von mir aus muss es in Verkehrsregeln gar nicht so, also es muss von mir aus
nicht viele Verkehrsregeln geben, aber wenn jemand jemanden tot gefahren hat,
hat er offenbar einen Fehler gemacht.
Und es ist mir dann auch relativ egal, ob das billig in den Kauf genommen ist
oder vorsätzlich oder was auch immer, dann kommt der strafende Staat und das
muss dann auch jeder wissen.
Gut, also Elon Musk sitzt im Oval Office und redet über die Bürokratie wie Lanz
in seiner Sendung über das Bürgergeld. Das ist die Ausgangsvoraussetzung.
Kurz gefasst, alle sind doof. Elon Musk ist dumm. Wir haben es ja schon mal
von Josh Boyd-Tapolski als Frage.
Wir haben damals schon gesagt, ja, vielleicht ist er auch einfach dumm.
Wir gehen das weiter durch. Das Heute-Journal war eine sehr gute Berichterstattung
dazu, deswegen können wir ein bisschen Fernsehen gucken.
Wie sehen die eigentlich sowas wie USAID? Wir haben das bisher immer als,
das sind die Soft-Power-Anteile, da sichert sich Amerika ab.
Das macht für Amerika Sinn, aber für uns jetzt nicht so.
Plötzlich dieser neue Zungenschlag.
Elon Musk und seine Mitarbeiter aus der sogenannten Kostensenkungsabteilung
für staatliche Effizienz haben, wie
schon gehört, die Schließung der Entwicklungsbehörde USAID vorangetrieben.
Musk nannte sie ein Schlangennest radikal linker Marxisten, die Amerika hassen
und beurlaubt fast alle Mitarbeiter kurzerhand.
Ja, also da sitzen natürlich die ganzen Diplomaten als noch amtierende Beamte
oder Pensionäre, die das aufgebaut haben zu Hause und schlagen die Hände über dem Kopf zusammen.
Wie kann man nur so doof sein?
Die New York Times hat ja mal angefragt beim Center for Global Development,
was bedeutet das eigentlich jetzt, dass die US-Entwicklungshilfe gestrichen wurde.
Und dieses Center rechnet im nächsten Jahr aufgrund dieser Entscheidung mit
etwa drei Millionen toten Menschen weltweit.
Über 1,6 Millionen Menschen könnten aufgrund fehlender HIV-Prävention sterben.
Über eine halbe Million werden ohne Ernährungshilfen sterben und eine Million
ohne Impfungen und Prävention gegen Tuberkulose und Malaria.
Also es sind diese 54 Milliarden Dollar, die da gestrichen werden.
Und jetzt ist ja die Frage, die sich für uns stellt, also für uns als Europäer zum Beispiel.
Sparen wir uns jetzt 54 Milliarden Dollar, um zu sagen, oder dann lieber drei Millionen Tote?
Oder retten wir Leben und machen uns beliebt.
Genau. Und was macht man aber? Wir erinnern uns, 24, da hat man den Haushaltsplan
für 25 gemacht und der sah vor, eine Milliarde weniger für Entwicklungshilfe.
Jetzt haben sich ja gerade Altmaier und auch der ehemalige Entwicklungsminister
Müller zu Wort gemeldet, weil sie schon das Rumoren hören.
Es soll die Entwicklungshilfe noch einmal gekürzt werden jetzt mit der neuen
Koalition und sie warnen dringend davor, das nicht zu tun.
Jetzt müsste man eigentlich, wenn man den Menschen so sehr in den Mittelpunkt
rücken will, wie das ja so Leute immer gerne betonen, die von Aufrüstung reden,
dann müsste man eigentlich sagen, ja genau, wir müssen hier aufrüsten,
um drei Millionen Menschen zu retten.
Die Summe ist jetzt ganz klar. Drei Millionen Menschenleben kosten 54 Milliarden Dollar.
Die Zahl ist errechnet. Jetzt muss man nur noch eine Koalition der Willigen
bilden, die diese 54 Milliarden Dollar zusammenbringt.
Ich meine, was sind diese Kriegsziele, die man jetzt immer formuliert?
Es sind ja auch Menschenleben retten.
Ja.
Kann man auch hier verbinden. Wir sind ja mittlerweile in einer Zeit,
in der selbst Dirk Niebel hatte nochmal ein paar gute Ideen,
als Entwicklungshilfeminister galt und Gordon Ripinski für Politico,
Springer, Politiker, wie Ralf Stegner fragt, sollen wir das jetzt abschaffen?
Und dann selbst Politiker aus heiterem Himmel, wie die machen,
was? Abschaffen? Nee, nicht abschaffen.
Vielleicht abgeben an den Koalitionspartner, aber nicht abschaffen.
Ja.
Also, ja, es kommt alles unter die Räder. Trump selbst wollen wir auch nochmal hören.
Also wir haben jetzt schon die Schlangengrube, die Marxisten,
das Idol-Game als Idee, da ist eine Mine und ein Fahrstuhl, das ist alles limitiert.
Trump hat jetzt auch nochmal eine Metapher.
Wir werden den Krebs los. Ich nenne es Krebs, den die beiden Regierungen verursacht hat.
Trump seit jeher skeptisch gegenüber der Bürokratie. Für ihn der Deep State.
Er glaubt, die Staatsbediensteten hätten in seiner ersten Amtszeit versucht, ihn zu sabotieren.
Als Antwort darauf bemüht er sich jetzt gar nicht mehr darum, sie zu überzeugen.
Stattdessen versucht er, sie loszuwerden und die, die bleiben,
einzuschüchtern, damit sie ihm ohne Frage gehorchen.
Schließen könnte Trump demnächst auch das Bildungsministerium.
Und so weiter und so fort. Also Bildungsministerium ist ja bis jetzt geschlossen,
Health and Human Resources, wo das Familienministerium drunter fällt,
da wurde gestern angesagt, 10.000 Stellen weg und so.
Also es geht zur Sache und das Leitbild ist der Krebs, der besiegt werden muss.
Ich höre natürlich immer noch Hoss und Hopf, denn ich möchte kurz darauf hinweisen, wenn ich sage,
ich höre die belanglosen Podcasts Berliner Männer, die sich als Journalisten
verstehen nicht mehr, weil sie mir nach einer Wahl erklären,
dass sie das mit den Linken nicht auf dem Schirm hatten, Michael Brücker,
ist das was ganz anderes als Platz 1 Ratgeber seit Wochen Hoss und Hopf, Millionenpublikum.
Also ich muss ja hören, was da gesprochen wird.
Das ist zwar auch dumm und schlimm und gefährlich, aber halt nicht belanglos.
Das ist, wie ich mir jeden beknackten Film ansehe, um zu wissen,
was ist ideologisch gerade der Fall.
Aber ich habe halt sehr viele, ich hatte so eine Story mit Horst und Hoffgürmer
gemacht auf Instagram und dann kamen so sehr viele Reaktionen im Sinne von ich
dachte, du hast damit abgeschlossen, du hast keine Männer-Podcasts mehr und so weiter und so fort.
Ich habe dann wirklich bei jedem so ein bisschen drunter geschrieben,
nee, bitte hört im Podcast richtig zu, was wir sagen. Versteht bitte, was wir...
Männer-Politik-Podcasts nicht mehr, die aus Berlin sind, die dir nicht weiterhelfen.
Die Selbstbeschäftigung sind und.
Die nur nochmal den News-Ticker auffrischen. Und du hörst aber nach wie vor,
um zu wissen, was wird unter jungen Männern gedacht.
Genau.
Ross und Hopf.
Ja, ich will einfach wissen, was hier Sache ist. Also das Krebsbild von Trump.
Die amerikanische Regierung ist der Krebs. Klingt bei Philipp Hopf so.
Kongress schlagen die Opposition.
Sorry, hier.
Ich meine, der Patient Europa hat nicht nur schweren Krebs, sondern er ist voller Metastasen.
Das heißt, es hat alles schon gestreut. Das ganze System ist innerlich verrottet,
wenn wir es mal vom Verschwendungsstandpunkt aus angehen.
Und du hast eben Leute, die keinerlei Konsequenz fürchten müssen.
Für ihr Handeln. Deswegen, sie sind einfach von ihrem naturell aus,
sind sie schon völlig, im Englischen sagt man numb, sie sind stumpf.
Ja, wir müssen es nicht lange hören. Also wir hören diese Verknüpfung auch immer,
die politische Klasse als das Europa verrottende Krebsgeschwür.
Und das sieht man ja auch am naturell der Leute. Und dann wird irgendwas von,
die fliegen alle im Privatjet und ich denke so, nee, die Kommission hat nicht
mal eigene Flugzeuge oder Flugbereitschaft.
Die gehen aber nach Brüssel zum Flughafen und fliegen Economy irgendwo hin.
Das macht auch Ursula von der Leyen selbst.
Also da ist sozusagen, wir sparen uns jetzt auch von Horst nochmal den Nachtrag
zum Thema, da liegt einfach das falsche Mindset vor.
Diese Vorhandlungen kann man sich selber anhören.
Zurück zu Elon Musk. Er erklärt hier die Ziele von Doge.
Ich werde Elon Musk ein paar Worte sagen und wir nehmen einige Fragen. Elon, gehst du. Sure.
So, at a high level, you say, what is the goal of Dojo, and I think a significant
part of the presidency, is to restore democracy.
This may seem like, well, are we...
Das war übrigens diese berühmte Szene. Sein Sohn X ist ja immer da,
hält die Kleiderordnung ein, wendet sich Trump gegenüber zu und sagt ihm,
du bist nicht der Präsident.
Halt die Fresse, das ist ja das Originalzitat.
Während Elon Musk oben offenbar in voller Kontrolle über seine Aufgaben und
Verpflichtungen, zu der auch Kindererziehung gehört, nicht gewahr,
plötzlich das ganze Land irgendwie in seinem...
In a democracy? Well, if you don't have a feedback group... Okay, I would have to...
Sorry. Sorry, gravitas can be difficult, sorry.
Ja, der Spruch von Musk war, die Wahrheit kann manchmal ein bisschen anstrengend sein.
Also mit X kommt die Wahrheit ans Oval Office, Kindermund spricht Wahrheit, Grund.
Wahrscheinlich hat er doch gehört, was er gegen Trump gerade gesagt hat und
meint dann, ja, die Gravitas der Wahrheit. So, okay.
So, if there's not a good feedback loop from the people to the government,
and if you have rule of the bureaucrat, if the bureaucracy is in charge,
then what meaning does democracy actually have?
If the people cannot vote and have their will be decided by their elected representatives
in the form of the president and the Senate and the House, Dann leben wir nicht
in eine Demokratie, sondern wir leben in eine Bureaucracy.
Es ist unglaublich wichtig, dass wir die Feedback Group close,
dass wir die Feedback Group fixieren, und dass die Publikum der Repräsentativen,
die Präsidenten, der House und der Senat, entscheiden, was passiert,
als opposed zu einer large, un-Elected Bureaucracy.
So, dieser Clip ist wahnsinnig interessant, denn hier wird eine Unterscheidung
aufgemacht, die es so nicht gibt.
Nee, habe ich auch nie gehört.
Weder in der Empirie, noch in der Theorie, noch irgendwie. Es gibt keinen heuristischen
Zugang, der diese Unterscheidung irgendwie untermauert.
Denn er sagt ja hier, wir haben ja eine Demokratie, aber die Demokratie wird
ausgehöhlt, wenn nicht gewählte Bürokraten ins Verhältnis zwischen Einzelnen und Staat reinfunken.
Und Judith Muster ist es sehr wichtig, immer wieder zu betonen,
und sie hat sehr viel Erfahrung über diese Metaplan-Beratung und so,
dass die Bürokratie, und zwar überall, Ansprüche absichert.
Das macht sie über Regeln. Und die Regeln können auch stören,
und dann kann man auch Regel A
haben und sich Regel B wünschen und dann Reformprozess und was auch immer.
Aber man kommt aus diesem grundlegenden Prinzip nicht raus, wenn man als Unternehmer
Ansprüche auf Profite anmelden möchte.
Braucht man dafür Bürokratie. Ein gelebtes Regelwerk.
Man muss nämlich irgendwie den einzelnen Fabrikarbeiter oder sonstigen Dienstleister
aus der eigenen Belegschaft oder aus Zulieferbetrieben in Verbindung bringen
mit am Ende wird verrechnet und die Staatskasse sagt,
dieses Geld, das du verdient hast, ist wirklich deins. Hier ist der Bescheid.
Niemand, der das anzweifelt, darf diesen Anspruch anmelden. Die Bürokratie steht dir hier zur Seite.
Und Elon Musk hat dieses zentrale Prinzip immer für sich genutzt.
Und macht jetzt plötzlich diese Unterscheidung auf, die wahnsinnig dumm ist.
Um dann zu suggerieren, man müsse zu so einer Ad-Hoc-Demokratie kommen.
Es gibt ein weißes Blatt Papier, es gibt keine Regeln und dann machen wir das
gerade über den schnellen demokratischen Weg jedes Mal. Und das ist ja gar nicht möglich.
Ja, und da springen die nämlich jetzt rein und sagen.
Wir regieren alleine durch.
Nee, die sagen technologische Republik. Ich brauche keine Bürokratie,
also nicht gewählte Bürokraten, wenn ich Smart Contracts.
Wenn ich nicht gewählte Algorithmen doch habe.
Ja, ich kann das ja alles, wir Deutsche Auf- und Abgeklärte sagen ja,
es gibt keine soziale oder technische Lösung für soziale Probleme.
Das sehen die ja anders. Wir haben es ja bei Alex Karp gelesen.
Also hier wird sozusagen wirklich Alex Karp Ideologie einfach durchgepaukt.
Und mit Ideologie meine ich in dem Fall wirklich diese eine Idee, dass es gehen könnte.
Dass die Verknüpfung, um Ansprüche abzusichern, auf Geld, auf Arbeitsleistung,
auf was auch immer, was du bist, krank zu Hause, na dann gleich mal Lohn kürzen
und so, dass man das elektronisch absichern könnte.
Durch so Ethereum, Smart Contracts, irgendwas. Wenn, dann. Und dann wird es kryptomäßig abgehakt.
Also diese Idee ist, finde ich, die einzig logische Erklärung,
um überhaupt so eine Unterscheidung aufmachen zu können, dass es noch was anderes
gäbe, als eine Bürokratie, um Ansprüche abzusichern in einem Rechtsstaat.
Also in der Sicht, das ist alles schon sehr tiefgreifend, viel tiefgreifender
als man glaubt und eben auch wahnwitziger als man glaubt.
Denn diese Idee, dass er das jetzt da machen könnte, es mehren sich diese Publikationen
über diese ganzen Vorfälle, die es im Wahlkampf gab.
Also Trump wird angeschossen und alle sind sich einig, das ist wirklich nur diese Kopfdrehung.
Also da reagierte einfach das Chaos-Prinzip. Es war totaler Zufall.
Die sagen jetzt göttliche Fügung. Wir sagen, krass, das ist ja wirklich extrem unwahrscheinlich.
Oder auch Neuinterpretationen oder tiefgreifende Verhärtung,
wie wir Elon Musk gesehen haben. Den Clip haben wir auch gespielt.
Der war ja kurz vor der Wahl bei Tucker Carlson in diesem Gespräch.
Da ist nur ein weißer Raum. Sie sitzen quasi irgendwo im Himmel und so.
In der Wüste des Realen.
Genau, die Wüste des Realen. Wo er so die erste Frage bekommt,
Trump jetzt nicht gewählt wird, bist du Toast.
Und er sagt so, ja, dann bin ich echt Toast und so. Und es war ja echt ernst gemeint.
Also so wie er diese Geschichten erzählt, damals Tesla war eigentlich vor dem Abgrund.
Ich habe dann so ein Telefonat gemacht und er hat gesagt, ja,
ich schicke dir 10 Millionen und so, ich sichere dir den Kredit ab.
Nur deswegen gibt es noch Tesla.
Und Elon Musk's ganze Biografie schirft wirklich immer an diesem Kram so lang.
Und genau so managt er das hier auch.
Also die einzige Verschwörungstheorie, die noch funktioniert ist,
das ist einfach das regierende Chaos.
Man hofft einfach, dass die eigene Idee, die man so hat, also Thiels Carbs,
Marc Andresen, Ethereum und so, dass das irgendwie aufgeht.
Was ich ja nicht verstehe, ist, dass diese Leute ja doch dann so ideologisch
getrieben sind, dass sie gewisse Dinge nicht mehr sehen.
Ich will es mal so sagen, wir haben hier diesen Podcast begonnen mit diesem
Ausschnitt von Roderich Kiesewetter, haben über die Wähler-Täuschung der CDU gesprochen.
Jetzt habe ich das ja auch hier klar verurteilt, aber was man daran ja sehen
kann, ist, die CDU ist nicht ideologisch.
Also in dem Sinne, dass sie natürlich erst einmal was verspricht,
Entwählen und Schulden sind ganz schlimm, aber sie sieht natürlich am Moment,
die Ampel kam ja nicht weiter wegen dieser Schuldenklausel.
Das müssen wir noch vorher, bevor wir regieren, ändern, denn wir brauchen Investitionen.
Das haben wir zwar immer geleugnet, aber wir wissen es ja.
Und eigentlich ist dieser Weg, den Habeck mal sich erdacht hat,
ein guter. Den werden wir jetzt umsetzen mit ein bisschen weniger Klimaschutz.
Das war ja auch im Bundestag noch und hat dann im März gelacht.
Aber eigentlich ist der Weg gut. Das ist ja ein unideologisches Vorgehen.
Und sie haben das Glück, dass die Grünen ideologisch sind, in dem Sinne, dass sie sagen …
Ja, aus einer staatspolitischen Verantwortung und weil wir die Rüstung als ideologisches
Projekt auch gut finden, unterstützen wir das.
Eigentlich war es noch witziger, weil Merz wusste, er braucht Geld,
aber er hatte keine Ideologie dafür.
Also haben die Grünen gesagt, nimm unsere.
Im Prinzip ja. Und die Grünen waren dann so großzügig, wenn man möchte, oder?
Weil sie wirklich ideologisch sind. Also ich meine jetzt nicht ideologisch böse
verirrt, sondern im Sinne von, für die ist jetzt eine gewisse Linie das Wichtigste,
egal wer sie jetzt am Ende umsetzt.
Und dann sagen sie, dann lieber geben wir unsere Stimmen Friedrich Merz,
dass er die Aufrüstung und die Infrastruktur umsetzt, bevor es nicht passiert.
Sie hätten es ja sagen können, dass sie es nicht machen.
Andersrum nämlich war es ja so, Olaf Scholz hat ja mit Habeck zusammen an die
CDU signalisiert, nach der Entlassung von Christian Lindner,
wir könnten hier zusammen jetzt Milliarden mobilisieren.
Friedrich Merz, wo kommen wir da hin? Wir werden doch jetzt nicht diese wichtigen
Entscheidungen und sollen die Leute doch mal wählen.
Also da sieht man den Unterschied. Und was mich jetzt, deswegen sage ich das,
was mich hier so fasziniert ist,
dass ja der Inflation Reduction Act, durchaus ein erfolgreiches Projekt von
beiden war und vermutlich seinen eigentlichen Erfolg jetzt in den nächsten Jahren
voll entfalten wird, von denen die beiden Regierungen dann gar nichts mehr hat,
dass die das nicht aufgreifen und das einfach neu benennen und sagen,
das ist jetzt alles uns und Biden hat das nicht verstanden oder so.
Die könnten sich ja irgendein schönes Narrativ, hier kann man es mal sagen,
ausdenken, aber nee, das machen sie nicht, sie sind doof.
Der Reduction-Inflection-Act wirkt ja wie so ein Magnet.
Die Europäer hatten ja Angst, dass jetzt alles nur noch in Amerika stattfindet.
Mit der Idee, wir beliefern die Welt.
Und jetzt kommt Trump und sagt, 30% Kostensteigerung.
Aber wir wollen die Welt beliefern.
Genau, es passt nicht zusammen. Ich will mal einen Punkt noch sagen zu diesem Erfolg der Grünen.
Also mein Argument, das ist ein Green Deal, nochmal untermauern.
Die Grünen müssen jetzt nicht regieren und können trotzdem diese,
du sagst jetzt Ideologie, Klimapolitik umsetzen.
Weil sie einfach das im Verfassungsrecht verankert haben.
Sie können das sogar jetzt besser machen, weil die CDU das macht.
Genau, also nur Nixon konnte nach China gehen und so, diese ganze Logik kommt jetzt.
Mit dem besonderen Umstand, das ist eben die Umgedrehte.
Also Biden hat erfolgreich regiert und jetzt wird es zertrümmert und die Demokraten
gehen durch so ein tiefes Tal.
Habeck ging durch ein tiefes Tal und jetzt kommt die Grüne, jetzt zahlt es sich
aus. Das ist so erfolgreich, das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Und diese kleine Idee, das finde ich wirklich eine wahnsinnig witzige Pointe,
muss man sagen. So diese typischen Treppenwitze der Geschichte.
Du hast eine Regierung, die zu dritt zusammenarbeiten muss, um gerade so eine
einfache Mehrheit im Bundestag herzustellen.
Und dann verlierst du die auch noch.
So. Und jetzt hast du gar keine Mehrheit und regierst aber plötzlich alles.
Und eine Regierung, die vorher als nicht handlungsfähig gilt,
weil sie hat ja keine Mehrheit mehr, weil die FDP fehlt, jetzt ist ja das Level höher.
Wenn du das ändern möchtest, was die Grünen durchgesetzt haben,
brauchst du eine Zweidrittelmehrheit.
Wir reden aber von einer Glyko.
Die ist ja wahnsinnig weit entfernt von einer Zweidrittelmehrheit.
Das heißt, wir haben das ja immer kritisiert.
Das Verfassungsrecht wird so aufgebläht, das Grundgesetz ist doppelt so lang
geworden, weil man dem parlamentarischen Prozess nicht mehr traut.
Die machen dann nur noch Wahlgeschenke und so weiter und so fort.
Und in diesem Maße haben wir jetzt eine blockierte Merz Klingbeilregierung.
Und das finde ich schon genial irgendwie. Eine Regierung, die ihre eigene Mehrheit
verliert, fährt dann drei Monate später den größten Erfolg.
Des Koalitionspartners ein und setzt die folgige Regierung komplett schachmatten.
Die aber bei uns immer noch als Sehgewohnheit große Koalition und so gilt.
Also das ist wirklich das ist schon beeindruckend und in der Hinsicht haben
wir da wirklich einen krassen Green Deal eingefahren. Mehr kann man sich kaum wünschen.
Insofern ja, hast du dann recht.
So, zurück zur Bürokratie.
Musk kommt jetzt mit diesem Argument, mit dem er alles zertrümmern möchte.
Aber jetzt sagen wir, eigentlich, wir werden alle bläden.
Wenn Geld ist, wenn Ihr Taxpayer Dollar nicht verwendet, in eine sensibel und
frügel Art, dann ist das nicht okay.
Ihr Taxpayer Dollar müssen sich verwendet, was die Menschen wichtig ist.
Ich meine, es ist einfach common sense.
Es ist nicht draconian oder radical, ich glaube.
Es ist wirklich nur sagen, wir schauen alle die Expenditures und sagen,
ist das in der besten Interesse der Menschen? Und wenn es ist,
dann ist es gewählt. Wenn es nicht, dann sollte man es denken.
Es ist verrückt. Es ist eine Kurserie Examination von Social Security.
So,
also sein Wortlaut ist einfach, wir merken uns mal den letzten,
dass er da 150 Jahre alte Leute in der Statistik gefunden hat.
Sein Wortlaut ist, wir schauen uns, in Deutschland ist ja das Haushaltsgesetzbuch
1000 Seiten lang, so pro Jahr, in Amerika wahrscheinlich länger.
Und wenn man das so durchblättert mit gesunden Menschenverstand,
sagt man zu ganz vielen Sachen, die können weg.
Das ist nicht radikal und nicht drakonisch, das ist der gesunde Menschenverstand.
Und das ist sozusagen diese Einflugschneise für, das kriegt man algorithmisch umgesetzt.
Hier braucht man nicht mehr Menschen, die Ermessensentscheidungen treffen,
irgendwem irgendwelches Geldzuschuss dann und so weiter, sondern einfach eine Wenn-Dann-Regel.
Du bist arbeitslos, okay, Timer läuft, Dein Handy klärt dich auf,
90 Tage, kriegst du Überweisung auf dein PayPal-Konto, erledigt.
Da muss doch nicht noch jemand da sitzen und irgendwie in einem Bergwerk und
so weiter Papier ausfüllen.
So, und er hat jetzt schon darauf hingewiesen, da gibt es ja 150 Jahre alte
Leute in der Statistik. Das merken wir uns mal.
Das neue Prinzip, das haben wir ja schon festgestellt, wir haben es letzten
Monat beschrieben, aus einem anderen Themenfeld.
Zelensky sitzt im Oval Office und sagt, ich brauche Sicherheitsgarantien.
Und Trump sagt, Sicherheitsgarantien, ich schicke doch Amerikaner dahin,
das ist die Sicherheitsgarantie.
Also da muss doch kein Papierkrieg stattfinden, der das absichert.
Wir brauchen keinen Vertrag, sondern einfach nur, da sind Amerikaner, das reicht doch.
Die Russen werden ja wohl nicht Amerikaner abschießen, das ist unser Stolperdraht.
Wenn dann Amerikaner von Russen abgeschossen wird, ist das sofort unser Kriegseintritt.
Das hören wir jetzt hier auch. Also das wird so ein grundlegendes Prinzip.
Wir brauchen keine Bürokratie, weil wir ja, auch das heute Morgen Aufklärung
von Precht, Machiavelli hat sehr viel über die Republik geschrieben und ab und
zu über Strongman, aber er meinte immer nur den Guten, der immer das Gute will,
auch wenn er mal was Negatives macht.
So, und jetzt hören wir hier die Charaktereigenschaften des guten Herrschers.
Was sind die zwei ingredientien, die wirklich notwendig sind,
um den Budget zu reduzieren, um 2 Milliarden zu 1 Milliarden zu reduzieren?
Und es sind wirklich zwei Dinge.
Kompetenz und Wettbewerb. Und wenn man Wettbewerb und Wettbewerb wird,
dann wird man den Budget zu reduzieren.
Der gute Herrscher ist ein Kümmerer, der sich auskennt.
Und der kann dann auch das Budget halbieren.
Der kompetente Kümmerer.
So, wenn wir jetzt Amerika sehen gerade und die Leute, die da am Ruder sind
und wir sagen, die kennen sich weder aus, noch kümmern sie sich,
fällt das alles in sich zusammen.
Also dann ist einfach alles Nonsens. Dann muss auch nicht noch jemand in der
Zeit einen Kommentar schreiben, dass ja an dem Punkt schon was dran ist und
die Amerikaner wirklich das Recht haben, die Deutschen sollten mal mehr zahlen oder sowas.
Also entweder es passt, man schafft die Bürokratie ab, weil man den kompetenten
Kümmerer als Herrscher hat oder es geht halt nicht.
So, Musk, hier diese kurze Szenerie.
Wir haben ja bisher mal mit Metaphern bekommen. Ich will jetzt mal ein Bild
richtig zeigen. Das haben wir natürlich alle schon.
Du beschreibst uns jetzt mal aus ästhetischen Gründen. Wir haben einen ganz
kurzen Auftritt von Millay.
Er hat nur die Aufgabe, bei dieser CPAC-Veranstaltung die Kettensäge reinzubringen,
Musk in die Hand zu geben und dann wieder zu verschwinden.
Du sagst uns danach aus ästhetischen Gesichtspunkten, wie MeLay diese Aufgabe
meistert. Während die Hörer Musk hören. Ich sehe genau zu, ja.
So, bis hierhin, er übergibt die Kettensäge.
Ja.
Wie würdest du diesen Gang beschreiben?
Der eiert darunter, als hätte er irgendwas getrunken.
Es ist breitbeinig, verzögernd, jeder Schritt soll irgendwie von Bedeutung sein
oder so. Und er macht große Elefanten-Taps.
Eigentlich wie so eine Witzfigur. Oder könnte er vielleicht so als...
Er kann nicht mal gehen.
Ja.
Und man vertraut ihm jetzt an, als du bist der ideologische Vorgänger und so
weiter. Er schafft es nicht mal, auf eine Bühne zu gehen.
Ja, also man muss sich das wirklich so vorstellen, wie wenn früher Musikantenstadel
nochmal irgendjemand ganz alt ist, der in den 60ern Hit hatte,
nochmal zum Vollplayback auftreten darf, aber schon ganz vergessen hat,
das Mikrofon zum Mund zu führen.
Ganz, ganz schräg. So, jetzt kommt Elon Musk, er übernimmt die Kettensäge.
Das ist Becheza. Trendsor für Bureaucracy. Trendsor!
Oh!
Das ist gut.
Siehst du, Millet im Hintergrund, so wie er nicht auftreten konnte.
Ich weiß, soll ich jetzt gehen? Ich winke mal noch ins Publikum,
aber ich gehe mal einen Schritt zurück und so.
Jetzt ruhen Sie nochmal.
Gut, ich kriege nicht eine Praxis.
Das ist so schräg.
Also sowohl, er bringt uns einfach nur die, er hat keinen Text.
Wir stellen immer fest, Elon Musk hat auch keinen Text. Er schreit einfach, das ist das Programm.
Klar, er macht danach dieses Interview, wir hören gleich noch ein bisschen rein.
Also das ist sozusagen die inhaltliche Tiefe von allem, was wir hier sehen.
Jener, der jetzt irgendwelche Texte liest, gibt es einen großen roten Faden oder so.
Ja, die Frage wird ja sein, gibt es nur Elon Musk?
Also Elon Musk hat ja diese Vorstellung, man kann den amerikanischen Staat so
umbauen, wie er Twitter umgebaut hat.
Man entlässt ganz viele Leute und macht dann so ein paar neue Dinge und eigentlich
ist man aber auch nicht wirklich lukrativ damit.
Jedenfalls ist das ja mal die Idee, USA ist eigentlich wie Twitter,
deswegen bin ich der ideale Mann, um das zu machen.
Die Frage ist jetzt, gibt es in diesen republikanischen Reihen Bürokraten,
die jetzt positioniert werden,
die sich tatsächlich auskennen, um eine gewisse Doktrin in die Tat umzusetzen
und da tatsächlich Effizienzgewinne zu erzielen,
die aber dann natürlich auf Kosten von vielem gehen, was wir als wichtig empfinden würden.
Aber darum geht es ja eigentlich, weil Elon Musk wird sich ja nicht in irgendwelche
Papiere und Einzelheiten vertiefen.
Solche Sachen wie das mit dem Aufzug eben oder dass da bei den Renten 150-Jährige
immer noch Renten kassieren, das sind ja Dinge, die haben ihm mal Leute gesteckt
und mehr weiß er darüber nicht.
Schritt für Schritt machen. Es gibt jetzt Beobachtungen aus Deutschland.
Einmal so und einmal so. Einmal ganz dumm. Das ist so dumm, dass es quasi auf
Augenhöhe mit Elon Musk schafft die Bürokratie ab.
Und danach hören wir eine kluge Einschätzung, die nochmal auf deine Frage zurückkommt.
Bleiben wir aber zuerst bei diesen 150 Jahre alten Menschen.
Trump hat ja vor dem Kongress eine Rede gehalten, weil er es nicht ausgehalten
hat. Ich warte nicht mal 100 Tage, sondern ich berufe jetzt beide Kammern ein.
Was für mich ja immer schon so ein Zeichen ist, ja klar, das ist das große Megafon,
der große Auftritt, den kann man aber nicht immer machen.
Da hat man einen Schuss frei und den hat er jetzt verbraucht.
Also da muss er jetzt schon auf die State of the Union warten,
falls er mal wieder eine Botschaft hat.
Und dann hat er ja vor Ort sich auch anderthalb Stunden länger noch Zeit genommen,
das war ja die längste Rede aller Zeiten.
So, wir hören einen kurzen Ausschnitt, der geht eine Minute elf.
Und danach hören wir einen Ausschnitt aus deutscher Kommentierung dazu,
der geht auch eine Minute elf.
Eigentlich finde ich, es ist nicht misszuverstehen, was Trump hier auf der Bühne sagt.
Nämlich, ich übersetze aber so vorab, das ist diese Szenerie,
wo er sagt, Elon Musk hat in den Dokumenten, in den Statistiken,
100, 200 Jahre alte Leute gefunden, das geht ja nicht, das ist offenbar Fraud,
das ist Betrug, hier müssen wir rein, seht ihr, das ist alles fehlerhaft,
das muss zertrümmert werden.
Sie lachen sogar dabei. Er macht noch einen Witz gegen, gleich am Anfang,
zu Robert Kennedy, im Sinne von wir haben ganz schön gesunde Leute hier in Amerika,
findest du nicht, wenn die 150 Jahre alt werden.
Also sie machen sich wirklich lustig darüber. Wir hören uns das mal eine Minute
an und danach hören wir, wie deutsche Journalisten das verstanden haben.
Das ist Trump im Kongress.
Wir haben ein gesundes Land, als ich dachte, Bobby.
So,
wer hat mir schon gehört, To Finish, er hat jetzt schon eine Weile darüber gesprochen.
Wir haben das Gelächter schon gehört.
Sie machen sich gerade lustig über diese Bürokratie, in der 150 Jahre alte Leute
Rentenbeiträge überwiesen bekommen.
120 und 229, eine Person zwischen dem Alter von 240 und 249 und eine Person
ist auf 360 Jahre alt, mehr als 100 Jahre,
mehr als 100 Jahre älter als unser Land.
Aber wir werden wissen, wo das Geld geht.
And it's not going to be pretty. By slashing all of the fraud,
waste and theft we can find, we will defeat inflation,
bring down mortgage rates, lower car payments and grocery prices,
protect our seniors and put more money in the pockets of American families.
So, und jetzt hören wir Apokalypse und Filterkaffee mit Wolfgang Heim im Gespräch
mit einer deutschen Journalistin.
Das Trump-Highlight aus dem Kapitol in dieser Woche war für mich,
als es um die Sozialsysteme ging, um den Missbrauch bei den Sozialsystemen in
den Vereinigten Staaten, diese Zahl, die Trump genannt hat,
130.000 Menschen in den USA sind älter als 160 Jahre.
Fand ich großartig. Okay.
Du guckst überrascht? Ja, ich weiß nicht. Bist du über diese Passage nicht gestolpert?
Ich habe nicht mehr alles jetzt im Kopf von euch und jedes Ding.
Aber es ist ja, dass er einfach eine Lüge nach der anderen erzählen kann.
Das ist einfach irre. Das ist wirklich verrückt. Und dass man ihm das glaubt.
Er sagt ja auch immer, wie viel Geld er für die Ukraine gibt,
dass es viel mehr ist, als sie wirklich geben.
Und es sind alles so, also man ist ja fast geneigt, ihn nicht ernst zu nehmen,
wenn es nicht so ernst wäre.
Die großen amerikanischen Zeitungen haben doch in der ersten Amtszeit von Trump
einen Faktencheck gemacht und sind, glaube ich, auf ein vierstelliges oder fünfstelliges
Volumen von Trump-Äußerungen gekommen, die einfach Lügen waren.
Aber schlechte Nachricht, das interessiert die Trump-Anhänger entweder überhaupt
nicht oder sie finden es toll.
Was sagen wir dazu?
Ja, ich weiß es gar nicht.
Das sind Journalisten, die daneben sitzen, wenn der Staat und die Politiker
Sachen machen und die uns das kommentieren.
Und selbst wenn da jemand mit einer Motorsäge auftritt und sagt,
ich rufe den ganzen Kongress zusammen, beide Kammern, und wir lachen jetzt gemeinsam
darüber, wie die Demokraten hier einfach an 150 Jahre alte Leute,
betrugt, da das Geld auszahlen und deswegen muss alles zerstört werden.
Und das ist die Interpretation dazu.
Er lügt, der Trump.
Der hat schon wieder gelogen, der hat gesagt, da gibt es Leute,
die sind 150 Jahre alt. Also es ist wirklich so peinlich, ich weiß nicht,
Also klar, wir finden alle, das, was Trump da macht, ist dumm.
Aber wir können nicht noch größere Dummheit daneben stellen und sagen,
das ist ein politisches Gespräch im reichweitenstärksten Politik-Podcast Deutschland.
Das ist einfach bescheuert.
Und in dieser Maßgabe, dass wirklich niemand weiß, worüber er spricht,
Lanz redet über Bürgergeldempfänger, hat keinen Plan.
Leute reden von Bürokratie, sie haben keinen Plan. Leute sind nicht in der Lage,
eine Trump-Rede zu verstehen.
Obwohl sie einen Lachtrack dazukriegen.
Bitte hier lachen. Bitte eine Minute lang jetzt lachen. Wir machen das hier
gerade lustig. Nein, das wird ganz ernst genommen. Trump hat schon wieder gelogen.
Also es ist wirklich schlimm.
Entsprechend passiert eben auf deutschen Bühnen dann sowas.
Schwerpunkt waren heute jedoch die Themen Wirtschaft und Bürokratieabbau.
Wir sind bei der CSU, Parteitag.
Vor allem in Bezug auf die EU. In den letzten Jahren 3.500 Regulierungen in Amerika.
Zum selben Zeitpunkt 13.500 neue Regulierungen, Verordnungen und Richtlinien in Europa.
Meine Güte nochmal in Europa. Was macht ihr da? Das braucht kein Mensch in Europa.
Kümmert euch um die Handelspolitik, aber nicht um diesen, sorry, Pipifax.
Ja, könnte vielleicht daran liegen, dass Europa aus einzelnen Nationalstaaten besteht.
Möglicherweise erfordert das mehr Einzelregulierungen als in den USA.
Ich meine, unter dieser Maßgabe...
Und was ist das überhaupt für eine Zahl? Was soll ich jetzt sagen?
Oh, das ist viel, das ist wenig. Das ist ja unsinnig.
Unter dieser Maßgabe könnte man jetzt sagen, Trump ist der beste Präsident aller
Zeiten, denn er regelt alles in einem Gesetz.
Oder wir reden lieber darüber, dass der Trump wieder Fake News verbreitet.
Ich meine, dass die Botschaft dann ist, ja, er hat halt einfach nur ein Gesetz
frei zum Haushalt, dass er mit einer einfachen Mehrheit, danach braucht er 60%
Mehrheiten und die hat er halt nicht.
Also schreibt er einfach alles in ein Gesetz, aber unter dieser Maßgabe hier
läuft das als bester Präsident aller Zeiten. So effektiv, hat einfach nur ein Gesetz geschrieben.
Hat etwa 17.000.
Seiten und so und keiner blickt durch und so weiter, aber super gut.
Und jeden Tag Dekrete unterschrieben.
Genau, jeden Tag Dekrete. Also nicht nur dieser Bürokratie-Abbau-Scheiße,
sondern auch unser Gespräch aus der Ferne darüber.
Es ist auf Augenhöhe dumm, genauso.
Auf der politischen Bühne, in dem Podcast, überall.
Vor allen Dingen, Fritz Merz nimmt ja hier großen Anlauf, um riesige Enttäuschungen zu produzieren.
Denn völlig klar ist ja, dass er da gar nichts dran ändern wird.
Das ist ja genauso wie bei der Migrationsfrage, wo er sagte,
wenn ich Kanzler bin an Tag 1, mache ich da dies und das.
Nee, jetzt sind die schon seit zwei, drei Wochen über irgendwelche Kleinigkeiten
am diskutieren. Warum? Ja, weil so nun mal das Ganze läuft.
Und Lindemann so, nee, jetzt bloß keine Eile. Ja, also es geht drunter und drüber
und es ist alles wirklich wahnsinnig dumm. Außer Precht.
Precht hat, finde ich, sehr gute Einschätzungen gemacht im Landsgespräch am
14.03. ist das vor zwei Wochen.
Denn ganz offensichtlich ist das, was zurzeit von Donald Trump innenpolitisch
gemacht wird, mehr als ein Systemupdate.
Das ist in gewisser Hinsicht eine Kulturrevolution.
So, Kulturrevolution.
Ja, da sind wir bei Mao.
Ich bringe immer mal wieder den Holocaust ins Spiel, um Pointen zu machen.
Um mich zu erschüttern, damit ich dann immer denke, oh Gott.
Du kriegst dann Nachrichten und ich denke mir, das ist doch witzig.
Also die Nachrichten, nicht mein Vergleich.
Die Kulturrevolution ist weit weg gewesen von uns, aber beim Holocaust reden
wir über das industrielle Morden von 6 Millionen Menschen.
Bei der Kulturrevolution reden wir über zig Millionen Menschen.
Bürgerkrieg im eigenen Land. Also die Kulturrevolution, Hungersnöte überall,
also abgeräumte Institutionen, Misstrauen in den Familien überall, die Kulturrevolution.
Es wurde von oben etwas veranschlagt und dann, also da kann man zum Beispiel
sehr gut sehen, dass man ja einfach
von der Mao-Regierung Produktionsziele ausgegeben hat für den Stahl.
Die musste man irgendwie erreichen. Man hat nachher, ging das so weit,
dass wirklich die Bürger dazu aufgefordert wurden, ihr Geschirr mit in den Kessel
zu werfen, um die Stahlproduktion irgendwie hoch zu bekommen.
Schiffe wurden gebaut, die haben den Hafen zwei Meter verlassen und sind zusammengebrochen.
Also man hat wirklich ein totales Debakel angerichtet, zentral gesteuert von
einer Person, nämlich Mao und dann seinen Leuten natürlich.
Ja, aber das war genau diese, deswegen ist Kulturrevolution eigentlich ganz gut dieser Vergleich,
weil man wirklich dann an einen Punkt gerät, in dem man nur noch Ineffizienzen
produziert und zugleich aber eine autoritäre Herrschaft hat,
in der diese Ineffizienzen nur noch verschleiert werden können,
weil jeder Angst hat, dass das auf ihn zurückfällt.
Am Ende kommen...
Weder Schiffe noch Informationen wieder an beim obersten Führer,
weil keiner traut sich. Jeder wird sofort Kopfkürzer gemacht.
Zuerst dachte ich, okay, das ist so spontan von ihm. Aber nein,
er hat es am Ende noch ein zweites Mal erwähnt.
Und ein letzter Satz. Wenn es irgendetwas Historisches gibt,
woran mich das erinnert, ohne das gleichsetzen zu wollen, dann am ehesten an
die chinesische Kulturrevolution.
Da haben nämlich auch junge Menschen teilweise ihre Eltern vor das Tribunal
gestellt und deren Gesinnungen überprüft und deren Lebensleistungen infrage
gestellt und sich schikaniert und so weiter. Auch hier war es sehr,
sehr viel schlimmer als in Trumps Amerika.
Aber diese Vorstellung, dass ein 20-Jähriger dafür ausgesucht würde,
eine Art kultureller Revolution durchzuführen, das ist die große Gemeinsamkeit
zu Donald Trumps Amerika von heute.
Es kommt dann nochmal ein zweiter Begriff, den finde ich sehr viel passender.
Und Bürokratieabbau ist eine
wahnsinnig komplizierte Sache, weil man sehr behutsam bei vorgehen muss.
Und das ist etwas, was in den USA jetzt gerade nicht passiert hat.
Da gibt es ja quasi eine Art Bürokratie-Pogrom.
Ja, das Programm ist eine ersatzlose Vernichtung sozusagen.
Also hier geht es nicht um Umbau oder sonst irgendwie, sondern hier wird einfach
wirklich was aus dem Weg geräumt. Und jetzt müssen wir weiter diesem irren Gedanken
folgen, dass es da einen Anschlussplan gibt.
Also, dass man ohne diese menschengemachte Bürokratie mit Verwaltungsbeamten,
die eine Laufbahn haben,
also Erwartungen an die eigene Biografie und damit auch Wissenstransfer sicherstellen,
damit man überhaupt weiß, in welche Richtung es geht, dass es da irgendwas eine neue Idee gibt.
Und die wird hier so ein bisschen deutlich, wenn man den Wortlauten folgt.
Zum einen hören wir mal kurz bei Jon Stewart rein, der mal, ja,
also ich habe jetzt so Korruption reingeschrieben, man müsste jetzt so an Mafia
denken, also Korruption jetzt so im soziologischen, das ist ja nicht allzu negativ
betrachtet, wenn man sagt, okay, da gibt es so Überbrückungen,
die eigentlich nicht vorgesehen sind.
Also jemand nutzt eine politische Macht, um wirtschaftlichen Vorteil zu erregen
oder umgedreht und so. Im Alltag völlig gang und gäbe.
Man spielt halt so Vitamin Bs aus oder was auch immer.
Ist natürlich politisch heikel.
When he said that he was draining the swamp.
I understood that as, or I understand that phrase as, we are going to crack down on corruption.
I think what he's saying is, that's not how the world works.
So I am going to exploit corruption because we're the biggest bullies on the planet.
And it's time that we swing our thang and make that happen and say things like,
hey, Canada. I mean, why are you going?
Why Canada? You know, but is that, is he basically exposing how the world and how business works?
So, wenn man keine Bürokratie hat, werden Ansprüche, die man ja über die Bürokratie
regelhaft durchsetzt und anmeldet, anders angemeldet und durchgesetzt.
Also dann kommt der Knochenbrecher und sagt, ich bin der Stärkere und so.
Man kauft sich einfach Muskeln oder schnelle Autos oder was auch immer.
Und dann spielt man Macht aus oder Gewalt, sagen wir mal so.
Nun sagen wir ja immer, Bildung ist eine wichtige Sache, weil Bildung ist der
Weg, der integrative Weg in die Gesellschaft.
Sozialisation findet irgendwo statt. Es ist nicht ganz egal, wo man herkommt.
Und es gibt eine sehr interessante Doku über Elon Musk, weil die sich nämlich
seinen Vater beschäftigt oder zeigt.
Und der Vater sitzt dann halt so da und sagt, ja, wenn es nicht wehtut, ist es keine Erziehung.
So ungefähr. Also man kann bei Elon Musk ganz viel rein psychologisieren,
bei Trump aber natürlich auch.
Und zwar nicht nur über seinen Vater und so, also alle so Daddy-Issues,
sondern auch über die Herkunft da in New York City und Manhattan.
Zu seiner Jugendzeit, als er sich also gerade aufschwang, ich trete jetzt aus
dem Schatten ins Business hinein.
Und das ist jetzt New York Times Daily.
Also große Aufmerksamkeit. gesehen, oder?
Nee, den habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Der Film beginnt ja genau mit dieser Zeit. Und Trump hat was?
Das ist das Thema im ersten Drittel des Films. Ärger mit der Bürokratie.
Nämlich, sein Vater hat ja Wohnhäuser mit vielen, vielen einzelnen Wohnungen drin,
in denen Menschen leben, die Sozialhilfe bekommen,
kommen oder irgendwie gestört vom staat
unterstützt werden und die aber dann zum teil nicht richtig zahlen oder nicht
lukrativ sind und eigentlich darf trump die nicht rausschmeißen er soll das
aber tun und er findet dann wege über diesen anwalt in der kennenlernt wie er,
Das einfach ignoriert, wie er sich über den Staat hinweg setzt und dann ja auch einen Prozess führt.
Und klar macht dieser Anwalt dann, der Staat darf die Freiheit des Unternehmers nicht beschneiden.
Warum, wenn der keine Schwarzen in seinem Haus wohnen haben will, dann ist das einfach so.
Dann hat der Staat nichts mehr zu melden. Das ist der erste Grundkonflikt quasi,
den Trump bei seinem Unternehmertum mit dem Staat hat. Das ist von Anfang an da.
Genau, da wird einfach ein Eigentumstitel als Allmacht angesehen und der Staat
dann allenfalls als Erfüllungsbehilf des eigenen, aber dass die anderen auch
enttitelt sind, da zu wohnen, das wird dann ausgeblendet und da ist dann immer die Frage,
kann man sich dann anschauen, in dem Falle dann in Manhattan,
70er, 80er Jahre, wie weit treibt man denn diesen, er hat dann Wege gefunden, kurzen Dienstweg?
Wird er auch staatlich vielleicht gedeckt, wenn ausreichend viele Beamte davon
entsprechend profitieren?
Trump hat da einen interessanten Trick. Also es gibt einmal diesen Anwalt,
der ihn ja dann sehr lange betreut und das andere ist, dass er sich nicht nur
mit den Politikern, die auf seiner Seite stehen,
verbündet, sondern er verbündet sich mit der Öffentlichkeit.
Er weiß, ich kann über die Öffentlichkeit meine Themen spielen und das kann
man dann auch sehen, wie er das macht.
Und das ist ja auch wieder genau so ein Event dann im Oval Office,
dass Elon Musk dort steht, das Kind auch dabei, Trump sitzt da.
Genau diese Art ist das, was er schon früh dann lernt, Ende der 70er Jahre.
Diese Verklüngelung wird hier Machine Politics genannt, die Politikmaschine.
70s, 80s, that was run by machine politics, where lots of aspects of government,
frankly, some aspects of the media, some aspects of the real estate industry,
were tinged with corruption.
And Trump's sort of basic belief, and we hear him articulate this in various
ways, is everything is a little corrupt.
And he is suggesting in this case it's a lot.
So, und das haben wir ja gelesen, das geht ja bis heute in dieser Amazon-Story,
dass Jeff Bezos einfach in Manhattan, Washington und überall diese Veranstaltung
macht, Abendveranstaltung hier, da und so weiter, um die Öffentlichkeit und
alle so ein bisschen bewirtend mit ins Boot zu holen.
Man braucht also eine Öffentlichkeit, die dafür empfänglich ist und dann noch
eine Figur, die sie bespielt.
Und das ist dieses Bild von Trump. Also er war ja mit Musk zusammen,
als sie dachten, sie müssten jetzt mal der Öffentlichkeit so langsam ein bisschen
erklären und für Ruhe sorgen.
Was ja nicht besonders gut gelingt, bei Fox News, bei Sean Hannity.
Und das Gespräch ging so los.
Der Präsident hat in den Medien so ziemlich verletzt. Es ist wirklich unerwältig.
Und ich habe jetzt viel Zeit mit dem Präsidenten mit dem Präsidenten gespielt.
Und nicht einmal habe ich ihn gesehen, was etwas mean oder kruel oder falsch war. Nicht einmal.
Ich habe ihn seit 30 Jahren kennengelernt. Ja. Und ich habe nie jemanden so viel, als er hat. Ja.
Also wir werden einfach die Kategorien ausgetauscht. Hier geht es nur noch,
er ist ein Herrscher, aber er ist ein guter Herrscher. Ja, der beste Herrscher.
Er hat noch nie was Negatives gemacht.
Alle wollen ihm aber was Negatives. Wie halten Sie das aus? Ja, habe ich eine Wahl.
Also der Dialog könnte drehbuchhaft nicht besser geschrieben werden,
als so wie das hier abläuft, dass der reichste Mann der Welt eine Huldigung
auf deine Macht abgibt und sagt, noch nie hat jemand seine Macht so gut eingesetzt wie du.
Es ist nichts Schlechtes an ihm zu finden.
Und damit ist die Unterscheidung gesetzt, die Figur betont und das Spielfeld.
Wir machen das hier im Fernsehinterview mit der Öffentlichkeit,
der zuschauenden Öffentlichkeit.
Was eben auch bedeutet, Trump muss sich jetzt immer mehr mit den Richtern anlegen.
Deutsche Berichterstattung.
Es wird durchregiert seit dem ersten Tag. Mit enormer Geschwindigkeit macht
Trump 2.0 Politik, die teilweise geltendes Recht bricht.
Eine Neuinterpretation der Macht, auch vorbei am Kongress.
Es gibt verfassungsgemäßen Widerstand, etwa durch Gerichte, aber den will Trump beiseite schieben.
Manche sehen die USA in Woche 3 der neuen Regierung in einer...
Wir sehen hier seinen Schreibtisch. Da stapeln sich die Dinger immer mit einem
gelben Postel drauf, damit überhaupt
noch jemand die Überblick über diese ganzen Dokumente da seine...
So sagt es aus, dass du alle Bücher signiert hast.
Genau, so sieht das dann aus. Er möchte sich an keinen einzelnen Richterspruch,
der von außen an ihn herangeht, halten.
Aber teilt die ganze Zeit solche Beschlüsse aus, die so quasi Richter...
Produziert also immer mehr davon. Aber die Unterschrift ist schon grandios, oder?
Die Unterschrift ist sehr gut, aber der Stift ist halt peinlich.
Ja, aber die Unterschrift ist halt so genial.
Ja, aber man schreibt nicht mit so einem Filzer. Das macht man in der zweiten Klasse.
Gut. Aber wie, er schreibt es schon toll. Ich bin ganz begeistert von dieser Unterschrift.
Also, er schreibt so. Es beginnt mit einem großen Bogen und dann kommt einfach
nur zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, rum und rum und oben.
Und dann nochmal einen großen Abschluss. Es ist sehr schön. Fällt mir gut.
Es ist absurd.
Verfassungskrise.
So, also wir sind ja am 12. Februar, aber jetzt wird schon von Verfassungskrise gesprochen.
Es ist nicht übertrieben zu sagen, dass wir gerade dem Tod der Demokratie ins Auge blicken.
So, das ist jetzt Chris Murphy, also ein Senator.
Das Kernstück unserer Demokratie ist, dass wir Gerichtsurteile befolgen.
Strafrechtliche, zivilrechtliche, verfassungsgerichtliche Urteile.
Niemand steht über dem Gesetz.
Es gibt eine Vielzahl von Klagen gegen Trumps Anordnungen.
So wurde die Abschaffung des in der Verfassung
verankerten Rechts auf Staatsangehörigkeit per Geburt blockiert.
Und ein Bundesgericht wies die
Regierung an, Milliarden eingefrorener Bundeshilfen sofort freizugeben.
Kein Richter sollte sowas entscheiden dürfen, das ist eine Schande.
Aber was, wenn die Exekutive die Judikative einfach ignoriert?
Der Vizepräsident macht klar, dass er die verfassungsgemäße Kontrolle durch
die Justiz nicht akzeptiert.
Wenn ein Richter versuchen würde, einem General vorzuschreiben,
wie er eine militärische Operation durchzuführen hat, wäre das illegal.
Richter dürfen die legitime Macht der Exekutive nicht kontrollieren.
Man braucht also eine militärische Operation. Die darf ja auch nach innen gerichtet
sein. Es ist ja kein Bundeswehr, kein Einsatz im Inneren oder so.
Also hier wird so langsam vorbereitet. Das Wasser wird so gekocht.
Ja, man transformiert das Land in einen permanenten Ausnahmezustand.
Für diese El Salvador-Auslieferungen hat man ja auch schon ein Kriegsrecht angewandt.
Da ist dann einfach die Frage, wann sagen Richter, das geht aber nicht,
haben sie ja in dem Fall auch und dann sagen die wieder, wir halten uns nicht
dran und irgendwann kommen Beamte in die Verlegenheit.
Also sie werden einfach widerstreitende Rechtstitel angebracht,
der Präsident sagt, ich darf das machen und dann sagen Richter,
nee nicht und dann muss ein Beamter eine Entscheidung treffen.
Wie er das jetzt macht, also da wird es einfach zugespitzt.
Was jetzt hier für die Diskussion bedeutet, Münkler macht mehrere Anmerkungen
im Deutschlandfunk-Interview der Woche, was ich übrigens, ich will es mal betonen, sehr gut finde.
Im Interview der Woche dürfen durchaus mal nicht aktive Politiker sein.
Leute, die so ein bisschen für uns da sind, uns was erklären und so weiter.
Wissenschaftler, also es ist nicht verkehrt. Es war ja mit Drosten auch schon,
dass man Drosten nochmal eine halbe Stunde Interview der Woche gemacht hat. Hier Münkler.
Trump Leute begnadigt hat, die am Sturm aufs Kapitol beteiligt waren und rechtmäßig
verurteilt sind, die mitverantwortlich sind für den Tod anderer Leute und sie
werden jetzt von Trump als Befreiungskämpfer gefeiert,
dann kann man nur sagen, ja, es ist einer, der nicht nur in der Außenpolitik,
was Putin anbetrifft, sondern auch in der Innenpolitik permanent mit Kriminellen
erkungelt und kuschelt.
Und wenn man denn je auf Werte Wert gelegt hat und nicht nur auf geopolitische Gesichtspunkte,
dann wird man mit diesem Präsidenten und seinen Leuten am besten wenig zu tun
haben, außer es ist aus Geschäftsgründen zwingend angezeigt.
So, man hält sich dann lieber fern. Wir haben das in guter Praxis.
Wir reden nicht mit Nordkorea.
Und die Telefonate, die mit Putin stattfinden, müssen halt Sachen regeln.
Ja, aber zum Beispiel hätten die ja mal besser wieder stattfinden müssen.
Aber Nordkorea ist für uns jetzt volkswirtschaftlich so interessant,
ob es das Land gibt oder nicht.
Macht keinen Unterschied.
Das auch, aber es ist ja nun einmal so, wir haben jetzt eben den Rheinmetall-Chef
gehört, wir wissen wie sehr die deutsche Wirtschaft mit der amerikanischen verbandelt
ist, wie Europa mit Amerika verbandelt ist.
Es ist doch völlig illusionär zu glauben, dass sich daran jetzt etwas ändern
lässt in der Weise, dass man die Kontakte abbricht.
Dass da möglicherweise jetzt ein paar andere Handelsbeziehungen noch entstehen.
Ist ja zu begrüßen, aber es ist ja auch interessant, dass Münkler sagt,
man hält sich von denen fern.
Es sei denn, das ist ja der Einwand, dann auch geschäftlich.
Und geschäftlich bedeutet ja, das ist das Eigentliche.
Also das ist ja, warum soll man sonst mit anderen Regierungen zu tun haben?
Meistens geht es um geschäftliche Dinge, vielleicht mal einen Gefangenenaustausch,
vielleicht mal dies, das, aber es sind geschäftliche Beziehungen.
Ich widerspreche mir selbst.
Denn ich… Also zu glauben, dass das jetzt damit abgewickelt ist,
ich sehe das auch nicht bei der kommenden Regierung.
Also wir haben eine CDU, in der ganz viele Leute Trump gut finden.
Das geht bloß von Tilman Koban, geht über Philipp Amthor, Jens Spahn und Friedrich
Merz, weiß ihn auch immer zu loben, der Ton gefalle ihm nicht immer,
aber doch eigentlich toll.
Und wer soll denn jetzt dort sich in Stellung bringen und sagen,
nee, mit der Trump-Regierung kooperieren wir nicht.
Das ist doch auch nicht die Möglichkeit.
Die wir haben.
Nein, Olaf Scholz, und das fand ich ja das klügste überhaupt,
hat ja jedes Mal dazu gesagt, nur mit den Amerikanern.
Also er hat bei beiden sowieso immer gesagt und das hält er ja bis heute durch.
Und das finde ich sehr klug, denn es sind ja die Amerikaner,
die keine inhaltlichen Vorschläge mehr machen, die uns anfeinden,
die J.D. Vance nach München schicken und so weiter.
Die Deutschen sollten darauf niemals öffentlich reagieren und immer daran appellieren,
dass uns ja die Amerikaner die Demokratie brachten, sie weiterhin immer bei
uns willkommen sind und wir ihre Freunde,
aber nicht auf einer inhaltlichen Ebene, sondern einfach nur immer diesen Appell loswerden.
Ja und ich habe eher die Angst, dass die das auf einer inhaltlichen Ebene machen.
Genau, diese Angst habe ich auch. Aber ich halte das für eine sehr kluge Taktik,
zu sagen, ja ja, da gibt es schon Brüche, aber die gehen von uns nicht aus.
Wir Deutsche, wir sind es nicht, sind die Amerikaner.
Und man muss eben Sachen führen und Münkler legt ja nochmal nach.
Trump ist ein so erratischer Typ, der macht, was er will und ab und zu weiß
er am Abend noch nicht, was er am nächsten Tag wollen will.
Insofern kann man vielleicht jetzt augenblicklich mal ein Gespräch mit ihm führen,
wo man das Gefühl hat, ich bin dann rangekommen, aber ob er sich daran am nächsten
Tag noch erinnert und ob das für ihn handlungsleitend ist. Das würde ich bezweifeln.
Weshalb ich meinen Appell nochmal verhärte, erhärte, wenn Staatsbesuche anstehen.
Erstmal eine Wagner-Oper gucken, sich dann von Sterne kochen lassen,
dann Sightseeing draußen, der Besuch auf dem Lande, wenn die dann wollen,
dass man irgendwas Inhaltliches diskutiert, kurz auf die Uhr gucken und sagen,
sorry, es ist schon so spät.
Ja, ja.
Also nur Hollywood vorspielen quasi, wie sie sich das alte Europa vorstellen.
Alle Kulturgüter zeigen, also der Macrons Einladung von Trump nach Notre Dame,
um dort das Erwachen der Orgel zu feiern. Ist für mich immer noch das Highlight des letzten Jahres.
Wir haben es ja im Salon ausführlich gehört auch, was da stattfand.
Perfekt, ja, also so muss das jetzt. Und wir haben ja nun genug,
wie heißen sie hier, die ganzen Heritages, also hier angefangen.
Marxburg.
Marxburg auch, aber jetzt mal angefangen von Akropolis ganz im Osten und dann
fährt man einfach bis nach Portugal durch und guckt sich alle 50 Städten an
und dann hat man alles gesehen.
Michael Hüther. Sehr wichtiger Clip in seinem Handelsblatt-Podcast.
Appell an alle Journalisten.
Das Erstaunliche. Ich meine, man steht ja ein bisschen ratlos davor.
Was denkt der sich eigentlich? Gut, man denkt ja manchmal nicht wirklich,
dass er sich viel denkt, weil diese Kindergartenveranstaltung mit dem Golf von
Mexiko, der jetzt Golf von Amerika heißt und dann fliegt der da drüber auf dem Weg zum Superpol.
Ich meine, das ist natürlich alles Politikinszenierung und da wird jeder Stoß
vorgetragen, als sei das eine neue Erkenntnis.
Und ganz beachtlich finde ich, weiß nicht, wie dir es geht, dass manche unserer
deutschen Kollegen ja auch nichts Besseres zu tun haben, als noch die intelligenten
Krümel in dieser O-Samen zu suchen, der da irgendwo drin sein soll.
Ich habe da jedenfalls nichts wirklich Intelligentes bisher gefunden.
Ja, ihr werdet auch von mir demnächst neue...
Reaktionen auf Gesprächsofferten sehen, also wenn irgendwer kommt und meint,
er müsse mir jetzt nochmal und hätte da so einen roten Faden gefunden und es
deckt sich ja auch mit hier und da und die Heritage Foundation und das Marolago-Papier
und die Zölle und so, dann sage ich, keine Angst vor Dummheit.
Hier liegt keine Verschwörung vor, ist einfach dumm.
Das Chaos ist zu groß, die Leute sind sich selber nicht einig,
das ist freies Kräftespiel, jeden Morgen wieder neu, Münkler sagt ja auch.
Gut, bei Trump selbst, also da gebe ich dem ja auch recht.
Es hängt alles an Trump.
Es hängt momentan alles an Trump, aber Trump ist ja auch nicht für die Ewigkeit da.
Wenn Trump aus dem Weg geräumt wird, Ole macht sich immer wieder darüber lustig,
dass meine zentrale Theorie ist, Trump wird diese Amtszeit nicht überleben,
weil sich irgendwann in einem freien Kräftespiel herausstellt,
J.D. Vance kann es jetzt übernehmen.
Und dann plötzlich, so ein alter Mann, irgendwie irgendwas passiert.
Und da ist durchaus.
Dann wird es gefährlich. Aber solange alle ins Oval Office zu Trump rennen müssen.
Ja, natürlich. Jetzt ist das alles völlig kontingent.
Runter und drüber. Diese neue Praxis. Es sind Säuberungen.
Es sind auch im deutschen Journalismus interessantere Moderationen.
Guten Abend. Das, was Donald Trump gerade mit US-Regierungsangestellten,
Behörden und Organisationen veranstaltet, die ihm ein Dorn im Auge sind,
nennen Kritiker eine Säuberung.
Wie angekündigt, durchforstet er gemeinsam mit seinem Effizienzbeauftragten
und Milliardärskumpel Elon Musk die Verwaltung der Vereinigten Staaten.
Sie feuern und beurlauben Beamte, denen sie vorwerfen, nutzlos,
illoyal oder amerikafeindlich zu sein.
Demokratische Kontrolle durch Parlament oder Justiz, für Trump egal.
Offenbar geht es um viel mehr als um die Verschlankung der Bürokratie.
Ja, es geht um mehr. Es ist ein Umbau, es ist ein Progrom. Man kann es vergleichen
mit einer Kulturrevolution.
Es ist eine Säuberung, sagen Kritiker, die das nicht gut finden.
Wenn wir in Deutschland jemanden haben, der das gut findet, Jens Spahn,
der kann das von mir nennen, wie der will. Aber wir nennen das bitte Säuberung.
Also da finden einfach Säuberung statt.
Denn es ist ja nicht einfach nur die Kettensäge, es wird ja auch gezielt zugegriffen,
wie hier im Justizministerium.
Beim FBI müssen Angestellte angeben, was sie mit den Untersuchungen zum Kapitolsturm zu tun hatten.
Eine Liste mit tausenden Namen wurde bereits dem Justizministerium übermittelt.
Von Säuberung ist die Rede.
Also tausende Menschen, die dort vor Ort sind und das Verbrechen begehen,
alle begnadigt. Und die tausenden, die das aufarbeiten wollten,
sind jetzt plötzlich die Verbrecher.
Das ist einfach, hier wird nicht einfach nur irgendwas abgebaut,
sondern hier wird umgebaut.
Und ist denn das alles so neu? Also wenn wir die 50er Jahre uns denken,
wir haben gerade noch hier ein Namensschild, eine Plakette gesehen, J.
Edgar Hoover, wenn wir an die McCarthy-Ära denken, wie dort zum Beispiel Künstler,
intellektuelle Wissenschaftler verfolgt wurden.
Wo jedem, der die Regierung oder das Regierungshandeln kritisierte,
gleich unterstellt wurde, er sei Spion für die Kommunisten.
Und man dort auch sehr viele Institutionen eingerichtet hat,
die man im Übrigen dann nachher auch nicht wieder abgebaut hat,
die genau solche Verfolgungen durchgenommen haben und damit ein Klima geschaffen
haben, dass viele sagen, dann schweige ich lieber, damit ich gar nicht je auf
eine solche Liste komme.
Da frage ich mich, ob wir es jetzt mit so einem völlig neuen Phänomen zu tun haben.
Also wir sehen uns natürlich auch danach immer das völlig Neue zu erkennen.
Aber vielleicht ist es doch ganz gut, Trump mehr auch in eine gewisse Linie
zu stellen, die uns jetzt als besonders radikal vorkommt und das ist sie in gewisser Weise auch.
Die aber dann doch im Ganzen gesehen zeigt, wie sehr der Staat immer wieder
solche autoritären Ausmaße annehmen kann.
Oder wir hatten ja hier zum Beispiel eine sehr lange Diskussion im Podcast über
diese Antisemitismus-Klausel, die im Bundestag dann durchgewunken wurde. Dies ist ja auch...
Ein Instrument, mit dem man die Meinung in Deutschland ganz klar beschneiden
kann und die auch dazu führen kann, dass Fördermittel entzogen werden,
dass Leute auf schwarze Listen gesetzt werden.
Das ist jetzt natürlich noch etwas sehr Partikulares, da es geht ja um diesen einen Bereich.
Aber man kann dann ja sehen, wie schnell das in eine andere Richtung ist.
Wir hatten die CDU gehabt, die sich jetzt mal angefragt hat,
welche NGOs werden eigentlich gefördert.
Das sind ja alles Tendenzen, die zu erleben sind.
Deswegen glaube ich, dass wir uns keinen Gefallen tun, wenn wir Trump als so
eine besondere Figur immer nur sehen. Das ist er in seiner ganzen Art und seinem Auftreten, ja.
Aber dass das doch eher eine allgemeine Tendenz ist, dass zum Beispiel auch
die Meinungsfreiheit in Bezug auf NATO-Einsätze und NATO-Politik in Großbritannien
sehr stark eingeengt wurde in den vergangenen Jahren,
ist ja auch etwas, was festgestellt werden darf.
Das heißt, wir haben doch hier eher so eine Strömung, die wir sehen,
die jetzt gerade ein besonderes Ausmaß auch deshalb annehmen kann in den USA,
weil der Präsident mit einer so großen Machtfülle ausgestattet ist und auch
weil man gerade für eine gewisse Zeit in dieser glücklichen Situation ist als
Republikaner, dass man die Macht auch wirklich ganz bei sich hat.
Wenn da bald wieder die Midterms anstehen und so weiter,
dann haben wir vielleicht auch andere Kräfteverhältnisse, die genau diese Tabula
Rasa Politik oder diese Säuberungspolitik wegen mir auch wieder etwas abbremsen werden.
Ich will das damit nicht verharmlosen, ich glaube aber schon,
dass es wichtig wäre, das mehr in Relation zu setzen.
Ja, also ich glaube, in dieser Relationierung jetzt liegt schon eine Verharmlosung,
denn wir haben es ja hier damit zu tun, dass sich Donald Trump auf der einen
Seite eine Privatarmee aufgestellt hat, also die Leute, die jetzt nicht mehr...
Bis zu 25 Jahre im Gefängnis sitzen, sind ihm zu immer dankbar. Und sie sind bewaffnet.
Und man hat gesehen, dass sie zur Gewalt bereit sind. Und die scheuen sich auch
nicht davor, ins Parlament zu stürmen, wenn da irgendwas ist und Trump Hilfe
braucht. Und da stehen jetzt Tausende bereit.
Gleichzeitig werden ganz gezielt aus dem Ministeriumsbetrieb die Leute ausgesiebt,
die die damals verurteilt haben. Also das ist eine echte Verdrehung.
Das ist sozusagen nicht eine, wir fragen mal an und machen im Vorfeld so ein
bisschen was und so weiter, sondern das ist,
hier geht's das ist sozusagen die Zielsetzung für alles, was du jetzt beschrieben
hast, was jetzt gerade unter Merz und hier mal eine Frageliste und schon mal
eine Liste führen, wer nervt mich besonders? Ah ja, frag den Staat und Arne Semsrott und so.
Hier würde Arne Semsrott schon richtig ins Gefängnis wandern.
Und man würde ihn wegen irgendeinem Spionage Ding, weil hat er das eigentlich
richtig formuliert mit Informationsfreiheitsgesetz soll jetzt auch schon abgeschafft
werden. Ja, damit genau.
Und dann hält noch Philipp Amthor die Rede dafür im Bundestag,
gegen das Gesetz, das ihn selber schon mal fast die Karriere gekostet hat.
Ja, ich sag ja, wir haben ja gewisse Tendenzen.
Aber hier sitzen halt alle schon im Gefängnis. Also hier ist Philipp Amthor
Justizminister und Arne Semsrott sind im Gefängnis. Das ist die Realität jetzt in Amerika.
Plus, weil du jetzt sagst, wir wissen ja nicht, wie die Kräfteverhältnisse in zwei Jahren sind.
Also in zwei Jahren Kongress, vielleicht spielt ja gar keine Rolle mehr.
Trump braucht jetzt gerade auch nicht den Kongress. Der macht alles über Dekrete.
Der fährt da höchstens hin, um eine Rede zu halten.
Dann ruft er alle zusammen und sagt, ihr klatscht jetzt alle für mich und dass
die nicht klatschen, ist ja allen klar. Hier kann ich ja sagen, was ich will.
Nur sind ja die Bundesstaaten auch mit einer erheblichen Macht ausgestattet.
Es ist ja kein Weg so, dass die einfach nur spuren dürfen.
Natürlich, aber nur die.
Die… Was ich sagen will, ich glaube auch, dass das zu nicht nur Reibung kommt,
sondern ich sehe ja auch die reale Gefahr von richtig massiver Gewalt,
gerade mit so einer privaten Armee.
Zugleich ist diese privaten Armee ja, wenn man es genau nimmt,
ein lächerliches Häuflein von irgendwelchen komischen Leuten,
die mit dem Gewehr rumrennen.
Es ist ja nicht nur die privaten Armee, sondern es ist ja auch der Einbruch, den man hat.
Ja, ich will nur sagen, man kann ja mit denen jetzt keine Revolution machen, mit diesen Leuten.
Die können... Die können viel Schaden anrichten und viele Menschenleben auch ruinieren.
Ich weiß nicht, welche Botschaften und welche Chatgruppen die gerade so haben.
Aber es gibt ja auch eben ein Militär, das sich jetzt nicht kommt.
Also ein Militärputsch zum Beispiel, wenn den Trump jetzt durchsetzt.
Also Trump herrscht ja nicht über das Militär in gleicher Weise wie zum Beispiel
Erdogan über das Militär herrscht.
Wir dürfen jetzt nicht wieder diesen Fehler machen, wie ich vorhin immer schon
angemerkt habe, dass wir jetzt so rote Fäden und Programme, also der herrscht
ja nicht über das Militär, oder wie würden die sich behalten?
Also Elmar Tewissen geht ja so weit zu sagen, da erleben wir jetzt einen Faschismus,
und der baut das jetzt da alles ganz um.
Ja, und das ist alles, diese Begriffe brauchen wir nicht.
Und da würde ich sagen, mit diesen Begriffe kommt man nicht weiter.
Man kann auch wegen mir da Bürokratie-Pogrom zu sagen, aber führt uns das jetzt tatsächlich?
Ja, also immer wenn ich sowas höre im Fernsehen, das schmerzt mich schon, das zu sehen.
Deswegen, wir haben ja heute schon eine Austritt, die mal gut waren und so,
Aber das Bild ist doch folgendes.
2021 im Januar war dieser Sturm aufs Kapitol.
Da wurden jetzt tausende Leute befragt, Familien sind in Mitleidenschaft gezogen
worden, wo ist denn ihr Sohn gerade, der ist hier flüchtig, der war da dabei,
der hat doch nichts Schlechtes getan und so.
Und dann wurden sehr viele hunderte, tausende ins Gefängnis gesteckt.
Die, sagen wir mal, Hinterbliebenen dieser Gefängnisinsassen haben sich alle organisiert.
Die haben ihre Townhalls gemacht, die haben sich getroffen, die haben ihre Chatgruppen,
die haben sich im Internet organisiert. Die sind nach Washington gefahren und
haben gesagt, Trump, du bist gewählt, du hast uns versprochen,
du begnadigst sie und so weiter und so fort.
Das heißt, diese Begnadigung am Tag 1 fiel auf so einen organisierten Raum.
Plus diese Ansage von Trump, die ganze alte Regierung und selbst meine alte
Regierung und Fauci und alle keine Sicherheit.
Trump legt es also drauf an, dass es zu Gewalt auf der Straße kommt.
Also er legt es drauf an, dass da irgendwelche Leute erschossen werden. Fauci ist tot.
Wäre nicht ein Schock im Sinne von ah jetzt seht ihr es, die Trump-Regierung,
das führt dazu, dass nein, die warten darauf, dass endlich die eigene Planung jetzt losgehen kann.
Wir können jetzt nicht mehr auf den Kongress warten. Irgendein Gericht hat was
gesagt, hier ist Bürgerkrieg auf der Straße.
Wo man ja eine ganz interessante Parallele sehen kann ist, Und zu Narendra Modi,
der hatte ja auch die Wahl damals schon gewonnen durch den Social Media Wahlkampf.
In gewisser Weise ist Modi Trump vorausgegangen, was Social Media anbelangt
und auch das Ignorieren des großen Fernsehens, sondern wirklich zu sagen,
ich muss an die Community ran.
Überall diese Stimmungsfilmchen.
Und was ja Narendra Modi auch so besonders stabilisiert hat und auch für Furcht
und Schrecken sorgt, ist, dass er so eine private Armee hat, die dort...
Und da kann man es glaube ich sagen, Art pro Chrome durchführt.
Und wenn man jetzt denkt, dass Trump die zweite Chance hat und überlegt,
woran scheiterte es dann, dann wird er ja sofort sagen, Marc Milley,
so ein Typ, der stand mir da nachher im Wege.
Also das Militär ist vielleicht noch nicht so ganz hinter mir.
Vielleicht brauche ich dann nochmal zusätzlich eine Einheit,
die da ein bisschen schlagkräftiger ist und ganz meinen Willen umsetzt.
Und ja, diese Gefahr ist natürlich real.
Also Blümkort hat keine Armee, die ihm was durchsetzt. Trump wird eine haben.
Also hier ist alles brenzlig. Elmar Tewissen erklärt kurz, das ist auch so ein
Handlungsstrang, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Also ich denke, das ist nicht ganz falsch.
Die beiden gemeinsam sorgen dafür, dass Staatsbedienstete auf diese Weise gefeuert
werden, die eigentlich einen besonderen Schutzstatus in den USA genießen.
Und sie schaffen ganze Behörden komplett ab, obwohl ein Teil dieser Behörden,
zum Beispiel USAID, vom amerikanischen Kongress vom Parlament genehmigt worden ist.
Und jetzt geht es darum, dass diese Klagen, die angestrengt werden,
durch die Instanzen laufen.
Donald Trump will am Ende, dass der oberste Gerichtshof entscheidet und ihm
dann tatsächlich alle Macht gibt in der Exekutive.
Und wenn er es dann täte, dann würde
das ein großes Fragezeichen über die Gewaltenteilung in den USA aufwerfen.
Also Trump verursacht jetzt Chaos in der Hoffnung, dass der Supreme Court mal
entscheidet und er dann im richtigen Moment vorher nochmal da vielleicht anruft
oder so und sagt, auf euch sieben Leute kommt es jetzt an.
Und man hat ja schon, diesen Clip finde ich hochinteressant,
die, Bennett heißt sie glaube ich, eine der drei Richterinnen,
die Trump miteinander hat in seiner ersten Amtszeit, die war ja auch mit im
Kongress, als er da seine Rede hielt.
Und diese Begrüßung von den beiden, also wie sie da steht und Trump begrüßt.
Und nachdem Trump dann seinen Blick endlich von ihr abwendet,
sie so richtig erleichtert ist, wie so der Peiniger ist endlich vorbeigezogen
und dann schluckt sie nochmal und so, weißt du.
Ich glaube auch, da laufen so Kommunikationen, die sich nicht gut machen im Geschichtsbuch.
Aber sehr viel der Frage beantworten, wie war es möglich.
Das ist nur mal so. Also der Supreme Court wird sozusagen langsam rein provoziert
in die, na der wird ja dann nicht gegen die öffentliche Meinung oder je nachdem.
Der Proud Boys Chef wurde halt damals schon im Wettstreit mit Biden als Stand
Back, Stand By ausgerufen.
Biden hat ihn dann, also während Biden wurde er verurteilt. Nicht Biden hat
ihn verurteilt, während Biden wurde er verurteilt zu mehr als 20 Jahren oder
so und Trump hat ihn jetzt wieder freigelassen.
Also der Typ hat seine Loyalität und seine Gewaltbereitschaft gezeigt.
Und wenn der Supreme Court eine Entscheidung zu treffen hat,
die nicht allen gefällt und so weiter. Der Kongress.
So,
mal kurz diesen Kontext. Also sie sitzen in diesem Gespräch mit Sean Hannity,
und Trump so, bei Fox News und Trump so, du schreibst so ein schönes Dekret.
Und dann kommt so eine Bürokratie und zerredet dir das wieder.
Und er hier neben mir, der geht aber mit seinen 100 jungen Geniuses da rein
und kriegt Sachen geregelt.
...jungen Leute arbeiten für ihn, die sich viel besser als ihn drehen.
Sie drehen nur in T-Shirts.
Du wirst nicht wissen, dass sie 180 haben. Er ist deinem Tech-Support.
Nein, nein, er ist. Aber er ist viel mehr als das. Ich bin Tech-Support,
aber... Er ist ein Leader.
Du hast viele Tech-Leute, und du hast Leute, die gut mit Tech-Leute, But he gets it done.
You know, I said in real estate, you had guys that would draw beautiful renderings of a building.
And they'd draw the rendering. It would be great. And you'd say,
great. When are you starting?
But they were never able to get it built. They couldn't get the financing.
They couldn't get the approvals. It would never get done.
And then you have other guys that are able to get it done. You know,
they could just get it done. I was in real estate. Same thing in this.
He gets it done. So when he said that, he said, you know, when you sign these
executive orders, a lot of them don't get done.
And they'd be the most important ones. Und er würde das executive order und
er würde die Leute gehen zu whatever agency es war.
Wenn Sie es tun? Get es getan.
Und ein paar Leute, dass sie vielleicht nicht wollen, all of a sudden er ist
es. Er hat sich nicht. Er hat sich nicht.
A lot of diese executive orders müssen in den Lauter. Sie brauchen die Republican
Congress zu follow. A lot of them will.
In the meantime, wir haben vier Jahre. Die beauty ist, wir haben vier Jahre.
Das ist das, was ich liebe Ja.
Man hat ja noch vier Jahre und der Kongress wird schon Spuren irgendwie und so.
Midterm, ne, keine Bedrohung, also das wird irgendwie ausgeblendet.
Das ist schon alles. Wir gucken mal zwei Clips von Musk auf der Bühne nach seinem Chainsaw-Ding.
Also die Chainsaw steht dann schon vor ihm, präsentiert sozusagen das Anliegen.
Er füllt nur noch so ein paar Worte auf.
Ich weiß nicht, wir reden jetzt viel über Bürokratie und jetzt heißt es immer
USAID. Wer braucht das schon?
Ministerium für Bildung, können das nicht die Staaten selber machen?
Wer braucht das? Nur hier geht es ja auch um die Steuerbehörde.
So, as we're finding savings, that's going to translate directly to reductions in tax. Yeah.
I mean, I think they fired 6,000 people at the IRS today. Yeah.
And I think Lutnick said last night that they're talking about shutting down the IRS.
And... Ich denke, es ist fair.
Ich denke, es ist fair. Ich denke, das ist, ich meine, die Amt von Möden wir
senden Washington, fünf oder sechs Trillion a Jahr, das ist so ein ungodlich Amt von Möden.
Ich meine, was Sie sagen, ein Trillion Sekunden ist, wie 30 Jahre oder so.
Ich meine, das ist wie viel wir senden, und sie sehen, dass sie nicht genug haben.
Es muss ein viel Sie können. Nein, absolut. Was die meisten surpriseen,
was die meisten surpriseen, was die man erlebt, wenn man in D.C.? Und ich sage,
Ja.
Ich habe immer darauf hingewiesen, das Land ist groß.
Er sitzt da mit einer schwarzen Sonnenbrille.
Er hat nicht einmal seine Augen gezeigt, weil er weiß, was da wieder alles, wo es sich ging.
Steuerbehörde abschaffen. Jetzt kann man ja so überlegen, okay,
Steuerbehörde, das heißt, Input, Outcome, Staatsfinanzierung und so weiter.
Wir hören nur in so eine Verschwörungstheorie rein, also Verschwörungstheorie
im Sinne von, hat jemand gehört?
Also, Jay-Z Dvorak hat einen jungen Sohn, der arbeitet im Tech-Bereich,
da redet man über solche Sachen.
Hier so eine Vermutung, wenn es stimmt, wird es dieses Jahr sich noch zeigen.
So they have, he believes the following is going to, this is a scenario,
this is a predictive scenario that I liked.
They're going to try to fix systems, including the IRS filing system,
which apparently stopped working.
And since it's an old COBOL system, you know, basically, they can't,
they have to, they're just, he pointed out that AI COBOL, which is all these
new kids are doing. They use AI to do coding.
It doesn't code COBOL because there's not enough material to feed the language
model. To slurp in, right.
So AI can't do COBOL. And so they're going to have to abandon COBOL and go to these new systems.
He predicts it's going to not work right away.
There's going to be such a big screw-up that the IRS is going to go as follows.
You don't have to file.
That's all right, because President Trump's going to take away income tax anyway.
It's all good. It'll be fine. This may be part of that scheme. It's fine.
The way it goes is like this. You don't have to file right away.
You can file later. The April 15th thinks they're going to give him some slack on this.
But what it really means is you're not going to get your refunds. Yeah, there's that.
Yep, there's that. Und so die Regierung wird sich auf diese Reifung für Gott
weiß wie lange. Das ist die Rumor Mill, JC's hearing?
Ja, die Rumor Mill ist, ihr nicht mehr zu bekommen, diese Reifung zu bekommen.
So,
also wird es irgendwann einen Zeitpunkt geben, wo es heißt, dieses Jahr keine
Steuererklärung abgeben, wir können sie gerade nicht verarbeiten.
Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen.
Man kann vieles nicht vorstellen.
Es ist ja so, dass Elon Musk auch nicht alle Befugnisse hat.
Also das ist ja das eine, ob der
auf so einer Bühne mit der Kettensäge dem Moderator dann noch was erzählt.
Oder ob nicht da doch auch Republikaner sind, die sagen mit den Steuern,
das ist folgendermaßen.
Elon Musk hat da nichts mit zu tun. Also was der ja jetzt gerade wegstreicht,
sind ja Ausgaben, Posten.
Das heißt in Form von Personal, in Form von Zeitschriften, Abos und eben so Entwicklungshilfen.
Das ist alles sehr schlimm, aber momentan heißt das ja einfach,
ich streiche Budgets, ich kappe einfach irgendwelche Grundflüsse.
Und da wird sich auch zeigen, wie lange man das aufrechterhalten kann,
weil natürlich auch Leuten, die da einfach rausgeworfen werden,
vielleicht irgendeine Entschädigung und so weiter zusteht.
Das sind ja alles Prozesse, die erst in Gang kommen. Und also wenn ich jetzt
nicht davon ausgehe, dass der Staat einfach in so einen Ausnahmezustand verwandelt
wird und so faschistoid angelegt wird, wo das einfach gar kein Anrecht mehr gibt.
Aber dann sind wir wirklich in der Lage, wo man dann sagt, sie hatten vielleicht
mal irgendwelche Rentenansprüche, ab morgen nicht mehr.
Das wäre natürlich dann ein Schritt, der ja dazu führt, dass nicht nur in Podcasts
sich Leute Sorgen machen, sondern das ist ja auch etwas, wovor man Angst haben muss als Regierung,
dass dann plötzlich sich bürgerkriegsähnliche Zustände entwickeln und zwar die
sich gegen diese Regierung entwickeln.
Nur Musk ist ja, du sagst jetzt, der hat ja da nicht diese Zugänge.
Ich sage, der ist ja gar nicht die Regierung.
Musks private Anliegen müssen gar nichts mit Trumps zu tun haben.
Musk verarscht uns, der kann genauso gut auch Trump verarschen.
Und die Szenerien, die du jetzt beschreibst, also da wird es ja wohl noch jemanden
geben und so weiter, dieses Steuersystem, dieses Zahlungssystem wird irgendwie
von 16 Leuten, also 16 Leute haben Befugnisse, da Änderungen vorzunehmen.
Musk ist dahin und hat gesagt, ich möchte der 17. sein. Dann haben die gesagt, nee, das ist nicht.
Dann hat er gesagt, ich feuere dich. Und dann wurde der gefeuert.
Also wir sind jetzt schon an diesem konkreten nuklearen Punkt angekommen,
wo einfach Leute sagen, nee, ich bin einer von 16, ich kann dich hier nicht
reinlassen und dann muss er trotzdem.
Also was mich eben da so ein bisschen skeptisch macht, wenn es um diese ganz
großen Horrorvisionen geht, ist, dass ja auch alle, sowohl Trump mit seinen
Unternehmen als auch die Leute, die dann in seinem Umkreis sind,
alle ganz gut mit der amerikanischen Wirtschaft und ihrem System,
auch dem bürokratischen, fahren.
Die mögen sich über Dinge aufregen.
Aber es ist ja nicht so, dass die eigentlich am Start zugrunde gegangen sind
und jetzt sich nochmal irgendwie ein bisschen Oberwasser verschaffen.
Das heißt, wir sind eigentlich da an einem Punkt, wo man sagen kann,
die sägen an ihrem eigenen Ast. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass das sich dadurch
auch wieder etwas einhegen wird, aber dass das sehr schmutzig bleibt.
Eine Angst vor Dummheiten.
Und dass da auch sehr viel, ja, aber eine ökonomische Raffinesse haben diese
Leute ja meistens schon, sonst wären sie ja nicht dahin gekommen.
Ja, aber die ist partikular und unternehmerisch. Und die sind ja auf völlig fremden Gebieten.
Ja, aber auch wenn du unternehmerisch tätig bist, musst du ja eine gewisse Grundstruktur haben.
Ja.
Und diese ganz zu zerschlagen ist wenig hilfreich. Also gerade wenn man ja sieht,
also es gibt ja auch eben diese Strömung, die von Alex Karp und anderen vertreten
wird und die finden wir auch bei jemandem wie Peter Thiel, der jetzt gerade
nicht im Vordergrund steht.
Ja, im Vordergrund steht er nie.
Aber er ist irgendwie so ein bisschen da oder gar nicht da, man weiß es nicht.
Aber von denen gibt es ja schon diese Idee des investierenden Staates, der...
Große Mittel in Bewegung setzt, um ein nationales Wir zu formen,
das dann auch so aussieht, dass man aufrüstet noch und nöcher und all das.
Und das geht dann noch in Kombination jetzt mit den neuen Startups, die entstehen.
Wir sehen das ja auch in Europa, wenn überall plötzlich Werbung für Drohnenunternehmen,
für Startups gemacht wird.
So und diese Seite des Business gibt es ja auch.
Und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass man das alles über Bord wirft und völlig ignoriert.
Also Trump ist ja eben kein Ideologe in dem Sinne, dass er mit einem Playbook
da reingeht und das durchzieht,
sondern wenn er sich überreden lässt und das kann schon bald der Zeitpunkt gekommen
sein, oder bei den Chips können wir es ja schon sehen,
also da ist er ja sehr freigebig und findet Subventionen und all das gut,
er ist ja für eine Reindustrialisierung der USA,
dann glaube ich, wird man dort auch andere Wege wieder finden,
die weggehen von diesem libertären Ansatz, den Elon Musk jetzt gerade so groß vertritt.
Also nachdem die Notfall-Podcasts hier zum Thema Chatgruppe und so veröffentlicht
waren, wurde Trump öffentlich gefragt, was sagen Sie denn dazu als Präsident?
Wovon? Habe ich noch nie gehört. Also wir können auch davon ausgehen,
dass Trump gar keine Ahnung hat davon, was da läuft.
Zentrale Idee Elon Musks hier im Hard Fork Podcast, aber mit einem Politikredakteur
aus der New York Times besprochen, um es nur abzubinden, diese große Idee,
man könnte diese Bürokratie irgendwie ersetzen durch Technologie.
Thomas Shedd, who's a former Tesla engineer, he's been tapped to lead a technology
team at the General Services Administration.
He told some staff members they hope to put all federal contracts into a centralized
system so they could be analyzed by artificial intelligence.
And I know from my own reporting that Elon Musk privately for months now has
been talking about this idea of using artificial intelligence to identify waste
within the federal government.
And, you know, it doesn't seem like a crazy idea to me.
Conceptually, I mean, use whatever tools you can to figure out where the wasteful
spending is. Problem is, I don't have,
Ja.
Grundsätzlich finde ich das nämlich auch.
Ich habe nichts gegen so einen Staatsumbau, wenn er demokratisch organisiert
ist und planvoll abläuft.
Und dazu gibt es Vorschläge in Deutschland von einer Initiative namens Initiative
für einen handlungsfähigen Staat. Darüber dieser Podcast.
Und im November, diese Geschichte ist ganz interessant, im Ende Oktober hat
Steinmeier eingeladen.
Er hat gesagt, ich nehme die Schörherrschaft an. Vier Stiftungen sind da irgendwie dabei.
Wir veranstalten bei mir eine Auftaktveranstaltung. Ende Oktober da eingeladen.
Der Termin fand dann irgendwann Mitte November statt.
Zur Einladung konnte man auch denken, es ist der letzte Versuch,
den wir haben. Noch mal durchschnaufen.
Kamala Harris wird gewählt. Die Ampel schlägt sich durch.
Und schon zwei Wochen später hieß es, Trump wird regieren. Es gibt keine Ampel mehr.
Und den eigentlich angedachten für Oktoberbericht mussten sie jetzt auf März
vorziehen, weil ja jetzt gerade Koalitionsverhandlungen sind,
haben dann auch dort Vorstellungen gehabt.
Also Thomas de Maizière, Andreas Voskuhle, Julia Leickel und Peer Steinbrück
waren also auch mal in den Verhandlungsrunden, haben da mitgeredet.
Und wir nehmen uns nur mal einen Aspekt daraus oder zwei Aspekte,
nämlich zum einen der Handlungsdruck, der grundsätzlich entsteht,
das jetzt mal zu machen und dann eine ganz spezifische,
sehr Doge-artige Idee, die Julia Lekke in der Pressekonferenz da vorgestellt hat.
Aber wir lassen mal Voskule den handlungsleitenden Druck hier nochmal darstellen.
Wenn die Bürgerinnen und Bürger ihren Staat als nicht handlungsfähig erleben,
und das tun sie im Augenblick in vielen Bereichen, dann wenden sie sich von
der Politik ab, verlieren Vertrauen in die politischen Institutionen und verletzen.
Entscheiden sich für Personen, die vielleicht eher an dem Rand des politischen Spektrums tätig sind.
Wenn sie den Staat als handlungsfähig erleben, dann sind sie bereit,
sich selbst zu engagieren und das Vertrauen in den Staat steigt.
Also Government Efficiency ist nötig, neu.
Entweder machen es die ein oder wir. Also machen die den Vorschlag,
wir machen es und hier kommt ein großer Paradigmenwechsel.
Erster wichtiger Punkt, wir müssen weg von einer Misstrauenskultur hin zu einer
Vertrauenskultur, was das Verhältnis zwischen Bürger und Staat angeht.
Ja und das finde ich ganz interessant, weil in Amerika ist ja die Ansage,
ich bin ein guter Herrscher, vertraut mir.
Und in Deutschland ist jetzt die Ansage hier, die Bürger meinen es nicht böse
mit uns, lieber Staat, vertraue den Bürgern und so weiter.
Jeder, der BAföG empfängt, will betrügen.
Ja, so. Und das finde ich schon mal gut. Also hier, das ist sehr unterstützenswürdig.
Zweitens, Digitalisierung.
Dann müssen wir den Staat sehr viel schneller digitalisieren.
Digitalisierung ist die Voraussetzung für alles.
Für Bürgernähe, für Bürokratieabbau, für Zukunftsfähigkeit und für wirtschaftliche Dynamik.
So, also wie bei Trump steht Vertrauen zentral,
wie bei Trump steht Digitalisierung zentral und bei Digitalisierung ist sogar
die Vorzeichen gleich mit Trump, also da wird einfach nur die Art und Weise
der Methode der Umsetzung ist halt anders und jetzt kommt Julia Jäckel.
Mit einer Idee, wir diskutieren das damit kühl auch ein bisschen ausführlicher,
weil er das auch anders gelesen hat. Ich habe den Originaltext nochmal vorgelesen.
Wir hören jetzt mal sie, wie sie das vorschlägt.
Ich finde, das geht ganz schön krass weit.
Wenn das überhaupt so im Raume steht, muss das viel mehr diskutiert werden als jetzt gerade.
Denn der Vorschlag ist auch hier Digitalisierung und Personal.
Jetzt in einem, finde ich, paradoxen Verhältnis neu zu denken.
Ich habe es ja vorhin schon kritisiert in Amerika, dass Musk überhaupt auf die
Idee kommt zu sagen, wir schaffen Bürokratie, aber ohne Bürokraten,
sondern mit Algorithmen. ist einfach, also irgendwas passt da nicht.
Wir haben keine historische Erfahrung dafür, keine Heuristik sowas zu beobachten.
Die Konzepte laufen alle fehl und man kann es im Grunde nur trial and error
am laufenden Prinzip machen mit der Erwartung oder eben nicht,
dass dieses Jahr da keine Steuerzahlen verarbeitet werden können.
Also so weit ist jetzt der Denkraum angekommen.
Also es soll ein neues Ministerium für Digitalisierung und Verwaltung geben.
Wir können es kurzfassen, die Digitalisierung müssen wir viel entschiedener
angehen, als wir es bisher getan haben.
Wir empfehlen deshalb die Schaffung eines Ministeriums für Digitales und Verwaltung.
Denn beides, eine moderne und umsetzungsstarke Verwaltung und ein digitaler
Staat, gehören, wie schon Herr Voskule angedeutet hat, untrennbar miteinander zusammen.
Je nachdem, wie man den Grundbegriff Staat, den es nicht gibt,
jetzt umdeutet, Staat ist Verwaltung.
Also wenn wir vom Staat reden, meinen wir nicht die Staatsgrenze,
das Staatsvolk, die Staatssprache, sondern wir reden im Grunde von der Verwaltung, die Bürokratie.
Das ist jetzt ein Ministerium für Digitalisierung und Verwaltung.
Für Digitalisierung und die Bürokratie selbst.
Ja eben. Also alle Ministerien produzieren Bürokratie oder produzieren Auflagen, die Bürokratie meinen.
Und die sollen dann darüber sein. Aber was soll das dann ergeben?
Wir sind hier wieder in so Paradoxen, wir kriegen es nicht ganz aufgelöst.
Wie ist das gemeint und so. Hier kommt noch dazu, das Ministerium für Digitalisierung,
an sich schon mal ein Novum, kriegt nochmal eine Digitalagentur parallel gesetzt,
wo zentral Software hergestellt werden soll für den Staat, was sich aber in
Form einer GmbH wiederum den demokratischen Eingriffsmöglichkeiten so ein bisschen entzieht.
Da ist dann einfach ein Geschäftsführer, der die Geschäfte führt.
Ungestört von, ach so, Sie sind Staatsrekretär, sind das Parlament angebunden,
haben hier Rechtschaftspflichten und so weiter und so fort. Also es ist die Konstruktion ist...
Wie bei der Bahn oder was soll das sein? Ja, so ist es. So eine ähnliche Konstruktion.
Die Bahn fährt unabhängig davon, wie jetzt gerade der Bundestag die Stimmung ist oder so.
Und es soll ein kleines, schlagkräftiges Ministerium sein.
Dieses Ministerium ist Treiber und Umsetzer der Digitalisierung und einer Staatsreform.
Es ist ein schlankes Ministerium, aber mit einer großen Kompetenz.
Ja, es muss ja mit der Kompetenz ausgestattet sein, allen anderen Ministerien zu sagen, was los ist.
Also entweder ist es eine gute Idee oder werden einfach nur die sich gut Anhörenden
schlagkräftig, schlank, zugriffsberechtigt.
Einfach noch ein bisschen Bürokratie dazu mit sowas.
Aber das ist doch die Theorie zu dem, was wir bei Doge sehen.
100 Leute, nicht mehr. Die dürfen überall hin. Die dürfen alle feuern.
Ja, also das müsste ja so sein. Also wenn die jetzt am Ende dazu degradiert werden,
dass die ein paar digitale Vorschläge machen können und mal im Ministerium vorbeischauen,
ob schon alles weit gekommen ist oder noch ein bisschen braucht,
dann ist das wieder eine reine Quatschveranstaltung.
Genau, und dazu hören wir uns jetzt mal diesen dritten Clip an.
Weil hier geht es jetzt ans Eingemachte.
Das ist auch der, den wir da mit Kühl so ein bisschen soziologisch auseinandernehmen.
Das ist wirklich schräg, aber es geht wirklich weit.
Diejenigen, die diese Kultur heute schon verkörpern, müssen gestärkt werden.
Die, die es vielleicht noch nicht so können, müssen angeleitet werden.
Und neue von draußen mit Digitalkompetenz, mit Managementkompetenz,
denen muss man überhaupt erst mal Lust machen, beim Staat mitzutun,
mitzuarbeiten. Wir brauchen also innen und außen.
Das Ministerium für Digitales und Verwaltung treibt also diese Entwicklung.
Somit ist es auch für das Dienstrecht und dessen Erfrischung zuständig.
Quer wechseln oder Seiteneinsteigern wird das in Wahrheit heute fast unmöglich
gemacht. Das muss sich irgendwie ändern.
Das Ministerium erhält dann auch die umfassende Zuständigkeit für Personal.
Und für die ressortübergreifende Personalplanung.
Bei Erfrischung dachte ich erst, die reichen Cocktails, aber es ist was anderes.
Also wenn das Dienstrecht erfrischt wird, das Dienstrecht ist nochmal die Frage,
kannst du hier Karriere machen, ist der Staat für dich ein attraktiver Arbeitgeber, was droht dir hier?
Und du weißt, ein Minister selbst will mich hier haben,
aber der muss erst nochmal beim Department of Government Efficiency anfragen,
ob das denn mit deren Personalplanung, die nämlich jetzt übergreifend für alle
Häuser gemacht wird, in Einklang zu bringen ist.
Oder ob die einfach sagen, nee, jetzt Einstellungsstopp, wir haben hier eine Softwarelösung.
Die Digitalagentur liefert nächste Woche, wir gucken uns das dann mal an und
dann entscheiden wir. Dann haben wir es hier wirklich mit tiefschürfenden Eingriffen
zu tun, die in Sachen, wie das da in Amerika abläuft, jetzt konzeptionell echt nicht nachstehen.
In dem Text steht sogar drin, nicht nur bauen wir die Kapazität und Kompetenz
für Personal und Personalplanung und Dienstrecht auf, sondern die anderen Häuser
bauen das ab, ihre Personalverantwortung für ihre eigenen Häuser.
Aber woher weiß denn dieses Ministerium, was in den anderen Ministerien gebraucht
wird, beziehungsweise wer der wirklich qualifizierte Mensch dafür ist?
Das ist die eine Frage und die andere Frage ist auch, wenn das Gesundheitsministerium
von der SPD besetzt ist und der Digitalminister kommt von der CDU,
darf der dann über den Parteichef der SPD hinweg da rein regieren und sagen und so weiter.
Gebt euch jetzt mit dem anderen zufrieden.
Ja, es sind ganz krasse, krasse Fragen, die hier so als Idee in den Raum gestellt
werden, aber die wirklich diskutiert werden müssen.
Und die werden aber gerade nicht diskutiert, sondern in heimeliger Runde.
Wir haben das da mal so vorgestellt.
Ich verstehe es auch ehrlich gesagt nur so halb. Also es setzt ja voraus,
dass dieses Ministerium aufgrund der Deklaration offenbar und aufgrund der Leute,
die man dann dort einbringen will, einfach über alles besser Bescheid weiß als
die anderen Ministerien.
Und da bin ich skeptisch. Also das ist ja so ein Taskforce-Gedanke,
der aber eigentlich immer nur funktioniert, wenn man mit Ellenbogen durchgeht
und klare Fakten schafft.
Und dann geht es aber gar nicht darum, ob es aus einer Expertise heraus ist,
sondern mehr so, wir haben mal reinen Tisch gemacht, sind jetzt 30 Leute weniger
oder 50 Gesetze gestrichen.
Und dann würde man ja auch solche Rechtfertigungen finden oder beziehungsweise
muss ja auch dieses Ministerium sich wieder legitimieren,
würde also irgendwelche Planziele haben, so und so viele Gesetzesbürokratische
Hürden müssen gespricht werden, damit dies und das.
Also es klingt, ja, wie schätzen wir das jetzt ein?
Sagst du jetzt, da ist ein bisschen Hoffnung drin?
Oder würdest du sagen, nee, das ist eine verklausulierte Anpassung an das,
was wir mit Doge erleben?
Meine Pointe sieht wie folgt aus. In Amerika gibt es gerade die Idee,
wir machen das wieder mit dem König, aber es ist ein guter König.
Und ich sage, nee, die Königsidee selber ist ein bisschen fishy.
In Deutschland gibt es jetzt die Idee, wir machen das wie Doge, aber ein gutes Doge.
Und ich denke mir, nee, ist nicht die richtige Idee. Und ich bin echt ein großer
Verfechter von Bürokratieabbau.
Ja.
Von vor allem elektronischem Ersatz. Also ich bin ja nun wirklich der Verfechter
von machen wir es mit Technik und so.
Das ist für dich die größte Zumutung, wenn du einen Brief zur Post bringen musst. Absolut.
Aber das halte ich für undurchdacht.
Praktisch nicht umsetzbar. Und es geht mit dem Abbau von erheblich also sehr
wichtigen bisherigen Prinzipien einher.
Ja, allein schon, dass wir immer in Deutschland eine Koalition haben.
Werden die regiert, macht das schon fast undenkbar, weil es genau das bedeutet,
dass plötzlich CDU-Leute reinregieren bei SPD-Ministerien und dann sagen die, Moment mal.
Und das kriegst du auch nicht durch Expertokraten-Overloads oder so.
Ne, es ist genau, das finde ich auch so interessant, dass man also nochmal jetzt
so einen technokratischen Versuch, es ist ja wirklich ein technokratischer Versuch,
dass man sagt, wir haben so eine Effizienztruppe,
die am liebsten hätte man vermutlich noch gesagt ideologiefrei,
einfach nur Prozesse optimiert und die kommen von außen.
Dass aber da die ganze Zeit das Politische mit drin ist, zwar das Personalpolitische
und überhaupt das Politische, das in Entscheidungen auch bürokratischer Natur liegt,
dass das so rausgenommen wird oder dass
man glaubt, man könne jetzt da mal ideologiefrei oder so draufklicken.
Ist illusionär.
Weshalb ich jetzt eine konstruktive Wende einleute? Also ich mache jetzt einen
echten Vorschlag, ganz ernst gemeint.
Aber ich darf sagen, Alena Büchs feiert das sehr. Sie ist da auch mit Bertelsmann mit drin.
Die wird das super finden. Ja genau, da sind ja 50 Leute. Wir hatten die Freude,
55 anzufragen und 52 haben am ersten Tag zugesagt.
Also ist ja auch, wir bauen jetzt Bürokratie ab, indem wir einen Arbeitskreis aufbauen.
Finde ich kritisch. Wenn so viele zusagen, dann müsste man sich eher fragen.
Ob man ganz schön viele Leute ganz schön was haben. Und das ist nämlich meine
Pointe. Ich habe ja angefangen mit...
Man könnte auch sagen, die guten Leute hatten keine Zeit.
Oder so, genau. Drei gute haben keine Zeit und die anderen machen es jetzt.
Ich habe ja angefangen mit der Hängematte. Und der Umdeutung des Sozialstaats,
der Bürokratie als Hängematte, dass nicht die Bürgergeldempfänger da ihre 500
Euro abgreifen, vielleicht sogar illegalerweise, weil sie eigentlich noch irgendwo
irgendwas gemacht haben und nur 300 Euro ihnen zustünde.
Sondern die soziale Hängematte ist für Milliardäre da.
Nur weil der Staat eine soziale Hängematte aufgezogen hat, die Arbeiterschaft
befriedet, den Gewerkschaften so ein bisschen Spielraum lässt,
ist es überhaupt möglich, eine Milliarde zu sagen, das ist meine.
Und dann stehen Gerichte da und sagen, ja, das stimmt, das ist deine.
Dafür braucht man sehr viel Staat, sehr viel Bürokratie und das Ganze läuft
für mich unter dem Hashtag Hängematte. Hängematte für Milliardäre.
Und jetzt Per Steinbrück ist ja auch mit in diesem vierköpfigen Führungsteam.
Er unterstreicht hier nochmal die Eile.
Wenn das in der nächsten Legislaturperiode nicht gelingt und die Erosion des
Vertrauens in die staatliche Handlungs- und Funktionsfähigkeit abnimmt,
in die staatliche oder die politische Lösungskompetenz,
dann sind wir der Überzeugung, dass die nächsten Bundestagswahlen zu einer Nagelprobe
für unsere Demokratie und unser Verständnis einer funktionierenden parlamentarischen
Gesellschaft oder Demokratie werden können.
Insofern erheben wir nicht den Anspruch, alles besser zu wissen.
Wir kommen auch zu dem Ergebnis, dass vieles sich technisch im Einzelnen anhört.
Aber was wir vorschlagen in seiner konzeptionellen Zusammenfassung,
ist nichts weniger als in der Tat eine tiefgreifende Veränderung dieses Maschinenraums.
So, eine tiefgreifende Veränderung dieses Maschinenraums innerhalb von einer
Legislaturperiode, bevor die AfD größte Fraktion im Bundestag wird.
Sein Vorschlag, ich fühle das natürlich nur als unter anderem,
aber ich sage jetzt, das ist sein Vorschlag.
Und er steht für mich auch konträr zu vielen anderen, die da sowohl in Amerika
als auch hier von Jekyll und überhaupt genannt wurden. Sein Vorschlag lautet, ist ganz kurz.
Sie wollen in die Rechtsstaatlichkeit vertrauen und in die Durchsetzungsfähigkeit
des Staates, Recht durchzusetzen.
Weshalb wir viele Vorschläge machen mit Blick auf die Bekämpfung von Steuerhinterziehung,
Steuerbetrug, Sozialbetrug, Geldwäsche und auch Schwarzarbeit.
Weil die Menschen den Anspruch erheben, dass der Staat seine Regeln durchsetzt
und insbesondere im Bereich der Wirtschaftskriminalität sehr viel ehrgeiziger,
sehr viel drängender vorgeht.
Insbesondere auch mit Blick darauf, dass man alleine über die Bekämpfung von
Steuerhinterziehung, Steuerbetrug Milliarden, Mehreinnahmen erzielen kann für die Haushalte.
So, Stefan Kühl hat den Strafen den Staat vorgeschlagen. Ich mache mir das als
Vorschlag zu eigen und sage, ich plädiere dafür.
Denn angenommen, wir nehmen jetzt mal alle Regulierungen raus,
die für einige wenige Märkte schließen.
Konkurrenz ist gar nicht möglich, weil die ganzen Vorgaben, die kann wirklich
nur der Marktführer einhalten.
Plötzlich so, ja, Microsoft ist hier Industriestandard.
Wenn du irgendwas machen willst, alles auf der Azure Cloud und so.
Das könnte man ja auch mal lockern.
Diese ganzen Regeln, die das festlegen, dass man da nur Microsoft benutzen darf,
die müssen ja gar nicht sein.
Wir haben ja auch ein paar Software-Booten, die mal in der Schule Farbe,
wo ein Schüler mit einem Stift malt, das muss ja jetzt nicht alles patentmäßig
auf Microsoft-Seite laufen.
Oder beim Thema Verkehr.
Ja, du darfst niemanden auf der Autobahn totfahren, Aber das heißt doch noch
lange nicht, dass es nur die Post hinkriegt, mal ein öffentlich zugelassenes
Fahrzeug herzustellen, in Eigenregie, das Pakete transportiert,
mit 30 kmh von Adresse zu Adresse fährt.
Wo sind eigentlich die ganzen anderen Anbieter, die auch gute Ideen haben?
Ah ja, die können nicht, weil das Regelwerk ist nun mal darauf ausgelegt,
dass man eine 5000-Mann-Justitiareinrichtung bei VW braucht,
um ein Modell, das mit 30 kmh durch den Stadtverkehr fährt,
entsprechend ertüchtigen. lauter solche Sachen.
Also ich bin sehr dafür, dass wir diesen Weg hier gehen und sagen,
wir lassen das mal mit der Bürokratie und nehmen nur die Sachen raus,
die wir nach ernsthafter Prüfung und zwar nicht, ich habe da eine bessere Idee,
sondern es ist so, wie wir es da aufgezeigt haben.
Also dass wir so eine Forensik unserer Bürokratie machen unter der Maßgabe,
was sind hier Marktschließungsmechanismen, was sind Monopolabsicherungsmechanismen,
wo steht der Staat vielleicht durch ein Recht auf oder Verbot von Streiks oder so, ja.
Dingen im Wege. Wo werden Patente zugewilligt,
die gar nicht gerechtfertigt sind, weil wie man eine Schraube in ein Gewinde
dreht, dafür braucht man kein Patent, das einen davon abhält,
dass andere jetzt plötzlich auch auf so eine Idee kommt, dass man ja eine Schraube
durch Drehbewegung in eine und so weiter.
Okay, aber das sind ja jetzt Sachen, die in die Eigentumsordnung hineingehen würden.
Also wenn du jetzt Patente angreifst, also ich habe nichts dagegen,
ich will nur darauf hinweisen,
dass das ein Problem ist, auch gerade, und da sehe ich dann auch selbst ein
Problem, mit einer internationalen Konkurrenz.
Also wenn du jetzt sagst, also du kannst ja Microsoft sowieso jetzt nicht das Patent abnehmen.
Also da musst du sagen, wir verzichten jetzt auf Microsoft in Deutschland an Schulen oder so etwas.
Also das wirst du nicht einfach übergraben können. Und bei den anderen,
wenn du jetzt den deutschen Unternehmen sagst, naja, dein Patent,
ob du die Schraube so oder so reindrehst, wir machen es jetzt alle so,
dann mindest du ja deren Unternehmen Unternehmenswert, bedeutet also,
dass die im internationalen Konkurrenzkampf eher schlechter dastehen.
Also da sehe ich ein Problem.
Gleichzeitig aber innovativer, Innovation getrieben werden. Also die deutsche
Autoindustrie wurde nicht geschützt dadurch, dass irgendwelche Marktschließungsmechanismen
allen dem ganzen Markt die Innovation austragen.
Lange Zeit schon, dann hat man gewisse neue Entwicklungen mit der E-Mobilität.
Dann habe ich einen Einwand bei dieser Sache, dass du davon ausgehst,
dass wenn weniger Monopolbildung stattfindet, dass dann weniger Bürokratie ist
oder beziehungsweise, also,
Monopol kann ja durchaus dafür sorgen, dass man weniger Bürokratie hat.
Ja, aber ich will ja mehr Marktgeschehen.
Ja, aber mehr Marktgeschehen kann auch mehr Bürokratie bedeuten.
Also wenn du mehr Akteure hast und gerade dein Postbeispiel,
also die Post ist ja deshalb auch schlecht geworden, weil man das Ganze geöffnet
hat, weil es jetzt mehrere Anbieter gibt und weil man,
nicht mehr wie früher sich darauf verlassen konnte, dass man jeden Tag auch
Post bekommt in seinem Briefkasten, dass da der Briefträger ist.
Okay, aber du weißt, wir leben ja in einem Land, in dem sehr viele Leute noch
nicht digitalisiert sind. Das ist ein großer Prozess.
Guck mal, zum Beispiel dieses, wenn du in Deutschland Digitalisierung vorantreiben
willst, bist du am besten so ein Netzeanbieter, der auch Funkwellen losschickt.
Was hatten wir in Deutschland für einen Stress mit dieser Vergabe von Lizenzen
Funkwellen zu bespielen?
Dieser ganze Blödsinn. Toll-Collect. Die Anforderung für das Einsammeln von
Gebührengeldern war so hoch,
so hoch, dass es nur die Telekom schaffte als größtes Technologieunternehmen
Deutschlands und auch nur in
Zusammenarbeitung noch mit anderen Dienstleistern. Das ist einfach absurd.
Für einen Eintrittsschein für die Autobahn. Lauter solche Sachen.
Ich stimme dir an allem zu. Ich weiß nur jetzt wirklich keine Lösung in dem
Sinne, aber ich bin ja auch nicht in der Kommission glücklicherweise,
aber wo du das jetzt gerade ansprichst, jetzt haben wir ja anfangs über die
Aufrüstung gesprochen, über diese hunderte Milliarden,
die da jetzt auf den Weg gebracht werden und dann nochmal auf europäischer Ebene zusätzlich 500,
800 Milliarden, man weiß es noch nicht genau.
Was glaubst du, was das wunderbare, große, bürokratische Monster schaffen wird?
Ja, ja, deswegen ja. Da nämlich sehen jetzt die Startups ihre Chance,
das wird jetzt alles der digital-militärisch-industrielle Komplex werden,
bei dem man sich in zehn Jahren fragen wird, ja, aber wo ist denn das ganze Geld hin?
Und man wird dann nicht mehr nur die Schuld irgendwelchen Beamten vom Beschaffungsamt
geben können, sondern man wird dann selber sehen, dass sich Leute an dieser
Bürokratie reich gemacht haben.
Diese richtige Voraussicht ist absolut korrekt.
Aber es ändert ja trotzdem nicht am grundsätzlichen Handlungsdruck, der da ist.
Der ist da. Also man müsste es ja mal schaffen, sich die großen Problemfelder,
und das wäre ja zum Beispiel Wohnen und Bauen anzusehen und durchzugehen.
Warum dauert das drei bis sechs Monate, bis etwas gemacht werden darf?
Ich habe hier schon mal das Beispiel erzählt von einem vermögenden Mann,
der einen großen Park mit Wohnungen bauen wollte und der lauter an bürokratischen
Hürden scheitert es bis jetzt noch nicht gebaut hat.
Das heißt, da hätten jetzt im Prinzip schon jahrelang Menschen drin wohnen können,
noch ist kein Stein auf den anderen gestellt.
Und das ist ja nicht ein Einzelfall, den habe ich jetzt mal persönlich kennengelernt, zufällig kurz.
Aber diese Fälle kannst du ja zuhauf überall beobachten. und das ist natürlich
etwas, was uns in diese desolate Lage führt.
Ich will ein paar Themen nennen. Also bauen und wohnen auf jeden Fall.
Diese Vorschriften, es muss so ein Giebeldach sein und es muss auch 40% der
Baukosten verschlingen, auch wenn du dann nur 2% deiner Lebenszeit in diesem
Haus im Dachgeschoss verbringst, alles absurd. Das kann man alles vereinfachen.
Ja, da sind Bauordnungen, die wurden von Leuten in den 80er Jahren gemacht,
die sind jetzt schon alle tot und die Leute, die da jetzt sind,
führen einfach weiter aus und haben auch keinen Antrieb, sich mit irgendjemandem anzulegen.
Das sind ja alles Profite, die verbucht werden.
Naja, es sind nicht nur Profite, die verbucht werden, jetzt auch von der stadtplanerischen Seite.
Also da arbeiten eben auch Leute vielfach, die sagen, ich mache hier nicht irgendwas,
ich disruptiere hier immer nichts,
ich verwalte den Status quo, natürlich ist das völlig idiotisch,
dass jetzt alle diese Dächer bauen müssen, dass wir nur so niedrige Häuser haben,
ist auch eigentlich ein Problem.
Aber was stört es mich? Ich mache einfach weiter.
Ja, ich gucke mal, ob ich diesen einen Clip finde von Steinbrück.
Die steuerfinanzierten Sozialleistungen des Bundes umfassen inzwischen 171 verschiedene
Leistungen, für die fünf verschiedene Bundesministerien zuständig sind und denen
teilweise sehr unterschiedliche Begriffsdefinitionen zugrunde liegen.
So, bevor wir das weiterhören. Es geht hier nur darum, dass genug Essen auf dem Tisch ist.
Für Leute, die durch Arbeitskraft es alleine nicht schaffen. Nur darum geht es.
170 Maßnahmen.
Klassisches Beispiel, eine alleinerziehende Frau mit einem pflegebedürftigen
Vater hat Anspruch auf ungefähr zwölf Sozialleistungen,
denen vier verschiedene Einkommensbegriffe zugrunde liegen und sie muss sich
mit acht Bewilligungsstellen befassen.
Das heißt, wir diesen Sozialstaat als...
Ja, muss man gar nicht weiterhören, jeder versteht. Das ist absurd.
Was bedeutet, mein Buch beginnt ja mit dem Appell, schafft das Familienministerium ab?
Und zwar nicht, weil ich denke, wir brauchen kein Familienministerium,
sondern weil das eine ehrliche Einsicht in die Relevanz dieses Bereiches ist.
Das Familienministerium finanziert Arbeitgeber und Vermieter und der Rest von
diesen 13 Milliarden Budget ist nicht nennenswert.
Also dieser Kinderplan, den es da gibt, 400 Millionen oder so, spielt keine Rolle.
Familienpolitik braucht also kein Programm. Einfach pauschal,
ein Kind wurde geboren, herzlichen Glückwunsch, ab jetzt, 15 Jahre lang,
18 Jahre lang, 20 Jahre lang, diesen und jenen Betrag.
Falls das Kind mal stirbt, sagen sie uns Bescheid, ansonsten keine Bürokratie.
Ausländer kommen nach Deutschland, Arbeitsverbot, Residenzpflicht,
der ganze Kram, einfach abschaffen.
Wir brauchen halt Regelungen, wenn jetzt jemand kommt und sagt,
nee, die drücken ja dann den Lohn und so weiter, radikalen Mindestlohn.
Einfach für alle. Ja, mit einem radikalen Mindestlohn hast du alles.
Das war ja damals, dann hat Merkel sofort, als sie die Grenzen öffnete,
gesagt, ja, da müssen wir nochmal gucken, ob man da den Mindestlohn umgehen kann.
Sofort wieder Unternehmer, die sagten, ja toll, dann erkläre ich mich auch bereit
und dann werden tausend Ausnahmen produziert wieder.
Also mit gesundem Menschenverstand, sagen wir mal, unserer etwas progressiv-lastigen
Agenda, wie wir sie im Podcast pflegen, können wir hunderte Seiten Gesetzestexte
einfach pauschal, weg mit einer Regelung ersetzen.
Mindestlohn ersetzt zehntausende Seiten Papier.
Arbeitsverbote einfach nicht mehr aussprechen, erlöst sich quasi von fast allem.
Und ganz wichtig, was Steinbrück eben noch sagte, wenn wir in Deutschland statistische
Erhebungen haben, zum Thema 100 Milliarden Euro gehen am Start vorbei,
dann lohnt es sich auch mal 10 Milliarden zu investieren auf der Suche nach den dann 90 Milliarden.
Dass wir einfach gar nichts in diese Suche rein investieren,
sondern einfach alle machen lassen, wie sie wollen und sagen,
nee, Bürokratie betrifft nur die anderen.
Nein, also dann einfach gleiches Feld für alle.
Dann haben wir allein die Einnahmeseite so weit geregelt, dass wir müssen Bürokratie
abbauen, weil Leute unzufrieden sind.
Dann haben wir an der Unzufriedenheit schon ganz schön viel geregelt.
Und dann ist auch dieser Druck, nur noch eine Bundesregierung hat Zeit,
das zu machen, ist dann auch schon wieder genommen.
Also es gäbe hier schon Einflugschneisen, aber dafür braucht man einen ehrlichen
Umgang und keine Julia Jäckel, die uns sagt, eine Digitalagentur als GbH organisiert,
die aber dann eine Hoheit über ein Ministerium hat,
das Personalplanung für die ganze Bundesregierung macht ja, also bitte,
dann können wir auch Elon Musk fragen, ob er uns auch nochmal eine Kettensäge schenkt.
Ich habe mir nochmal Gedanken gemacht über die Wehrfähigkeit,
die Wehrpflicht und die Aufrüstung auch mit Blick auf ganz Europa und ich bin
einmal an die Ränder gegangen bzw.
Wollte ich mal wahrnehmen, was so darüber gedacht wird jenseits der Talkshows.
Und so hörte ich einen Podcast, der heißt Queerocracy.
Das ist also ein Podcast, der sich mit queeren Themen beschäftigt,
noch nie vorher von gehört.
Luz De Lier moderiert, zu Gast ist von der SPD, Falco Drossmann.
Er ist sowohl der queerpolitische Sprecher als auch ein verteidigungspolitischer
Sprecher und Experte, beziehungsweise da in einem Ausschuss, verbindet also beides,
man könnte sagen, woke und wehrhaft.
Wir hören mal da rein.
Wir haben da das Thema Queerness auch zum Schwerpunktthema gemacht.
Und ich bin nach Ungarn gefahren und habe mich dort mit der Community getroffen.
Ich bin nach Serbien gefahren und habe mich mit der Community getroffen.
Ich war in Äthiopien, ich war im Sudan, ich war in Armenien,
also so etwas, um mir das da anzuschauen.
Und ich muss sagen, gerade auch nach dem, was jetzt in den USA passiert,
es ist ein bisschen erschütternd, aber wir sind in einem Abwehrkampf.
Wir versuchen, das, was wir an Freiheit hier haben, das, was wir an Verwirklichung,
eigenen Identität hier erreicht haben, das versuchen wir zu verteidigen.
Und das versuchen wir massiv zu verteidigen gegen die AfD, das versuchen wir
aber auch zu verteidigen gegen die CDU und international ist der Druck seit
drei, vier Tagen auch nochmal massiv gestiegen.
Alles wird hier verteidigt, sowohl gegen innere Widerstände als auch gegen äußere.
Nun geht es darum, wie das dann eigentlich mit Verteidigung und Queer ist.
Denn interessanterweise kommt ja, sagen wir, aus dem Lager, dem queeraktivistischen
Lager, doch relativ wenig Kritik zum Beispiel an,
Aufrüstungsplänen oder auch von der Wehrpflicht oder so ist das ja tatsächlich
eher so gerade etwas, was man wahrnehmen kann, dass so das Woke und Wehrhafte
zusammen gedacht wird und in gewisser Weise spiegelt sich das auch in dem Podcast wieder.
Aber wir sind in der Verteidigungspolitik und du bist ja Gott sei Dank auch
verteidigungspolitischer Sprecher und manche Leute sagen, ah,
das ist ja komische Kombination.
Ich finde, das ist aber eigentlich eine ganz gute Kombination.
Mein Eindruck ist nämlich eigentlich, dass Kriege eigentlich selten militärisch
und meistens politisch gewonnen werden und auch oft politisch geführt werden
und dass wir uns momentan eigentlich auch in einer digitalen Auseinandersetzung,
geopolitischen digitalen Auseinandersetzung befinden.
Wir merken, hier geht so alles zusammen. Also alles ist ein bisschen Krieg und
alles ein bisschen Verteidigung und dann gibt es noch Hass im Netz.
Nun ja, Sie kommen dann auf das….
Was habe ich denn davon, wenn ich in dem Krieg stecke?
Und die Idee war jetzt zu sagen, dass Krieg erweitert als Begriff zu fassen
ist, also man führt die Kriege, die Verteidigungen für zum Beispiel queere Rechte
und dann würde ich sagen, ja man kann das alles als Krieg und alles als Verteidigung
und so weiter bezeichnen,
nur werden dann die Begriffe so durcheinander, dass sich daran doch was interessantes
zeigt, denn dein Einwand ist ja völlig korrekt.
Nämlich, dass wir ja etwas Interessantes erleben.
In Bezug auf den Krieg in der Ukraine erleben wir ja, wie tatsächlich,
das nennen wir es mal der Einfahrheit halber und es ist jetzt nicht despektierlich
gemeint, dass Wokellager ja auch sagte,
aufrüsten jetzt, Waffenlieferungen jetzt und jetzt auch beim Thema Wehrpflicht
sagt, vielleicht dann doch, aber nicht für alle oder sowas. Das werden wir auch
jetzt gleich noch hören.
Und das finde ich erstmal bemerkenswert, dass man also hier aus diesem progressiven
Lager heraus plötzlich so einen Mischmasch findet von,
ja wir verteidigen ja alle in irgendeiner Weise, der eine mit dem Twitter-Account,
der andere bei Instagram oder jemand mit der Waffe in der Hand,
zum Beispiel auch queere Rechte.
Und so werden ja auch dann Leute, wie zum Beispiel Ole, der sagte,
ich will da nicht dienen, werden ja sofort angegriffen, wie bist du etwa nicht
für Minderheiten, willst du nicht dich vor Minderheiten stellen und die schützen oder so.
Das ist ja so eine Sarah Bosetti würde so einen Ton anschlagen.
Ich habe früher diesen Ausschnitt gesehen, ne?
Also ich muss auch wirklich sagen, wenn man diese Sendung da mit Sarah Bosetti
guckt, ich habe das noch nie vorher gesehen, weil ich ja nicht verrückt bin.
Ich wusste auch nicht, dass das so eine, das ist so YouTube irgendwas.
Das ist ja, also sie nimmt ihn ja quasi in so ein inquisitorisches Verhör,
um ihn jetzt wirklich mal festzunageln, aber wann würdest du dann schießen,
wann würdest du dann wirklich mal abdrücken?
Und dann denke ich mir, du bist doch gehätschelt und gehätschelt vom öffentlich-rechtlichen
System, machst da diese Sendung für die Deinen,
wie kannst du dir eigentlich anmaßen, jetzt jemanden dazu zu bringen,
dass er jetzt endlich sagt, und dann schieße ich, ja du schießt doch auch für nichts.
Ja.
Das ist doch alles nur gekasper.
Ja, ich finde es auch gut, die Nachfrage
von Ole dann, weil sie nach der Solidarität fragt. Und Ole, mit wem?
Ja. Ja, ja, das wird ja immer so gesagt.
Mit den Milliardären oder was? Also schütze ich jetzt deren,
was habe ich mit diesen Hochhassern zu tun?
Wo sind wir denn jetzt gerade solidarisch? Vor allem auch hier nochmal sage
ich, wer solidarisch sein will. Kann das ja die ganze Zeit sein.
Wo bleibt denn da die Solidarität?
Ja, also ich brauche nicht den Krieg, um zu erfahren, dass ich in einer Gesellschaft lebe.
Ja, also ich würde ja auch sagen, ein Krieg ist ein zivilisatorischer Bruch.
Ja.
Und dass man ausgerechnet im Krieg dann plötzlich an Solidarität appelliert, ist auch...
Oder für einen Krieger.
Ja, aber das ist alles so paradox. Das ist so eine interessante Richtung jetzt. Wir hören mal weiter.
Also ich glaube, die Aussage ist ja sehr klar. Die SPD steht hinter dem Selbstbestimmungsgesetz
und den bisherigen querpolitischen Errungenschaften. Ein Zurück wird es mit uns nicht geben.
Also deutlicher kann man es eigentlich nicht machen an der Stelle.
Also Grundrechte, die man Menschen
auch aufgrund von Entscheidungsverfassungsgericht zurückgegeben hat.
So, also wo man einen verfassungsmäßigen Zustand hergestellt hat.
Den kann ich ja nicht zurücknehmen, finde ich.
Also ich könnte dem unter keinen Umständen dann zustimmen. Aber finden das deine
Kolleginnen und Genossinnen auch? Ja, das finde ich auch.
Die Frage ist ja jetzt, ob diese Große Koalition vielleicht doch wieder an queeren
Errungenschaften etwas wegnimmt.
Man kommt jetzt auf den Verteidigungsfall zu sprechen.
Okay, ein anderer Teil des Selbstbestimmungsgesetzes, den ich für suboptimal
halte und der mich aber immer wieder überrascht, ist das, was wir das Militärgeschlecht nennen.
Nämlich, dass im Spannungs- und Verteidigungsfall im Abstand von zwei Monaten,
meine Änderung quasi zurückgedreht wird in Bezug auf das Militär.
Dann hätte ich quasi ein Geschlecht in Bezug auf zivile Geschichten und ein Bezug auf das Militär.
Nein, das ist ein Missverständnis, ehrlicherweise.
Ah ja, dann erzähl mir, wie liest du das? Und es wird sich sowieso ändern,
wenn wir über Verteidigungsfähigkeit unseres Landes und unserer Werte und unserer
Freiheit sprechen, Das müssen wir nämlich auch nochmal tun.
Da sind wir sowieso dabei. Also im Augenblick ist es so, dass nur Männer eingezogen
werden dürfen. Richtig.
Das ist halt 50er Jahre Gesetzgebung. Und jetzt stelle man sich vor,
es kommt zu einem irgendwie gearteten
Zwischenfall und wir sind in einem Verteidigungsfall als Bundesrepublik.
Dann kann die Bundesrepublik alle Männer einziehen.
Ja, Moment.
So. Und was dann nicht geht, ist, wenn der Brief kommt, du kommst jetzt gefälligst
in einem Monat zur Bundeswehr, dass ich dann einen Termin beim Standesamt mache,
das Geschlecht ändere, weil Frauen nicht angezogen werden dürfen. Und zwei Monate vorher.
Ja, es gilt ja als Abverteidigungsfall. Vorher dürfen die gar nicht einberufen werden.
Naja doch, also das Gesetz sagt ja relativ klar und zwei Monate vor der Ausrufung
des Verteidigungsfalls.
So, Lusseli hat recht. Lusseli hat recht. Ja, wir gehen da jetzt auch mal nochmal
Grundsätze an. Lusseli hat recht.
Wir haben jetzt hier mit einem Experten für queere Politik und Verteidigungspolitik
zu tun. Und er erkennt, er versteht das eigene Gesetz nicht.
Also dann gucke man sich doch mal an, wie ein Verteidigungsfall ausgerufen würde.
Also wenn jetzt die Panzer über die Grenze rollen, dann warten wir doch nicht zwei Monate.
Das ist doch ein bisschen ein Verteidigungsfall. Sorry, nee,
das ist ein Missverständnis. Es geht darum... Nee, nee, ich glaube, wir verstehen uns miss.
Also die Panzer rollen über die Grenze und ihr ruft den Verteidigungsfall aus.
Meine Interpretation des Gesetzes ist, alle diejenigen, die von männlich weggeändert
haben, zwei Monate vorher, werden auch eingezogen. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Doch.
Lucili hat vollkommen recht, hat dann auch nachher im Faktencheck das nochmal gesagt.
Das Gesetz lautet, das ist Paragraf 9,
die rechtliche Zuordnung einer Person, also es geht um das Selbstbestimmungsgesetz,
zum männlichen Geschlecht bleibt,
soweit es den Dienst mit der Waffe auf Grundlage des Artikels 12a des Grundgesetzes
und hierauf beruhender Gesetze betrifft,
für die Dauer des Spannungs- oder Verteidigungsfalls nach Artikel 80a des Grundgesetzes bestehen,
wenn in unmittelbarem zeitlichen Zusammenhang mit diesem die Änderung des Geschlechtseintrags
von männlich zu weiblich oder divers oder die Streichung der Angabe zum Geschlecht erklärt wird.
Unmittelbar ist der zeitliche Zusammenhang während eines Spannungs- oder Verteidigungsfalls
sowie ab einem Zeitpunkt von zwei Monaten vor Feststellung desselben.
Das heißt also, wenn du heute dein Geschlecht mit diesem Selbstbestimmungsgesetz
änderst und im Mai sagen die,
jetzt müssen wir die Houthis in die Steinzeit zurückbomben,
dann musst du trotzdem kämpfen.
Das finde ich sehr gut.
Dann wird das wieder rumgedreht. Und er tut jetzt so, als stünde das nicht da drin. Es steht da drin.
Ich frage mich, ob wir irgendwann in diesem Podcast nochmal eine Situation herstellen,
in der Fachleute oder sonstig legitimierte Leute, die über ein Thema reden,
wissen, wovon sie reden.
Also Lanz weiß nicht, was ein Bürgergelempfänger ist.
Diese ganzen Entbürokratisierer wissen nicht, was Bürokratie ist.
Der queer-politische Sprecher, der dann nämlich mal an dem Verteidigungsausschuss
saß und demnächst wahrscheinlich wieder sitzen wird, hat den Gesetzes Wortlaut
nicht präsent in dem Podcast zu diesem Thema.
Der entscheidende ist zu diesem Thema. Das ist der einzige Paragraf auch dazu.
Man muss nur den kennen. Man kann ihn auswendig lernen.
Und dann sagt er noch Folgendes.
Also das ist nicht so, sondern die Menschen werden dann auch gegen ihren Willen,
die Männer, so, die Männer werden dann auch gegen ihren Willen eingezogen.
Das steht auch im Gesetz drin, so.
Auch das ist ja nicht so, sondern auch da kann man eigentlich verweigern.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass alle sofort eingezogen werden. Das droht als Gefahr
und dass man dann irgendwann den Ausnahmezustand erklärt und dann geht gar nichts mehr.
Und man kann nur noch versuchen irgendwie zu fliehen. Aber auch da ist ja eigentlich
grundgesetzlich was anderes angesagt.
Das wird aber hier einfach von einem SPD-Experten verbreitet.
Dann geht es um die Ukraine.
Ich war oft in der Ukraine. Und wer hat denn ganz am Anfang wirklich die Gewehre in die Hand genommen?
Das waren vor allem Menschen in Seniorenheimen. Und das war die queere Community.
Das waren die Ersten, die da gestanden sind, weil sie nicht unter russischer
Herrschaft leben wollten, weil sie wussten, was ihnen dann passiert.
Ja, es gab diese Bilder.
Das fände mir so eine Fahrstuhlmetapher.
Aber das ist so ein schönes Bild, dass man sagt, dieser Krieg ist eigentlich im Wurka-Krieg.
Und haben Sie in der ukrainischen Gesellschaft eine riesen Anerkennung damit auch?
Das stimmt teilweise. Tatsächlich bin ich aber auch ein Teil von Queeren Nothilfe
Ukraine, die sich genau mit solchen Sachen auseinandergesetzt hat.
Und wir haben viele Fälle gesehen von insbesondere trans Frauen,
die wirklich durch die Wälder und durch die Flüsse geschwommen sind.
Und große Gefahren auf sich genommen haben, um das nicht machen zu müssen.
Auch. Das war sehr dramatisch für viele Leute.
Ja, komischerweise wollten die auch nicht alle kämpfen. Und hier muss ich auch
sagen, ist mir das zu partikularistisch argumentiert von Luce Delir,
da müsste eigentlich jetzt nämlich ein universalistischer Ansatz kommen,
dass man sagt, wir wollen generell nicht, dass Menschen gezwungen werden zu kämpfen.
Denn man redet doch die ganze Zeit vom Selbstbestimmungsgesetz.
Wenn sich das aber nur die Selbstbestimmung auf das Geschlecht bezieht,
Und man sagt aber dann, im Ernstfall, du bist ein Mann, ach du bist auch nicht
trans, okay, dann ist das jetzt so, dann hast du keine Selbstbestimmung mehr
über dein Leben, dann brauchen wir darüber nicht reden.
Also da muss man doch gleich auf eine andere Ebene kommen und sagen,
also hört mal, egal jetzt welches Gespräch, das soll niemandem zugemutet werden, das zu tun.
Wahnsinn. So und jetzt kommt wirklich die Passage, bei der ich denke,
wir hatten irgendwann mal über russische Deserteure gesprochen,
die unglaubliche Schwierigkeiten haben, hier eine Aufenthaltserlaubnis zu bekommen.
Und wir haben immer gesagt, Putin hat ein demografisches Problem.
Putin gehen eigentlich die Männer oder generell die Leute aus.
Wir sehen es dann auch mit Lieferungen aus Nordkorea.
Und wir haben uns immer wieder gefragt, wie kann man Putin schaden.
Sanktionen ist ein Mittel, hat dann auch nicht in Gänze so funktioniert,
wie man sich das dachte, beziehungsweise hat man da sicherlich auch einige Dinge
immer durchgehen lassen.
Und sei es mal so, jedenfalls gibt es ja ein Mittel, mit dem man Putin schaden
könnte, nämlich ihm das demografische Problem zu vergrößern.
Und es ist ja Ivan Krastev, der ja darauf hinweist, ja, der hat eigentlich ein
Demografieproblem, der Putin.
Der braucht ja nicht mehr Land, sondern der braucht eigentlich mehr Leute.
Und dann geht es hier darum, um die Aufenthaltsgenehmigung beziehungsweise Asylverfahren
für queere Menschen aus Ländern, in denen sie verfolgt werden.
Und da gibt es wohl einige kritikwürdige Punkte, kann ich nicht beurteilen,
bin ich nicht eingelesen.
Jedenfalls will jetzt Drossmann zeigen, dass man auch nicht da einfach nur queere
Rechte einfordern könne, denn es gibt ja Sonderfälle und sonst kommt man da ja in eine Präduille.
Und das ist jetzt der Sonderfall, den er nennt.
Ein blödes Beispiel. Es gab ganz große Gruppen, die gesagt haben,
dass hier die queere Community, wenn jetzt ein queerer Mensch aus Russland sich
quasi meldet, dass wir doch hier aufnehmen müssen.
Also das hätte in der Konsequenz bedeutet, dass jeder russische junge Mann,
der der Zwangs eingezogen werden soll und sich in dem Moment als bisexuell erklärt,
nach Europa hätte kommen. Das hätten wir nicht durchgehalten.
Wunderbar, hätte ich gesagt. Macht das. Ich hätte eine Propagandaaktion gestartet.
Junge Russen, meldet euch einfach als bisexuell, wir nehmen euch auf,
dann werdet ihr nicht zwangsverpflichtet.
Was hätten wir denn nicht durchgestanden? Meint ihr, es wäre dann zu viel gewesen?
Ja.
Also ich kann es gar nicht fassen. Also der sagt, ja, es wäre so leicht gewesen
und sagt dann, nee, das geht ja nicht.
Also für mich ist das ja auch die Entsprechung des Spruchs, stell dir vor,
es ist Krieg und keiner geht hin.
Ja, alle melden sich bisexuell.
Und wenn wir einen Mechanismus haben, der zu keiner geht hin hat,
dann ja, also ist mir auch unklar.
Ich bin völlig fassungslos gut. Wir wenden uns einem anderen Spektrum der Gesellschaft
zu, nämlich den ganz Rechten.
Und zwar Philipp Stein, Benedikt Kaiser und Volker Zierke, die sind ja aus diesem
Schnellroder-Kosmos, das heißt also sehr rechts.
Rossis, Thüringen, Land.
Und zu Kubitschek irgendwie gehörend, ich weiß nicht wie da genau gerade die
Beziehungen sind, in Teilen auch mal zum KRA-Umfeld gehören,
weiß ich auch jetzt gar nicht.
Jedenfalls ist das nicht jetzt die Mehrheitsstimme der AfD.
Was aber den Vorteil hat, ist bei diesem Podcast, den sie da machen,
der heißt von rechts gelesen, dass sie dort,
ziemlich frei darüber reden, wie die AfD so ist und wie sie so denken über Krieg und alles mögliche.
Und da sie diese etwas randständige Position haben, können sie sich da auch
eine gewisse Freiheit erlauben.
Und sie sind alle drei belesen und sind in intellektuellen Diskursen drin, was auch helfen kann.
Jedenfalls dachte ich mir, was sagen die eigentlich zum Thema Zeitenwende?
Und da hören wir jetzt mal rein.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Zuhörer, zu einer neuen Episode von Rechtsgelesen,
dem rechten Kultur-, Literatur- und Szene-Podcast des Jung-Europa-Verlags.
Ja, wir gehen mal so rein, es bleibt nicht bei der Musik.
Klingt so, als darf man den erst ab 18 Uhr hören oder so.
Wir hören mal weiter.
Dass durch die Tatsache, dass Trump ja ein ganz großer Bösewicht ist und die
europäischen Leitfiguren der Politik mit ihm nicht wirklich gut können,
es in der letzten Zeit so ein bisschen klingelt überall und man plötzlich wieder
davon spricht, dass Europa aufrüsten müsse.
Dass Europa vielleicht doch nicht so sehr an die USA gekettet sein dürfe,
dass man womöglich sogar eine bundesdeutsche Atomaufrüstung brauche, soll bedeuten,
wenn man zumindest den Aussagen der Politiker und den Zeitungsartikeln glaubt,
erleben wir gerade die Rückkehr eines militärischen europäischen eigenen Bewusstseins.
Und das ist ja eine Sache, die nicht nur unser Leib- und Magenthema ist,
sondern auch eine Sache, die glaube ich, viele so haben nicht kommen sehen.
Also die Frage, die über diesem gesamten Podcast steht, wie finden wir das eigentlich?
Sehr gutes Thema.
Das war jetzt Philipp Stein. Wir hören Volker Zierke. Selbst glaube ich auch
eine militärische Vergangenheit, bin mir gerade nicht sicher.
Wir haben ja eben schon mal gehört am Anfang dieses Podcasts,
Das Denken muss jetzt verändert werden, etc. Und wir sehen jetzt immer so Allianzen.
Also ich will dir einfach mal zeigen, wie über die Perspektive.
Ich bin in einer Atomwaffenallianz mit diesen Podcasts.
Ich befürchte es. Nein, also ja, wir hören da gleich rein.
Jedenfalls ist ja interessant, dass man fast allen bis zum Teil in die Linkspartei
hinein den Leuten sagen kann, Aufrüstung und wohl auch Wehrpflicht und so können
sinnvoll sein, müssen wir jetzt unterstützen.
Und interessant ist ja, wie viele verschiedene Positionen man da drin hat.
Und jeder wünscht sich natürlich auch, mit der Aufrüstung oft was anderes zu
erreichen. Wir hören jetzt erstmal hier.
Was viel wichtiger ist, ist glaube ich, dass das Mindset, um mal einen schönen
deutsch-englischen Begriff zu brauchen, das fehlt halt den Europäern.
Und er führt das dann auch mal näher aus.
Nämlich und das hat dieser
ukrainekrieg gezeigt dass diese kriege der zukunft
abnutzungs kriege sind das heißt das muss
reicht eben nicht einfach nur 200 panzer irgendwo zu
kaufen und dann zu erwarten dass dann sagt man halt im verteidigungsbudget gut
die halten bis 2040 oder so und dann ist gut und dann kaufen wir neue panzer
sondern zu sagen gut sind so und so viele panzer gekauft worden davon stellen
wir so und so viele brigaden auf und im verteidigungsfall können die so und so lange,
Zwei Wochen oder so durchhalten, sonst haben die kein Zeug mehr,
also haben sie kein Material mehr, dann haben sie keine Mannschaften mehr.
Und diese ganzen Überlegungen, also auch eine Wirtschaftskrieg kriegsfähig zu
machen, aber auch eine Bevölkerung darauf einzustimmen,
das halte ich für einen viel, viel schwereren Akt als diese ganze Diskussion
über Gelder und Budgets und Truppenteile und so weiter, sondern es ist ein innerer Vorgang.
Ein innerer Vorgang. Jetzt sind wir wieder bei Hopfs, naturell und so.
Ich weiß auch, warum das eine schwierige Sache ist, weil den Leuten das nicht
zu verklickern ist. Es ist einfach zu doof.
Es ist sich zu doof, aber du siehst ja von Alena Büx bis zur Lage der Nation.
Ja, aber das ist halt Gerede, bis es hart auf hart kommt.
Und wenn man einfach nur einen Panzer ersetzen will, man kann den auch in Testfällen
und so weiter runterfahren.
Also da braucht man nicht zwei Wochen Krieg, da kann man auch zwei Monate Übungen machen.
Ich kenne ja deine Argumentationen und sage ja immer, hoffentlich hast du recht.
Ich will mal noch einen anderen Punkt mit reinbringen. Wir haben ja diese.
Naja, du meinst jetzt in Bezug auf, wenn es hart auf hart kommt?
Nee, in Bezug auf, dass die Leute dazu dann doch nicht zu bringen sind und das
ist völlig illusorisch, dass die Leute dazu bereit sind.
Aber wir hatten doch diese ganze Diskussion über die Männer,
die perspektivlos sind, die keine tollen Jobs mehr bekommen,
die nicht genügend wertgeschützt werden und die zugleich sich Fitnesskörper
nicht nur antrainieren, sondern Körperpanzer, möchte ich behaupten.
Die sich Videos bei YouTube ansehen, die den Titel tragen, trainiere wie ein
Elitekämpfer, iss wie ein Soldat oder sei diszipliniert, ganz schlecht.
Und haben wir hier nicht ein ganz großes Potenzial von jungen Männern,
denen man jetzt nur sagen muss, pass auf, hier kann ich...
Deiner Sinnsuche einen Sinn geben in Form des Nationalstaates und die sammle
ich damit ein. Also ist da nicht eine große Gefahr drin?
Wir haben, um das noch zu verlängern, was du schon sagst, Rutger Brechmanns Buch gelesen.
Wann sagen die Leute, ging es mir richtig gut im Krieg, als die Solidargemeinschaft
sich selbst und so weiter, als die Nachbarschaft, als ich plötzlich alle Namen
kannte und jeden Tag hat jemand eine Suppe gekocht. Also es gibt viele gute Erzählungen.
Aber wir sind ja nicht in Churchills Zweiten Weltkrieg und der Verteidigung
Englands und da fliegen Flugzeuge, werfen Bomben ab und wir wissen,
ah, heute ist der große Angriff.
Sondern diese Kriege, die doch jetzt drohen, die beginnen doch nicht damit,
dass Putin Befehl gibt und dann ein Panzer über die Grenze fährt.
Nein.
Sondern die beginnen mit, als allererstes wird mal Strom ausgeschaltet,
dann wird Internet gekappt und der ganze Kram.
Dein Handyakku geht noch sechs Stunden, aber du hast schon keine Verbindung mehr.
Diese Idee, dass Krieg eine Situation ist, in der wir alle weiter podcasten,
miteinander verbunden sind, uns irgendwie Fotos von unserer Uniform schicken oder was auch immer.
Nein, Krieg wird heißen, keine Wasserversorgung, keine Stromversorgung,
kein Internet, du bist wieder auf dich selbst zurückgestellt und so weiter und so fort.
Aber auch in Kiew gibt es ja Strom und Internet und da werden Podcasts aufgenommen.
Genau, und das kann aber dann bedeuten.
Dass man sagt, wir schicken...
Also wir sagen jetzt wieder.
Da ist kein Krieg, Da sind natürlich Luftangriff um die ständige Gefahr.
Aber die Situation wie in der Ostukraine seit 2014 ist in Kiew nicht.
Genau, aber da kann man ja andere hinschicken. Also nicht die Podcaster werden
da selbst sein, aber die Podcaster werden aus ihrem Podcaststudios zurufen,
macht mal bitte weiter mit dem Kampf.
Krieg in der Ostukraine, wie er läuft, läuft so,
weil das Damoklesschwert des Atomkriegs immer darüber hängt und deswegen der
Krieg fast wie so ein Scharmützel an der Grenze zwischen Pakistan und Indien
als Faustkampf ausgetragen wird.
Genau und Volker Zierke sagt.
Das wäre hier in Deutschland ganz anders.
Ja, wenn wir jetzt davon ausgehen, dass eine Armee in Frankfurt steht und eine
andere ihr gegenüber, das meine ich ja nicht damit.
Ich glaube, da wird gar nicht mehr in Armeen und Panzern und so weiter.
Volker Zierke ja hier sagt, und ich glaube, da hat er wirklich einen Punkt,
dass er sagt, die Kriege der Zukunft oder der Gegenwart sind Abnutzungskriege.
Und genau das ist ja das, was wir in der Ukraine erleben. Da werden die Menschen abgenutzt.
Das heißt, sie sterben noch und nöcher. Und ich könnte mir gut vorstellen,
dass man, wenn man jetzt weiter aufrüstet und das alles als so richtig empfindet,
dass man in Regionen vertreten, ich
will jetzt nicht irgendwelche Regionen benennen, wo man dann aber sagt,
hier stationieren wir 20.000 Soldaten und die stehen anderen 20.000 Soldaten
gegenüber und die kommen immer so ein bisschen weiter, aber dadurch halten wir
uns gegenseitig klein. Und das ist die Großgefahr.
Ich rede jetzt auch nicht von einem Bombenhagel wie in den 40er Jahren,
sondern ich rede eben von so etwas.
Und genau da sehe ich ja auch diese große Gefahr drin eigentlich,
dass man junge Männer dazu überreden kann, sich dem auszusetzen.
Und bei Zierke, der jetzt noch von altem Schlage ist, sage ich mal,
ist da erstmal nicht dran zu denken, weil er folgendes jetzt sieht.
Und der fehlt halt im Westen komplett durch Jahre linksliberaler Einwirkung
und natürlich im deutschen Allgemeinen dieser Schuldkultgedanke,
das ist denke ich mit einer der Hauptgründe.
Warum Deutschland nicht marschiert und auch nicht marschieren wird.
Er will natürlich, dass Deutschland marschiert. Sitt nennt jetzt dann dieses
rechte Kampfwort Schuldkult. Er spricht über die Linksliberalen.
Und jetzt ist aber interessant, wie Philipp Stein widerspricht und sagt, ja Moment mal.
Kriegsbegeisterung des linksliberal-grünen Milieus, das die ja selber nicht
sozusagen einlösen mussten, diese Versprechen, jetzt plötzlich schon irgendwie
so ein bisschen ernst wird.
Oder nicht? Es wird kein Ernst draus.
Jetzt übernimmt Philipp Benedikt Kaiser.
Und ich glaube, dass es nicht nur am Ukraine-Fetisch der linksliberalen Kräfte
im herrschenden Block in Deutschland liegt, sondern das liegt daran,
dass die Ukraine für diese Kräfte mittlerweile nur noch ein Symbol ist.
Und zwar ein Symbol, der Verteidiger des Westens zu sein.
Also hier wird nicht einfach ein Kampf zwischen Ukraine und Russland kommentiert
und militärpolitisch eingeordnet und mit Aufrüstungsideen und Aufrüstungsplänen verwoben,
sondern hier steht der ganze Westen als Projekt, als Emanzipationsprojekt,
als Projekt der Westbindung im Wortsinne, das Projekt der Emanzipationsideologie,
als Projekt des Individualismus, als Projekt der westlich geprägten Marktwirtschaft,
als Projekt der Menschenrechte.
Dieses Projekt, aus ihrer Sicht irgendwie so eine Art komische Zwitter aus humanistischen
und materialistischen Zielen, dieses Projekt steht jetzt am Scheideweg.
Und für sie, die haben sich selber sozusagen in diese Situation hineingemimmt,
dass die Ukraine sozusagen der letzte Vorposten dieses freien Westens ist im
Kampf gegen die düstere Despotie aus den asiatischen Steppen.
Und die Unterscheidung, die Kaiser hier macht, ist auch die zwischen dem Westen und Europa.
Also sie sehen sich ja als pro-Europäer. Diese Rechten, die wir jetzt gerade hier hören,
nämlich wollen die eigentlich eine faschistische, europäische Ordnung haben,
während der Westen angedockt ist an die transatlantische Partnerschaft.
Also ich höre ja Leute, die sich sehr klug fühlen und sehr abgeklärt und die
jetzt irgendwie einen großen Deckel drauf machen wollen, wo wir nur durcheinander
sehen und die ganzen Woken und so weiter. Ich höre mir das jetzt noch ein paar
Clips an und danach mache ich ein finales Urteil.
Weil das ist einfach dumm.
Wieso ist das dumm?
Also diese ganze Idee, wie er jetzt rangeht.
Naja, aber es ist doch interessant, erstmal festzustellen, dass die Friedenspartei,
die Grünen, mehr denn je.
Warst man alles vor.
Und die Begründung ist ja tatsächlich, von jetzt auch Leuten wie Strack-Zimmermann
oder so zu sagen, wenn die Ukraine fällt, fällt der Westen.
Das sind alles diese Scharmützel. Ich weiß, also ich höre es ja,
wie da Waffen, Waffen, Waffen gefordert werden aus dem grünen Lager,
wo ich mir dachte, die kommen da aus der Friedensbewegung.
Die reden also auf bestimmte Art und Weise über Krieg, bei der ich sage,
das ist aber merkwürdig, seid ihr bescheuert, könnt ihr mal mitdenken.
Die reden ja genauso merkwürdig über Krieg. Die drehen nur so ein paar Vorzeichen um.
Die wollen ja den heroischen Soldaten.
Genau. Und ich möchte jetzt, ich bringe es mal auf so eine ganz kleine Ideepointe begrifflich.
Dass wir hier einen Abnuchzungskrieg haben, dass wir überhaupt in die Gelegenheit
kommen, über Jahre hinaus so eine mediale Erzählung zu haben von in der Ukraine
und die waren seit Monaten nicht zu Hause und da wo sie sind,
im Schützengraben hängen, die Familie aufzunehmen. gehangen,
für die kämpfen sie nämlich und so weiter und so fort.
Hat ja nur damit zu tun, dass internationale Kriege so geführt werden,
wie die sich das wünschen, dass man sich da als Mann verdient machen kann und
vielleicht sogar noch ein Leben danach hat, weil nach fünf Jahren muss es ja auch mal reichen.
Der Krieg geht aber weiter, man selbst zieht zurück nach Kiew und sagt,
ich habe drei Jahre lang hier mitverteidigt, wie auch immer,
ich bin jetzt ein Herr von Welt.
So, dass wir diese Art von Abnutzungskriegen, die wir so als Meme,
wie sie auch kritisiert, mitlaufen lassen können, dass wir hier so gesund kurz
vor irgendwelchen Urlaubsreisen am Wochenende nochmal fordern können auf Twitter,
jetzt aber nochmal richtig rein und so, liefert mal die Waffen,
befreit den Leoparden und so weiter.
Ist ja nur möglich, weil die Entgrenzung dieses Krieges bedeuten würde,
dass wir es nicht mehr mit,
internationalen Kriegen zwischen zwei Parteien und der Rest ist so Stellvertreter-Mischmasch
haben, sondern wenn wir den entgrenzen und auch nur über eine Grenze hinweg
oder eine Kriegspartei mehr oder was, haben wir es sofort mit interkontinentalen Kriegen zu tun.
Interkontinentale Kriege sind keine Abnutzungskriege. Und da gibt es auch nichts zu gewinnen.
Interkontinentale Kriege sind kurzer Prozess.
Ja, das stimmt, ja.
Und in der Ukraine haben wir es mit einer Kriegsform zu tun,
bei der ich jetzt sage...
Die lässt sich nicht entgrenzen und die lässt sich nicht verlagern.
Wenn wir uns in Deutschland mit heroischem Gedankengut oder was auch immer da
jetzt noch so kommt, auf einen Krieg vorbereiten,
dann werden die Leute, die sich da glauben, gut vorbereitet zu haben,
sehr davon überrascht sein, dass das nicht so ein Scharmützel-Gefecht wie in
der Ukraine ist, sondern hier wirklich zur Sache ist.
Ja, aber auch in der Ukraine ist kein Scharmützel. Wir werden gleich noch Clips dazu hören.
Naja, aber in der Ukraine schießt man Artillerie und guckt man mal, wie weit das so fliegt.
Also es rechnet ja jetzt wohl kaum einer damit, dass Deutschland angegriffen
wird. Also so irre kann man ja nicht sein.
Ich sehe lauter Leute, die damit rechnen.
Ja.
Dass die Landesverteidigung, die alte Wehrpflicht und so weiter.
Ja genau, aber das wird ja alles ein Anschlag. Also der Precht hat ja von Massenwahn
gesprochen. Das ist eigentlich kein schlechter Begriff.
Das wird ja alles ein Anschlag gebracht, um überhaupt diese Auffrüstung zu schaffen.
Was ich mich frage ist, wird man vielleicht in acht Jahren von Europa aus sagen,
wir sind stark genug, jetzt machen wir uns an die Krippen, jetzt wollen wir die wiederhaben.
Da ist das größere Problem, dass ich dann auf Dauer sehen kann und dass eben
solche dauerhaften Abnutzungskriege dann zum Beispiel zwischen Russland und
Europa sein kann, weil dann Putin sagt, genau,
wir sind auch wieder stark genug,
wir gucken nochmal, ob wir da was abkriegen. Das ist ja das Problem.
Und ich will ja jetzt erstmal, ich habe ja diese Rechten ausgesucht,
um so eine ideologische Vermessung zu machen. Wo stehen die eigentlich?
Weil die ja eigentlich Militär und all das geil finden. Jetzt sagen die aber, hm.
Jetzt sind ja auch irgendwie diese Grünen sind ja auch dafür.
Ich müsste ja auch mit denen gemeinsam kämpfen. Und dann ist noch der queerpolitische
Sprecher Trossmann ist auch noch neben mir im Graben.
Was macht das?
Uiuiui.
Deswegen immer Bürgerkrieg. Krieg heißt immer auch Bürgerkrieg.
Also nein, das ist ja interessant. Und in der Ukraine kann man es ja zum Teil
schon sehen, du hast ja das Azov-Regime,
die Rechtsextremen und hast auch tatsächlich queere Soldaten. Ja.
Und das macht im Übrigen auch diese linksliberal-grüne, antirussische Aufrüstungsideologie
so anschlussfähig für westextremistische Hardcore-Rechte, die es auch in Deutschland gibt.
So Hardcore-Rechte muss man sich mal merken, denn er meint nicht sich selbst.
Also er meint damit wieder andere in der AfD.
Weil man auf einmal jetzt diesen gemeinsamen Feind im Kreml sitzen hat,
was die Russen im Übrigen nach meinem Dafürhalten völlig überschätzt in ihrer
Wirksamkeit, in ihrer Potenz, sowohl kulturell, wirtschaftlich als auch militärisch und politisch.
Aber das, deswegen klingen eben auch manche Verlautbarungen von radikalen Rechten
in Deutschland in Bezug auf die Ukraine und den Westen eben wie Verlautbarungen
von Grünen. Das kommt nicht aus nichts.
Also da gibt es eine komische Allianz, die ihr feststellt. Jetzt stellt sich
eine Frage. Ich weiß jetzt, was mich hier so aufregt.
Ich merke es, ich fühle es gerade.
Was denn?
Wenn die Linken, Grünen, Progressiven, wer auch immer Kräfte,
über sowas reden, schwingt da immer noch so ein eigentlich wünschen wir uns
das ja nicht, aber es muss ja jetzt sein.
Es kommt ja immer so dieses, die Not ist und so weiter.
Bei denen ist einfach nur, jetzt ist die Gelegenheit da, endlich ist Krieg wieder, Popkultur und so.
Also bei Kaiser würde ich das nicht so sehen. Ich glaube bei anderen da aus,
der Schnelle-Rote-Ecke, die haben schon so eine heimliche Freude.
Findest du nicht?
Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, die finden halt blöd.
Dass ihnen der Krieg gerade madig gemacht wird, weil die Falschen jetzt auch und so.
Also zumindest fragen sie sich, ob das helfen kann, denn, also man muss es vielleicht
nochmal für alle, die zu hören, jetzt klar machen.
Es gibt ja die AfD in der Ausprägung des Nationalismus, dass man sagt,
die D mag wieder und weniger Europa.
Ja.
Wenngleich diese Kräfte auch nachgelassen haben. Man schreibt da nochmal pro
forma was rein, aber so richtig will man aus dem Euro ja auch nicht mehr raus,
auch wenn man mal die D-Mark-Partei war.
Hier das ist eine rechte Strömung, die sagt, wir sind europäisch.
Wir haben auch Connections zu den Identitären, die ja auch europäisch sind.
Das heißt, man verbindet sich mit faschistischen Strömungen aus Italien, Frankreich, Spanien,
aus Osteuropa und kann auch in gewisser Weise die Russen, die dort kämpfen, schätzen,
weil man sagt, die sind ja auch zum Teil faschistisch und alle sind heroische
Männer, die sich gegenüberstehen und sich nochmal als Mann beweisen.
Das ist also ein anderes Konzept als das nationale Konzept der AfD.
Jetzt geht es hier um folgendes.
Das Irre ist ja letztendlich, dass dann eine Achse Macron, Merz und eben England
oder Großbritannien, wenn die den Krieg in der Ukraine noch verlängern,
während die USA aussteigen, was ja davon auszugehen ist.
Was denkbar ist zumindest, ja. Was denkbar ist zumindest jetzt,
zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt, wo wir hier aufnehmen.
Dann bedeutet das im Grunde, dass die EU ökonomisch ausblutet,
dass sie gleichzeitig aber natürlich militärpolitisch aufrüstet und damit eine Forderung erfüllt,
die auch von rechts pro europäischer Seite natürlich immer auch im Munde geführt
worden ist, nämlich sich unabhängig von Washington und Moskau eine eigene Sicherheitsstrategie,
eine eigene Sicherheitsautonomie zuzulegen.
So, und da sind wir an einem entscheidenden Punkt. Zirke sagt jetzt.
Weil natürlich auch für uns recht, dass sich jetzt die Frage stellt,
ist denn eigentlich eine interessensgeleitete Außenpolitik so wünschenswert?
Weil das ja auch nichts anderes ist als ein boomereskes, der gesunde Menschenverstand Absichtserklärungen.
Weil auch wir haben natürlich Werte, für die wir einstehen und die im schlimmsten
Fall es vielleicht auch wert ist, gegen Interessen abzuwerten.
Also man ist nicht noch und eins, jetzt kommt Philipp Stein.
Ich will auf den Punkt hinaus, das ist ja in einigen Teilen auch der europäischen
Rechten, nicht nur in Deutschland, man denke hier auch an Teile von Casa Pound,
man denke hier an Teile spanischer Gruppierungen,
man denke hier vor allem an Franzosen aus dem Umfeld der Güte und so weiter,
es gibt ja in der Ukraine durchaus in verschiedenen Einheiten die,
Ein, in Anführungszeichen, kleines Europa, wo also Soldaten,
Freiwillige, meinetwegen auch was auch immer, Freischerler gemeinsam durchaus
davon überzeugt sind, für ein gemeinsames Ziel zu kämpfen.
Ja, das ist ja ein sehr kleines Phänomen. Wurde auch immer mal wieder da abgebildet
von diesem jungen Europa Verlag.
Das ist ja der Verlag von Stein, dass die da immer wieder gezeigt haben,
hier ist mal ein Blockeintrag von einem der unseren, der dort kämpft.
Und jetzt steht man dem also komisch gegenüber und sieht auch,
ach das deckt sich aber jetzt auch nicht alles mit dem, was in der AfD so anzutreffen ist.
Jetzt ist das eine Sache, die keine größere Bedeutung erlangt hat, glaube ich.
Das muss man sagen, weder militärisch noch innerhalb der Rechten als sozusagen
ein wirklich strömungsübergreifender Einigungsprozess. Ganz im Gegenteil,
wir erleben ja seit geraumer Zeit eher diesen nationalistischen Rollback.
Und nationalistisch meine ich hier wirklich im schlechtesten Wortsinne so eine
boomereske, chauvinistische, ha ha ha, ich mach Polenwitze-Mentalität.
Also dieses wirklich, dieses ganz stumpfe, weiß ich nicht, diese ganz stumpfe
Denke, die mit einem tatsächlich einigen wehrfähigen Europäertum nichts zu tun
hat und davon auch nichts wissen will.
Das ist eher eine Tendenz in der Rechten, auch durch das Aufkommen und Erstarken der AfD.
Also man ist da jetzt zwiegespalten.
Das sind interessante Gedanken, die sich machen. Und ich meine damit nicht inhaltlich
interessant, sondern dass sie sich so Gedanken darüber machen,
also in dieser Form. Ich habe es noch nicht ganz durchschaut.
Also für sie ist ja klar, man kann nicht mehr in den Nationalstaat zurück,
sondern Europa als Raum muss geschützt werden von allem, was von außen kommt.
Das ist natürlich die Amerikanisierung.
Das ist die Islamisierung. Und das meint aber auch, Schutz vor Russen und Chinesen muss man bieten.
Und wir verbinden uns als Vielvölker Europa oder wie man das dann auch nennen will, miteinander.
Ethnopluralismus sagt, ja, darf sein, nur jeder bitte in seine Regionen.
Und gemeinsam kämpfen wir einen heroischen Kampf, um zum Beispiel dann Russen
oder Chinesen abzuhalten.
Wir haben ja als zivile Entsprechung so ein Phänomen, dass die Tagesthemen fasziniert
davon sind, dass ein Redakteur morgens in der Runde sagt, hört mal,
ich bin hier gerade durch die Stadt gelaufen, hier ist ein AfD-Stand,
aber da stehen irgendwie Migranten und machen die Werbung.
Und dann sagen die so, hey, das ist doch komisch, die sind doch fremdenfeindlich
und jetzt stehen die Fremden da und dann fahren die so hin mit dem Kamerateam
und stellen dann so fest,
ach so, die denken auch so Hardcore, Vater, Mutter, Kind, Herd,
Fabrikarbeiter, familienpolitisch und die denken genauso,
Der Fremde ist, der mir, aber ich selber bin ja nicht der Fremde,
ich bin ja vor zehn Jahren gekommen und habe mich hier verdient gemacht in Deutschland
und ich sitze dann daneben und denke mir, ja so ist das halt,
also Leute sind, er hat es ja aufgezählt, chauvinistisch oder wie auch immer eingestellt,
ideologisch halt, Bandbreite und da kann es halt zu Milieubildung kommen,
unabhängig von Hautfarbe und so weiter, die Hauptsache alle stehen stramm und was auch immer.
Bei denen muss man aber schon sagen, also hier jetzt bei denen,
die wir da hören, da zählt jetzt schon, also man muss schon Europäer sein.
Genau, ich will denen das jetzt nicht, ich meine nur, so wie die Tagesthemen
sich darüber verwundert zeigen, was da für Verbrüderungen stattfinden und dass
es doch mehr um Ideologie als um Aussehen geht und wie auch immer,
so sitzen jetzt erstaunlicherweise für mich auf der rechten Seite genauso die
Leute da und sagen, nee, darüber müssen wir erstmal reden, uns das verständlich
machen und dann kommt der eine mit einem Wortbeitrag und der andere und die
führen so eine Diskussion.
Und ich hätte gedacht, die hätten das für sich halt einfach geklärt.
Das wäre so gesetzte Sache.
Aber die sitzen ja genauso verwundert vor solchen Phänomenen und sagen,
dann sind aber noch ganz kleine Phänomene und hier und da und so.
Ja, man muss ja sehen, was ist Europa? Was ist Europa? Was ist Europa für die?
Und natürlich ist das jetzt die Anti-Alice-Weidel-Fraktion, die wir hier hören.
Es scheint ja alles Anti-Alice-Weidel. Das scheint ja das Phänomen zu sein wie bei Trump.
Alle tänzeln um sie herum, aber man braucht sie halt als die Frau kann doch
nicht Hitler sein, die lebt doch mit einer Frau in der Schweiz.
Ja, aber dieser Internationalismus spielt schon eine große Rolle.
Also ich glaube, dass jetzt die Schnellroderleute...
Alice Weidel eher als so eine globalistische Elite, um mal diese Begrifflichkeiten
zu verwenden, sehen würden, während ihnen natürlich was anderes vorschwebt.
Ja, man nennt das Posterchild, braucht man ab und zu, gerade wenn es ein gäriger Haufen ist.
Ja, naja und es gibt eben diese CDU-Leute, ehemals CDU-Leute Enttäuschte,
die bei der AfD sind, die wollen einfach die D-Mark wieder und am besten wieder
wie unter Helmut Kohl oder weiß ich nicht wem oder Konrad Adenauer.
Und das ist jetzt deren Sache, die wir jetzt für ihr hören, nicht.
Stein führt weiter aus.
Dort haben gewisse Kreise gesagt, der Ukraine-Konflikt ist eine Chance,
innerhalb der Rechten eine europäische Einigung herzustellen.
Wir haben das verneint, weil wir gesagt haben, eine europäische Einigung kann
niemals vor dem Hintergrund eines amerikanischen Stellvertreterkrieges passieren.
So mal ganz verkürzt zusammengefasst.
Wir haben das weitaus differenzierter dargestellt.
Wir haben aber gesagt, auf einer falschen Prämisse fußend kann keine Erneuerung stattfinden.
Jetzt erleben wir was ähnliches möglicherweise auf großer Bühne, wie ich sagte.
Jetzt stellt sich für den Rechten natürlich die Frage, und das ist ja die aktuelle
Diskussion auch rund um die Wehrpflicht,
können wir diese europäische Erneuerung, dieses europäische Erwachen möglicherweise
eines eigenen Bewusstseins tolerieren, um es später sozusagen für uns nutzen zu können?
Stellvertreterkriege sind Stellvertreterkriege, weil da irgendwer Gelegenheiten nutzt.
Mhm.
Oder sagt man aus einer grundsätzlichen Position heraus, unter diesen Vorzeichen
ist das mit jeder Faser des Leibes abzulehnen?
Ich glaube, das ist des Pudels Kern, den wir heute diskutieren müssen.
Wie verhalten wir uns als proeuropäische radikale Rechte?
Zu diesem neuen europäischen Projekt.
Benedikt Kaiser ist skeptisch.
Ich finde das...
Wir müssen ja folgendes aussehen.
Ich finde das gut.
Wir können ja wirklich ganz gut hier noch was dran sehen. Wir merken ja einen Rechtsruck in Europa.
Das heißt, Meloni regiert schon, Le Pen steht in den Startlöchern.
Die sind jetzt sicherlich keine Meloni-Anhänger, aber Meloni macht natürlich
für so Leute wie sie da, Sie ist ja eben Postfaschistin, wie man immer sagt.
Sie kennt natürlich auch Casa Pound, die hier schon erwähnt wurden und sowas.
Macht sie natürlich sehr viel möglich.
Bei Le Pen gibt es ja so eine Entwicklung hin auch zum Transatlantischen.
Das ist etwas, was von hier kritisch beurteilt wird.
Und die Frage ist jetzt, wie muss man sich da in irgendeiner Weise positionieren?
Denn das wird ja tatsächlich die künftige Frage sein, wenn so sehr aufgerüstet
ist und so viele rechte Regierungen in Europa da sind, dann werden wir auch rechte Kriege führen.
Und dann mag zwar da noch jemand dabei sein, der sich selbst als Vogue und Queer
und weiß ich nicht was bezeichnen möchte, dann wird er aber da mitgehen müssen.
Und da sehe ich ja noch gar keine Sensibilisierung für.
Ja, dass man sagt, wir müssen jetzt rechte Interessen durchsetzen.
Das ist dieses falsche Europäertum. Das ist dieses EU-Europäertum.
Die, die jetzt aufrüsten wollen, sind unsere ideologischen Hauptgegner.
Das ist im Endeffekt die liberale Mitte.
Friedrich Merz in England, aber auch in Frankreich Macron. Das ist im Endeffekt die EU-Schickeria.
Und jetzt könnte man natürlich einerseits sagen,
Und wenn jetzt sozusagen diese falschen Europäer aus unserer Sicht das europäische
Einigungswerk vollbringen, inklusive europäischer Sicherheitsautonomie,
inklusive europäischer Militärpolitik, inklusive europäischer Wirtschaftsautonomie
oder Autarkie sogar irgendwann,
dann hätten quasi die falschen Eliten das Richtige getan und dann müssten wir
nur noch die falschen Eliten absetzen und dann hätten wir sozusagen die Früchte
ernten. Die Früchte können wir dann ernten.
Bereiten die also alles für die Rechten vor, für die Übernahme später? Kaiser sagt.
Ich bin in der Frage tatsächlich ein klein wenig unentschlossen.
Ich bin da auch, muss ich auch gestehen, ich bin ein Freund eigentlich von Klarheiten
und von klaren Standpunkten und einer klaren Generallinie.
Ich bin ja auch unentschlossen, deswegen sage ich ja, ich verstehe den Punkt, wer den so machen will.
Ich glaube nur, wenn man den jetzigen herrschenden Eliten des Westens in der
EU, wenn man denen mehr Macht zuschanzt,
sprich europäische Militär, europäische Sicherheit, europäische Wirtschaftsautonomie,
dann glaube ich, dass das ihnen hilft, ihre Hegemonie zu verlängern die eigentlich
gerade innerhalb der Nationalstaaten prüchiger wird.
Durch den Vormarsch rechter, rechtspopulistischer, konservativer,
zumindest EU-skeptischer und EU-kritischer Bewegungen und Parteien.
Ja, was machst du jetzt?
Ja, ich würde sagen, dass Kaiser hier ein bisschen irrt.
Vielleicht auch, weil er sich wünscht, dass es so ist, dass es EU-skeptische Parteien sind.
Ich sehe tatsächlich bei der AfD nicht mehr diese große EU-Skepsis.
Meloni zeigt ihnen nämlich gerade, wie man wunderbar in diesem Konstrukt leben
und agieren kann und Le Pen schielt auch dorthin und wir werden noch weitere
erleben, die sich in diese Richtung, glaube ich,
bewegen und wenn es dann noch den einen oder anderen Schulterschluss mit den
Konservativen geben kann.
Ist eigentlich die EU nichts mehr, was man infrage stellt.
Und dann kann man tatsächlich davon ausgehen, dass die europäische Aufrüstung
die Gefahr birgt, dass, wenn mal alles eingerichtet ist, die Rechten dann immer
mehr übernehmen können.
Und man muss sich das ja auch mal vorstellen, man weiß ja schon jetzt,
dass es viel AfD-Militär in Deutschland gibt.
Auch viele andere, ich will hier auf keinen Fall sagen, Die Bundeswehr ist AfD durchdrängt oder so.
Aber man kann sich ja vorstellen, dass jetzt, wo solche Diskurse ja geführt
werden oder so, die Bundeswehr interessant wird für viele Leute,
die recht im Gedanken gut anhängen.
Und man wird möglicherweise dann den AfD-Offizier über sich haben.
Man muss dann auch gar nicht bis zum Verteidigungsministerium gehen.
Das heißt also, was hier jetzt gerade noch so als eine wunderbare bunte Inklusionstruppe gezeigt wird,
wird sich wahrscheinlich eher wenden, denn du sagst es ja zu Recht,
diese Leute, die jetzt hier aus Podcasts heraus bei Bosetti,
braucht man nur daran zu denken, die überhaupt gar nichts mit Militär zu tun hat.
Oder denken wir hier an den Schluffi der grünen Jugend, Jakob Lase.
Da wissen wir ja alle, der geht ja nicht zum Militär.
Der macht einen Tweet.
Wer dann am Ende dahin geht, da sieht das dann schon anders aus.
Ja, schade. Ich dachte, ich hätte noch mal ein Krah-Clip, denn Krah wurde auch
kürzlich gefragt, kürzlich.
Sie wollen ja aus der EU austreten, aber das steht ja in ihrem Wahlprogramm
gar nicht drin. Und er ist ja jetzt auch im Bundestagswahlkampf gewesen.
Und dann sagt er, nee, ich will nicht aus der EU austreten.
Nur diese EU, wie sie jetzt gerade ist, muss weg.
Ja, ja.
Also da sieht man schon so dieses Rumlavieren.
Und es war ja immer, als die Kritik aufkam, mit, die EU ist ein neoliberales Projekt.
Oder immer gesagt, das steht in den Verträgen nicht drin. Es wurde halt politisch dazu gemacht.
Aber es hätte auch genauso gut ein sozialistisches Projekt genau mit diesen Verträgen sein können.
So, und jetzt wird es halt ein rechtes Projekt, wenn die da entsprechend umvorwerken.
Atomwaffen, dein Leibnachenthema.
Wir sprechen ja jetzt in der Bundesrepublik schon von Atomwaffen. Undenkbar eigentlich.
Vor allem auch in der AfD kommt es jetzt ganz stark. Lukassen und Fröhlich haben
uns, glaube ich, heute beide bei X gefordert. Ja, und genau da sind wir ja bei dem Punkt.
Die AfD scheint das anders zu sehen. Also interessanterweise gibt es Kreise
in der AfD, die sagen, genau dieser Punkt, ist doch schön, wenn die,
die wir verachten, unsere Ziele umsetzen, nämlich die Wehrpflicht wieder einzusetzen.
Dafür kämpfen wir als AfD seit zehn Jahren und die machen es jetzt.
Wir brauchen gar nichts dazu beizutragen. Das ist ja so eine Argumentation,
die mir übrigens, und das habe ich ja eingangs schon gesagt,
zu Beginn des Podcasts, die einem in der Rechten mittlerweile relativ häufig
begegnet, zu sagen, naja gut, dann sollen die anderen doch das machen, was wir vorhaben.
Ist egal, wer es umsetzt. Hauptsache, es wird erstmal gemacht.
Sie verweisen auch auf die Migrationspolitik und sagen, da machen sie es ja auch schon.
So, ich bin ja für Atomwaffen, um zwei Sachen auszuschließen.
Nämlich zum einen, dass mein Bizeps ran müsste und zum anderen,
dass es zu Krieg kommt, denn Atomwaffen werden nicht eingesetzt.
Wenn also Atomwaffen immer drohen, werde ich nicht nach meinem Bizeps gefragt,
weil wir können uns hier kein, ja gut, wegen Atomwaffen machen wir nur so einen halben Krieg.
Wir graben Schützengräben und schießen aber immer nur so 100 Kilometer weit, nicht weiter.
Weil ansonsten das ukrainische Modell des nationalen Kriegs wir containen ihn,
nur das ist ja zum einen kritikwürdig also ich würde jetzt auch nicht unbedingt
meiner eigenen Argumentation da folgen,
aber ich finde es trotzdem eine interessante Idee, aber ganz klar ist,
Keine deutschen Atomwaffen. Wir haben mehrere Verträge, die uns daran hindern.
Also 2 plus 4, der eigentliche Friedensvertrag oder wie auch immer.
Und so, also wir Deutschen dürfen das gar nicht. Auch wenn wir mit unserem Wissensstand,
den wir haben, wahrscheinlich nur ein Jahr bräuchten, um sie einfach einsatzfähig
zu haben. Also es ginge relativ schnell.
Nur mein Atomwaffenappell ist dann schon europäisch.
Und mit europäisch meine ich auch nicht die Achse Frankreich oder so,
sondern ich meine dann schon europäisch.
Also nicht so wie die.
Jetzt können wir uns ansehen, wie es einen Graben gibt in der AfD.
Und zwar ist jetzt immer wieder die Rede von bundeswehrsozialisierten AfD-Politikern.
Das sind also nochmal andere als die, die jetzt hier gerade zu uns sprechen.
Die sind auch nicht, ich weiß nicht, ob die alle in der AfD sind.
Jedenfalls stehen sie der AfD nah am Graberaten und so.
Aber es wird nochmal gezeigt, es gibt da unterschiedliche Stimmen in der AfD. Ich würde mal sagen.
Wir hören diese Podcasts und sie sagen uns ganz explizit, Wir geben keine Wahlempfehlung,
sondern wir müssen dann raten, wie bei Hoss und Hopf, was sie wohl wählen.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, also hier ist es schon deutlicher. Noch deutlicher als bei Hoss und Hopf.
Naja, das ist ja ein ganz klare, also die sagen ja, wir machen hier ein radikalrechtes Projekt.
So, die Frage ist nur, wer setzt es am besten gerade um?
Oder sind wir, also das ist völlig außer Frage.
Zum Beispiel Hannes Gnauck, ein bundeswehrsozialisierter Mann,
was oft problematisch in der AfD ist, weil die oft entsprechende Mindsets mitbringen,
sage ich mal neudeutsch.
Knaug sagt halt allen Ernstes, die NATO ist...
Man muss immer neudeutsch dabei sagen, um nochmal zu sagen, dass man eigentlich
Anglizismen schlecht findet.
Das auch. Wir hören den Clip vielleicht nochmal von Anfang. Das finde ich interessant, wie er das sagt.
Denn die Bundeswehrsoldaten, die ich kenne, nachdem Stefan Kühl nach Bielefeld
aus der Bundeswehr-Uni so ein paar Seminaristen mitbrachte, die auch mal so...
Die reden die ganze Zeit von dieser freiheitlich-demokratischen Grundordnung,
auf die sie ein Eid legen, die sie verteidigen, die sie auswendig lernen müssen,
Grundgesetz immer dabei und so weiter.
Jetzt hören wir nochmal, wie läppig er darüber redet.
Zum Beispiel Hannes Knauk, ein bundeswehrsozialisierter Mann,
was oft problematisch in der AfD ist, weil die oft entsprechende Mindsets mitbringen,
sag ich mal neudeutsch. Wie meint er das jetzt?
Ja, wer meint das so?
Sind das Super-Extremisten oder Leute, die sagen, nee, ich weiß, was Krieg ist?
Nee, ich glaube, das Problematische, was er daran sieht, ist,
dass Leute sind, die sagen, ich kämpfe für Amerika und Israel auch.
Ah ja, okay.
Das ist der transatlantische Faden, den sie nicht wollen.
Wir haben aber auch Probleme direkt. Das ist ja wirklich traurig.
Allen Ernstes, die NATO ist das Beste, was wir derzeit bekommen können.
Und der leitet dann natürlich die Atomwaffenforderung ganz anders ab,
als beispielsweise ein Thomas Schröhlich, der heute bei X diese Debatte intensiv
geführt hat. Ich habe das nicht selber kommentiert, ich habe aber gelesen,
Marvin Neumann hat gut dagegen gehalten, in Anführungszeichen,
aber sachlich, fachlich.
Tomasch hat das so begründet, wie ich es auch aus seiner Sicht,
ich teile diese Sicht nicht, aber ich kann sie gut nachvollziehen.
Also Tomasch hat es gut begründet, Abstand zu beiden Hegemonen,
Moskau und Washington, wobei ich eben glaube, das haben wir schon tausendmal
besprochen, Moskau ist überhaupt kein Welthegemon, Moskau ist nur noch ein Relikt alter Tage, aber egal.
Moskau ist nur noch eine Regionalmacht. Aber er begründet das wirklich in einem europäischen Sinne.
Leute wie genau, befürchte ich eher, sind so Bundeswehr und NATO sozialisiert,
unter denen ändert sich die grundlegende globale Konstellation der Geopolitik gar nicht.
Das heißt, es gibt zwei Lagern der AfD, wie wir ja auch gerade solche Lager
woanders wiederfinden.
Es gibt die einen, die sagen, Aufrüstung, Atomwaffen, ja, aber bitte transatlantische
Partnerschaft weiterhin.
Und dann gibt es die, die sagen, Aufrüsten, Atomwaffen, ja, aber bitte europäische Autonomie.
Und das kann man auch in journalistischen Kreisen und so finden und das hat
erstmal noch gar nichts mit Rechts oder AfD oder so zu tun. Das Interessante ist ja…,
Das große Aufrüstungsprojekt auf europäischer Ebene genau diese verschiedenen
Positionen irgendwie unter einen Hut bringen muss.
Es ist fast so wie mit dem Katholizismus.
Da muss auch der Petrusbruder genauso drin vorkommen wie der moderne Wortgottesdienst
mit gebartigten T-Shirts.
Also das muss alles irgendwie so verbunden werden und da ist noch ein Mütterchen,
die glaubt an Marienerscheinungen, die ständig irgendwo stattfinden und da ist
noch jemand, der sagt, aber wir brauchen auch noch Befreiungstheologie,
gut, kommt auch noch mit rein und an sich ist das aber das katholische Projekt.
Und das ist jetzt gerade das, was wir in Europa so erleben, dass alle sich so
selbst was aussuchen, für was sie gerade kämpfen.
Die für die radikale Rechte, Europäisierung, die anderen für queere Rechte,
da kämpft noch jemand, um die NATO zu besiegen.
Und jetzt müssen die auch noch Posten verteilt in Ausschüssen und Macht und überhaupt.
Es ist wirklich gerade die große Unübersichtlichkeit und immer wieder diese
Frage von der AfD hier, also von Leuten, die der AfD nahestehen,
sollen wir doch mal jetzt das positiv sehen, es wird aufgerüstet,
es kommt die Wehrpflicht.
Thomas ist genau ein Beispiel für das, was wir besprochen haben,
zu sagen, Leute, wenn sich die Chance bietet, dann greifen wir sie beim Schopf
und sagen, Wehrpflicht ja,
Milliardenetat für Panzer, für Flugzeuge, für was auch immer,
meinetwegen Atombombe, wir kehren auf Umwegen sozusagen dahin,
wo wir eigentlich hinwollen.
Oder?
Ja, aber diesen Standpunkt teile ich nicht eins zu eins, aber ich kann ihn politisch
nachvollziehen, weil ich eben weiß und auch durch Thomas Fröhlichs Texte bei X und anderswo,
weil ich weiß, dass er ein Fernziel hat, das am Ende wieder mit unserem Konkurrent
verläuft, einigermaßen, soweit es in der Rechten geht.
Bei Leuten wie Gnaug oder bei all diesen stark Bundeswehr- und NATO-Sozialisierten,
da sehe ich eben dieses gemeinsame Fernziel nicht. Das ist der essentielle Unterschied.
Bei Fröhlich weiß ich, er will anders zu einem selben Punkt kommen wie ich.
Der Streit ist also der Streit über den Weg.
Bei Leuten, die stark NATO-Sozialisiert sind, wie Gnaug, da sehe ich die Gefahr,
dass nicht mal das gemeinsame Ziel stimmt.
Was heißt das jetzt für die kommende Generation der CDU, also für die CDU nach
März, wenn sie gemeinsam zum
Beispiel Stimmen haben möchte für die Wiedereinführung der Wehrpflicht.
Für die heißt das, wir müssen die NATO-sozialisierten AfD-Politiker auf unsere
Seite ziehen, um eine Wehrpflicht einzuführen. Weil mit denen ist das nicht machbar.
Die wollen dann, die reden auch gleich wieder von Trieu, La Rochelle und über
nochmal die ganz alten Rechten und so europäischen, ethno-pluralistischen Gedanken
Und was sagt eigentlich Alain de Benoit dazu?
Das sind sehr intellektuelle Diskurse innerhalb der Rechten.
Ich glaube aber, dass das nicht das ist, was sich gerade in der AfD besonders
durchdrückt, sondern es scheint
eher das zu sein, was hier kritisiert wird von den anderen Rechten.
Und da ist tatsächlich, sehe ich jetzt für uns wiederum, die wir nicht zu den
Rechten gehören, diese große Gefahr drin,
dass das wirklich ein Aufrüstungsprojekt ist im Sinne von einem neuen rechten
Projekt mit Teilen auch der AfD und anderer Regierungen dann in Europa,
die ähnlich aufgestellt sind. Stein sagt hier.
Die Grundtendenz zu sagen, gemeinsame europäische Armee, gemeinsamer europäischer
Wirtschaftsraum, gemeinsame europäische Außengrenze.
Und so weiter und so fort ist natürlich von den Grundbegriffen genau unsere Linie.
Und wir müssen natürlich entgegenhalten, jetzt braucht man auch wieder mehr
internationale Verbindungen, man muss mehr Freihandel, man muss mehr Migration
zulassen, um sich in diese Identitätsbereiche gar nicht zu begeben.
Das war jetzt, wie du auch zu Recht schon immer gesagt hast,
bei allem, was wir heute über den Krieg so abgespielt haben, Gerede.
Jetzt gehen wir nicht ins Gerede. Ich empfehle diese Dokumentation eindringlich.
Sie ist von Frontal 21 veröffentlicht worden, knapp 30 Minuten,
hat Frontal 21 zwei Deutsche begleitet, die in der Ukraine freiwillig kämpfen
und redet auch mit Müttern.
Genau, ich kenne das nicht, aber du sagst jetzt schon zwei und wahrscheinlich
hätte es gar nicht mehr viele gegeben, du hast ja schon mal diese Zahlen genannt.
Also man sagt es seit zwei Jahren, hier wird jetzt gesagt, es sind 100,
die ukrainische Regierung sagt, es könnten 300 sein, also sehr, sehr wenige.
So, und das will ich jetzt mal kurz festhalten. Diese Leute,
die wir gerade in ihrem Podcast gehört haben, die fühlen sich gerade bestärkt,
ermächtigt, die haben so das Gefühl von dasselbe Ziel, aber plötzlich haben wir mehrere Wege.
Naja, lassen wir doch unterschiedliche Wege laufen, können wir uns doch leisten und so.
Das gelingt ihnen, weil sie, keine Ahnung, die AfD hat jetzt irgendwie 10 Millionen
Wähler oder so. Kam auf 20 Prozent.
Grob Pi mal Daumen, was bedeutet, sehr viele Leute ermächtigen und ertüchtigen
gerade solche Denksachen.
Wir können aber da sagen, von den 10 Millionen AfD-Wählern hat 10 Millionen keine Ahnung davon.
Die wissen nicht, wer hat welche Ziele, welchen Weg gehen wir hier lang.
Ach so, europäische Armee, Frankreich ist auf unserer Seite, keine Ahnung und so.
Und so ist das grundsätzlich.
Lanz redet über Bürgergeld. Die Dogeleute reden über Bürokratie.
Die hier reden über Krieg und sehen eine riesige Armee an Unterstützern hinter
sich, nämlich 10 Millionen Wähler, die irgendwie so AfD-Programmen angeblich
inhaltlich unterstützen und wissen, was die hier diskutieren.
So, und jetzt gucken wir in so eine Fernsehserie und dieser Krieg,
ist nun für die Leute, die das so sehen, seit drei Jahren die Einladung,
hier kannst du dich verwirklichen, hier kannst du ein rechter Mann sein,
hier kannst du oben ohne rumlaufen, hier gibt es keine Regeln und so weiter.
Und wir reden davon, dass da 300 Deutsche sind.
Maximal.
Die maximale Zahl. Das sind die Verhältnisse.
10 Millionen, die im Fernsehen haben, okay, AfD und so weiter.
Und dann ist Krieg 300. Jahrhundert. Ja, das sind die Zahlen.
Ja, ja. Also das muss man den Leuten sagen. Also vielleicht sieht ja auch mal
ein Jakob Lasu oder eine Sarah Bosetti sich so eine Doku an.
Würde ihnen vielleicht weiterhelfen.
Wir hören jetzt den ersten Soldaten, der nennt sich Kola, also K-O-L-A geschrieben,
also sein Kampfname und bekommen mal vorgestellt, wie er über das Ganze denkt.
Er ist da sehr abgeklärt.
Als wir in Avdivkawan haben wir auf einer Mission acht Leute verloren.
Das, wie beschreibt man das?
Beim ersten Mal war es so, oh mein Gott, mein Freund ist tot und so weiter.
Aber je mehr Leute, je mehr Freunde sterben, umso weiter tut es dich nicht mehr bedrücken.
Also zum Beispiel, ich versuche halt wirklich traurig zu sein,
aber ich kann nicht traurig sein.
Mein Kopf tut das wahrscheinlich einfach zur Seite schieben.
Das heißt so, Tod oder Töten bedrückt mich nicht mehr so, wie es am Anfang war. halt eigentlich null.
Also wir sehen hier einen unglaublichen Abstumpfungsprozess.
Du hast ja die ganze Sendung gesehen. Wird hier weiterhin deutlich,
dass er bewusst, ihm bewusst ist, dass auch über ihn dann so geredet wird?
Er kämpft hier für irgendeine höhere Sache und am Ende, naja,
die werden mich einfach, keine Ahnung, die werden nicht mehr an mich denken.
Bei ihm, ja, er sagt irgendwann mal, wir wollen ja auch nicht vergessen werden
oder so, aber bei ihm ist eine große Abstumpfung da. Wir hören ja gleich noch einen anderen.
Ich meine, der hat jetzt gesagt, da sind acht Leute gestorben.
Ja.
Acht Leute sind vier neue Zwanziger-Podcasts.
Das sind drei von diesen rechten Podcasts. Das ist einfach viel.
Also Menschen leben einfach auf, naja, acht.
Acht klingt nicht so viel. Doch, acht ist sehr viel.
Naja.
Kriegsalltag. Schwer zu verkraften. Ich weiß, dass nach dem Krieg,
und da stehe ich auch zu, werde ich Hilfe brauchen, psychologische.
Das braucht jeder hier nach Ukraine, jeder Soldat.
Und ich kann es mir eingestehen. Und ich werde mir nach dem Krieg auch die Hilfe nehmen.
Ich denke, jeder geht unterschiedlich damit um. Also bei mir ist es so,
ich denke, du hast halt keine Zeit darum zu trauern oder oh mein Gott, er ist tot.
Nicht wie in Deutschland bei der Bundeswehr, oh mein Gott, jetzt habe ich PTBS,
ich will nicht mehr leben. Das funktioniert hier nicht. Hier musst du aufstehen und weiter kämpfen.
Beste Aussichten, wir sollten sofort ein Ziel formulieren, damit wir das alle mitmachen müssen.
Ja, also es ist ganz schockierend zu sehen.
Und zwar einfach nur, weil die Wien immer sagen, das ist scheiße,
aber ich als stolzer Rechter, ich möchte das. Umso mehr jetzt.
Natürlich vergisst man die Leute nicht, aber,
ein guter Freund von mir hat mal gesagt, it is what it is. Also es ist,
wie es ist, und so ist es auch.
Laut russischer Propaganda kämpfen v.a. Nazis für die Ukraine, auch deutsche Nazis.
Kohler sagt, er sei kein Rechter. Damit habe er nichts zu tun.
In den sozialen Medien berichten Rechtsextreme immer wieder von ihrem angeblichen Einsatz in der Ukraine.
Der deutsche Verfassungsschutz stellt klar, er wisse nur von einer kleinen,
einstelligen Zahl ausgereister Rechtsextremisten.
Auch über Cola finden wir einen Bericht, der ihn in Zusammenhang mit der rechtsextremen
Gruppe Der Dritte Weg bringt.
Wir erreichen ihn Ende Dezember an der Front. Ich war nie beim 3. Weg Mitglied.
Das stimmt so nicht. Angeblich soll er auch bei den Einheiten von Asov gewesen sein.
Sie galten als nationalistisch, teils als rechtsextrem.
Ich hatte bei Asov damals nie einen Vertrag gehabt.
Das kann nicht aufgeklärt werden. Es wird angesprochen.
Jetzt kommen wir zu dem 2., der vorgestellt wird. Da weiß man auch nicht so
genau, aber ich sage mal so, der hat den Kampfnamen Odin.
Ich vermute jetzt mal, dass das auch nicht ein Queerfeminist ist, der da kämpft.
Wir hören ihn jetzt, der mit einem anderen Ton darüber spricht.
Nordöstliche Ukraine. Die Front ist gerade mal 30 Kilometer entfernt.
Hier treffen wir einen anderen Deutschen im Einsatz für die ukrainische Armee.
Kampfname Odin, 34 Jahre alt. Auch er möchte nicht erkannt werden.
Denn auf ausländische Kämpfer setzt die russische Führung ein Kopfgeld aus.
Was hat mich bewegt, in die Ukraine zu kommen? Das ist teilweise jetzt eine
gute Frage nach über zweieinhalb Jahren Kämpfen.
Ich hätte damals den Glauben gehabt, irgendwas bewirken zu können,
beziehungsweise den Menschen hier zu helfen.
Aber nach der langen Zeit lernt man wirklich eines Besseren.
Teilweise eine gute Frage nach zweieinhalb Jahren Abnutzungskrieg,
dass es doch nicht so sinnstiftend ist, da zu sein.
Ja, und ich meine, es geht jetzt uns ja nicht hier zu sagen,
da sind jetzt ein paar Rechte in der Ukraine, sondern zu sagen,
das ist jetzt auch wirklich mal dokumentiert, der Alltag von Soldaten an der Front.
Und wir sehen dann auch da private Aufnahmen von ihm, die er mit dem Helm oder
so gemacht hat. Hier mal so eine kleine Impression.
Im Dickicht muss er darauf achten, nicht auf eine Mine zu treten.
Ein Kamerad geht vor. Er kenne den Weg besser. You know the way better.
Wir müssen aus der Baumreihe raus, weil die vermint worden ist von den Russen.
Die setzen da auch so eine Art Zweidermin ein.
Das sind wirklich so kleine Kanister, die von Drohner geknissen werden.
Und dann kommen jede Menge Minen raus, die verbunden sind mit einem Draht.
Der Draht ist aber so dünn, dass man den wirklich echt auf die letzte Sekunde ersehen kann.
Und wenn man den dann in Kontakt hat, dann explodieren halt die Minen.
Und das ist halt mit eigentlich der Most Killer jetzt bei uns an der Ecke mit den FPV-Drohnen.
Das heißt, du stolperst über ein Draht und wirst zerfetzt. Das ist die Situation da für 100.000.
Ich meine, die machen ja im Grunde Social Distancing. Die müssen ja immer 10
Meter Abstand halten, falls ja doch den Weg nicht so genau Ja.
Das ist ganz so. Und jetzt, wir alle haben im Westen nichts Neues gesehen.
Und das ist, was er berichtet.
Es hieß, dass eine Straße schon gesäubert worden ist. So nennen sie das die
Ukrainer, wirklich gesäubert von russischen Soldaten.
Ich bin um eine Hausdecke rum
und 1,50 Meter, 2 Meter vor mir stand auf einmal ein russischer Soldat.
Ich denke mal, es war einer, der sich verirrt hat oder versprengt war.
Er hat hektisch nach seiner Waffe gegriffen. Ich habe nach meiner Waffe gegriffen,
nur ich habe ihm sein Leben nehmen müssen, weil er wollte auf mich schießen.
Ich habe auf ihn geschossen, er ist zu Boden gegangen, aber ich habe ihn trotzdem
mit Respekt, stand ich ihm bei in seinem Todeskampf.
Also ich stand da noch mit ihm, habe seine Hand gehalten und er ist dann auch
direkt vor mir verstorben.
Ich habe Mitleid auch mit diesen Männern, weil für mich sind das keine Feinde,
für mich sind das auch Menschen.
Ja,
genau das sehen wir ja im Westen nichts Neues auch und das zeigt eben wieder,
warum auch eine Staatskritik wichtig ist, denn da stehen sich Staaten gegenüber,
aber die Menschen verbindet eigentlich etwas, was man hier an dieser Schilderung
ja bestens erleben kann.
Und das sind irgendwelche abstrakten Startzielen, die sie sich unterordnen müssen.
Und die bedeuten dann für den einen den Tod und für den anderen eben seelische Qualen.
Und ja, so endet die Doku.
Wir haben ein Jahr lang für diesen Film recherchiert. Gerade zu Odin hat sich
ein Vertrauensverhältnis aufgebaut. Er wollte seine Geschichte loswerden.
Dann erreicht uns plötzlich eine WhatsApp-Nachricht. Odin will aufhören mit
dem Krieg und nach Berlin reisen. Es gehe ihm schlecht.
Wir verabreden uns mit einem Seelsorger der Bundeswehr und warten an einem Berliner
Busbahnhof. Doch Odin kommt nicht.
Zwei Tage vergehen, bevor wir aus der Ukraine erfahren, warum.
Odin, der eigentlich Michael heißt, ist tot. Er soll sich in Kharkiv mit einer
Handgranate selbst das Leben genommen haben. nach zweieinhalb Jahren Krieg als
deutscher Soldat in der Ukraine.
Ja, also der ganze Film ist wahr.
Ja. Man muss das unbedingt gucken. Also absolute Empfehlung.
Und dann kann man ja nochmal über Wehrpflicht und wer will dann mal heldenhaft
für irgendwas oder ja, aber die Menschenrechte und die Demokratie,
die verteidigt ihr doch gerade da und so weiter.
Also das ist wirklich der Film.
Das würde ich noch machen. Staatskritik schon gut. Frieden ist auch Staat.
Ja, natürlich. Genau. Aber das Verhältnis wird ja da ein, sagen wir,
heikles, wenn der Staat plötzlich ein Ziel formuliert, dass er dann glaubt,
nur militärisch erreichen zu können.
Und dem darf man sich eben nicht unterordnen.
Aber so wenig, wie es eine Alternative
zur Bürokratie gibt und so nah wie Bürokratie und Staat sind...
Und Staatskritik muss halt innerhalb des Staates, so wie jedes Gerede nur innerhalb der Gesellschaft.
Man kann mit der Gesellschaft sehr unzufrieden sein.
Die Staaten sind ja auch erstmal da.
Das kommt noch dazu, wir haben es mit einem empirischen Faktum zu tun.
Die Sache ist nur, dass wir ja hier in diesen Ausnahmezuständen ja auch erleben
und dieser SPD-Politiker und andere haben es ja dann auch so formuliert,
dann ist halt einfach Zwang. Da muss man einfach.
Und genau dem muss man sich, glaube ich, jetzt vehement widersetzen,
dass ein solches Staatsverständnis nicht plötzlich als it is what it is angenommen wird.
Absolut, absolut. Aber der Staat ist nicht nur Gewalt und nicht nur Zwang,
sondern auch Frieden, Freiheit, Kino, Schule, Essen auf dem Tisch.
Wenn gleich ich mir auch Welten vorstellen kann, denen es Kinos aber keine Staaten gibt.
Ich nicht. Da habe ich zu viel Soziologie studiert.
Ja, ja.
Und zu wenig Literatur gelesen.
Nur werde ich für das Kino nicht in, also ich gehe in den Kampf jedes Mal mit
der Filmanalyse, aber ich gehe nicht in ein Schlachtfeld für das Kino.
Sehr gut.
Gut, ja, düsterer Monat.
Ja, aber...
Der letzte März im Frieden.
Nein, eben solche, genau in diesen Wahn darf man sich einfach nicht bringen
lassen von diesen Leuten.
Und ich hoffe, dass vielleicht ein paar Journalisten den Mut haben und da ein
bisschen stärker mal dagegen sind.
Und damit meine ich jetzt nicht, in Talkshow sieben Leute einladen und einer
ist auch tatsächlich mal gegen die Wehrpflicht, Sondern es bedeutet eigentlich
mal, sich selbst nochmal zu befragen.
Ist das also die Perspektive, die man haben möchte?
Ist das also der große freiheitliche Kampf, den wir da gerade sehen,
wenn am Ende jemand sagt, ich halte das nicht mehr aus und ziehe die Handgranate,
um mich selbst in die Luft zu sprengen?
Das ist eigentlich der Punkt, den man erkennen müsste, dann hat man eine leise Ahnung davon,
was eigentlich Krieg bedeutet und was da irgendwelche Leute aus Berlin-Mitte
in Podcasts oder in ihren Influencer-Kanälen loslassen von Solidarität, ist einfach nur bla bla.
Ich möchte zum Schluss gegen das Blabla vorschlagen, was man im Wortlaut sagen
könnte in beliebigen politischen Diskussionen.
Je nach Abstufung kann man sich das aussuchen. Der eine Wortlaut lautet, keine gute Idee.
Der nächste Wortlaut, den man anbringen kann, ist, nee, schlechte Idee.
Und man kann auch noch sagen, also das halte ich für eine ganz schlechte Idee,
oder eben, nee, ich bin gegen Katastrophe.
Funktioniert immer und man hat immer recht, das ist das Gute.
Die anderen können ja dann erklären, ja?
Genau.
Die anderen können dann erklären. Wenn jemand unbedingt kämpfen will,
gerne mal erklären, was meinst du jetzt mit Kampf?
Faustkampf, schießen, große Waffe, kleine Waffe, aus dem fahrenden Auto heraus
oder muss ich da anhalten oder wie auch immer, die können das dann erklären.
Aber man kann selber erstmal sagen, Keine gute Idee. Nee, ich bin dagegen.
Gut, wir sehen uns dann zum Salon wieder.
Dann geht es nicht so sehr um diese knallharte Politik, sondern da geht es um
unsere Gefühle in anderer Weise. Mood Machine, The Rise of Spotify and the Cost
of the Perfect Playlist von Liz Pelly.
Das ist das Buch, das wir gemeinsam lesen werden.
Das heißt, wir diskutieren ja dann immer so anderthalb Stunden darüber.
Und dann bringen wir noch wichtige Texte und Bücher aus dem Monat mit.
Und ich will noch nichts groß ankündigen, außer einen Roman,
den ich auf jeden Fall besprechen muss, denke ich.
Nämlich Christian Kracht hat einen neuen Roman geschrieben und natürlich will
ich ihn jetzt lesen und werde dann erzählen, ob es sich lohnt,
was uns Kracht eigentlich noch zu erzählen hat.
Denn er ist natürlich der Autor eigentlich der Generation Poschert gewesen.
Die sind ja Faserland, das ist ja deren Text, auf dem sie einen ganzen Lifestyle begründet haben.
Was sagt also dieser Autor jetzt im Jahr 2025?
Das interessiert mich.
Vielleicht gucke ich mal in Poschardt rein.
Ach, dieses Buch von Poschardt, ja.
Shitbürgertum oder wie es heißt? Schildbürgertum.
Ich krame nochmal raus, diesen Text über Podcast schneller hören macht klüger, wegen dieser Aussage.
Human hat diesen Text zusammengestellt, wir werden also mal so richtig KI generierte
Texte und ihre Herstellungsweise, auch weil es mich interessiert,
Human muss mir das nochmal erklären,
im Detail, ich saß zwar neben ihm vier Stunden lang, als er seinen Text zusammengeklüppelt
hat, aber im Saal auch dann Aufklärung dazu.
Und darüber hinaus weiß ich, selten war meine Leseliste so lang.
Also mal sehen, es wird ein sehr interessanter Salon. Und ich habe auch was Neues.
Da rede ich dann im Salon drüber. Neue Form zu lesen. Ich habe neue technische
Unterstützung, von der ich mir diesmal wieder sehr viel verspreche.
Du brauchst dringend noch einen weiteren Bildschirm hier oder so.
Erstaunlicherweise kein Bildschirm.
Okay, ich bin gespannt. Also wer uns dann erleben will im Salon,
wenn wir über all das sprechen, kann uns abonnieren. Das ist ganz leicht.
Am besten geht man auf die neue 20er-Seite, dort auf den goldenen Button,
kommt dann zu Steady und kann ein Monatsabo abschließen.
Drei Euro kostet das. Und dann hat man auch die alten Folgen parat.
Patreon, wer schon ohnehin dort angemeldet ist, kann natürlich auch das nutzen.
Und die Apple-Kunden sehen das ohnehin jetzt, wenn sie auf ihr Smartphone blicken oder wie ist das?
Naja, bei Apple ploppt ja eh alles auf. Und das betrifft dann den Salon demnächst,
der dann auch bei Steady einfach schon mit auftaucht und so weiter.
Man hat aber dann auch, wenn man da den Salon ankreuzt, wenn man das dann bucht,
dann kann man auch die anderen natürlich hören.
Genau, in der Hoffnung, dass es wirklich so funktioniert wie angekündigt,
ein Feed, in dem alles drin ist.
Also da ist es noch einfacher jetzt.
Apropos Webseite. Die Podcast-Webseite wird irgendwann nochmal neu gemacht.
Ich habe jetzt ein bisschen Zeit und ich habe jetzt auf meiner Webseite auch Termine.
Also jetzt im April 2 Karlsruhe und Wien, die kann man auf meiner Webseite nachlesen,
denn ich habe jetzt endlich den Weg gefunden, dass ich einen ganz normalen Kalender
führe, der einfach auf der Webseite ausgelesen wird.
Also ich dieses ganze Gefriemel, jetzt die Webseite ändern und der Kram und so.
Ab sofort gibt es Termine, sehr einfach übersichtlich.
Dann sehen wir uns bald im Salon.
So ist es, bis dahin.